GOOD MORNING WE'LL START
TODAY'S HEARING ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE -- ON EDUCATION
FINANCE AT TODAY'S HEARINGS
THE MISCELLANEOUS -- HEARING
OUR FINAL ONE WAS SENT HIGHER
ED STATE LIBRARY FINANCIALLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THAT
CITY AS WELL AS FUTURE ISSUES
WITH THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AT TODAY'S OF
COURSE AS ALWAYS THAT SOCIALLY
DISTANCE HEARING WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
TO PARTICIPATE -- REMOTELY
LATER ON AS WELL -- SO WITH
THAT -- WE WILL PROCEED WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE EDUCATOR
PREPARATION AND PIPELINE
GOOD MORNING JIM LEAHY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
-- THE DEMANDS ON EDUCATORS
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAVE BEEN INTENSE
AND UNPRECEDENTED LEADING TO
CHANGES THAT HAVE EXACERBATED
EXISTING EDUCATOR SHORTAGES
THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF WELL PREPARED TEACHERS
IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
HEY WELL PREPARED EDUCATED
WORK FORCES A SIGNIFICANT
FACTOR IN IMPROVING STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT HAVING CLOSING
THE PANDEMIC OF STUDENTS DEAL
WITH THE LONG TERM ACADEMIC
IMPACTS OF COVERT NINETEEN
GIVEN THESE CHALLENGES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH NEW OR
EXPANDING EXISTING TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN
DESIGNATED SHORTAGE FIELDS
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME PROPOSITION SHE'S ME ONE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR A TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND TWENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR -- CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE WHAT A TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT AT LEAST ONE THOUSAND
FORTY ONE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
EARNING A TEACHING CREDENTIAL
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN VERY WELL RECEIVED BY
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
AND HAVE UNMET DEMAND THAT
THERE IS CLAMORING TO RECEIVE
MORE FUNDING IN ADDITION THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE INCENTIVE GRANTS FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO ENTER A
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM AND
EARNED A TEACHING CREDENTIAL
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU -- GABRIELA
CHÁVEZ DEPARTMENT FINANCE
HI GOOD MORNING AS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOVERNMENT CHÁVEZ WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
WILL KEEP MY COMING SHORT AS
INDICATED IN THE AYE CHAN THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES SUPPORT
PROGRAMS TO STUDENTS AND
BUILDING TEACHER CREDENTIAL
PROGRAMS -- COULD COME MEET TO
BE WORKING AND HIGHFIELD SCHOOL
SITES WITH THE HIGHEST RATE OF
NON CREDENTIAL OR WAIT TEACHERS
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS TRAVIS -- JAKE
BRIMMER BREMNER FROM CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADAM THANK YOU -- J.
PARTNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S DEBATE COMMISSION
AND WE WELCOME THIS NEW
INVESTMENT IN THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM
IS TO MAKE COMMISSION IS BEEN
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INITIATE THIS NEW FORM OF
SUPPORT FOR ASPIRING EDUCATORS
AND THEY CONTRIBUTE TOWARD
EXPANDING OUR TEACHER WORKFORCE
PIPELINE AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALS FOLLOWING THE
REDIRECTION OF STATE FUNDING
INITIALLY ALLOCATED TOWARDS
PROGRAM -- AND THE TWENTY
TWENTY ALLOCATION OF FEDERAL
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EDUCATION ACT FUNDING THIS
TO MADE COMMISSION MOVE TO
SHIFT OUR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS PROGRAM TO FOCUS ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS ALSO NOTED
IN YOUR AGENDA MATERIALS THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION HAS
RECEIVED APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY APPLICATIONS
FROM STUDENTS INDICATING
-- THAT THEY'LL PURSUE A
SPECIAL A CREDENTIAL IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION THIS DO
NEED COMMISSIONS VERIFIED AND
VALIDATED APPLICANTS SPECIAL
EDUCATION CREDENTIALS WITH
THEIR INSTITUTIONS AND OBTAINS
TEACHING AGREEMENTS FROM
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS HOWEVER THE
COMMISSION HAS NOT YET BEEN
ABLE TO DISPERSE AWARDS TO
ELIGIBLE STUDENT APPLICANTS
ADDS I'M WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
FINALIZE THEIR APPROVAL ON AN
INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT THAT WAS
NECESSARY DUE TO THE USE OF ID
EA FUNDING FOR THESE AWARDS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
JUST FINALIZED AND SENT THAT
AGREEMENT TO THE STEAMING FROM
CHANNEL LAST WEEK WE ANTICIPATE
ITS FINAL SIGNING AND EXECUTION
-- WITHIN THIS WEEK -- I
HOPE TODAY -- THIS DO NEED
COMMISSION WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE APPLICATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE REMAINDER OF THE YEAR BUT
ESTIMATES THAT IT IS UNLIKELY
THAT WE WOULD EXTINGUISH THE
ENTIRE FIFTEEN BILLION IN THIS
YEAR AND REMAINING FUNDS WOULD
BE UTILIZED TOWARDS ADDITIONAL
AWARDS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO ACADEMIC YEAR
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT THAT WE
ANTICIPATE AWARDING TOWARDS
APPLICANTS THIS YEAR WOULD
BE APPROXIMATELY SEVEN POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR THE ONE POINT
FIVE PERCENT THAT ASIDE FOR
THIS TO MAKE COMMISSIONS
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM
AND RELATED OUTREACH EFFORT
THERE WOULD BE A REMAINING
BALANCE OF AT LEAST A SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
SIMILAR TO OTHER -- TEACHING
GRANT PROGRAMS RECIPIENTS OF
THE GOLDEN STATE YOUR GRANT
AWARDS WILL NEED TO PROVIDE
VERIFICATION OF EVERY YEAR
TAUGHT AT A TARGETED SCHOOL
SITE AND RECIPIENTS MUST TEACH
FOUR OUT OF FIVE YEARS -- AFTER
COMPLETING THE PROGRAM AND
THE STUDENT COMMITMENT WILL
BE FOLLOWING UP TO RECEIVE THE
FULL FOUR YEARS A VERIFICATION
-- AND THAT FORM IS IT'S STILL
UNDER DEVELOPMENT AS WE'VE NOT
YET SEEN THE FIRST -- COURT
AND TEACHERS ENTER OTHER SCHOOL
SITES SO -- WITH THAT ALL
STOP THEIR -- IT ON THE THIRTY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU MR BREMNER -- DOCTOR
MERRY VECSEY SANDY COMMISSION
ON TEACHING CREDENTIALING
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN JUST BY PROVIDING A
LITTLE CONTEXT AROUND THAT OF
A ROMAN TRANSCRIPTIONAL AND
CREDENTIALS SUPPLIED THE MAN --
ENROLLMENT IN TEACHER EDUCATION
EXPERIENCED A FOUR PERCENT DROP
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FOLLOWING SEVERAL YEARS
OF GROWTH DURING THAT SAME
YEAR THE NUMBERS OF TEACHING
CREDENTIALS ISSUED INCREASED
BY THREE PERCENT HOWEVER DUE TO
CHRONIC AND ONGOING SHORTAGES
THE COMMISSION ISSUED FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO MORE
INTERN CREDENTIALS EMERGENCY
PERMITS AND WAIVERS THAT FULL
TEACHING CREDENTIALS THIS
IMBALANCE IS EVEN WORSE IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE'RE ALMOST
TWO THOUSAND MORE INTERNAL
CREDENTIALS EMERGENCY PERMITS
AND WAIVERS WERE ISSUED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THAN FULL SPECIAL EDUCATION
CREDENTIALS THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT STATE INVESTMENTS
IN TEACHER RECRUITMENT ARE
DRAWING MORE TEACHERS INTO
PREPARATION AND TEACHING AND
INCREASING DIVERSITY IN THE
TEACHING WORKFORCE OTHER GOOD
NEWS IS THAT WE HEAR FROM THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMUNITY
THAT CANDIDATE APPLICATIONS
FOR ENROLLMENT IN TEACHER
EDUCATION WENT UP THIS YEAR AND
ARE ALSO UP FOR NEXT YEAR WE
BELIEVE THIS SEARCH MAY BE DUE
IN PART TO FLEXIBILITY AROUND
IT MISSION SIX EXAMINATIONS
RACIAL PROGRAM CAPACITY HOWEVER
MAY BE INSUFFICIENT TO ADMIT
THE NUMBERS OF CANDIDATES
APPLYING FOR ENROLLMENT SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO KEEP AN EYE ON AS WE LOOK
TO THE FUTURE IN TERMS OF
AREAS -- IN WHICH DEMAND THAT
-- FOR NEW TEACHERS APPEARS
TO BE GROWING I DISTRICTS
ARE REPORTING ANNUALLY ABOUT
THE NEED FOR TWENTY THOUSAND
MORE NEW TEACHERS AROUND
THIRTY PERCENT OF THOSE ARE IN
MULTIPLE SUBJECT AREAS TWENTY
PERCENT IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
SIXTEEN PERCENT IN THE STEM
FIELDS JUST UNDER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION HAS BEEN INVESTED IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS OF THESE
FUNDS ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE
TEN MILLION FOR UNDERGRADUATE
PATHWAYS TWENTY FIFTY MILLION
FOR LOCAL SOLUTIONS GRANTS
FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR A
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PROGRAM
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM
AND FIFTY ONE MILLION FOR THE
TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAM --
ITSELF THIRTY SEVEN GRANTS HAVE
BEEN ISSUED TO DATE TO LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES PARTNERING
WITH TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS AT AROUND TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY RESIDENTS OF WORLD
LAST YEAR JUST UNDER HALF OF
THEM IN SPECIAL EDUCATION A
THIRD IN STEM FIELDS AND TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT SEEKING BILINGUAL
CERTIFICATION SEVENTY PERCENT
COMPLETED THEIR PROGRAMS LAST
YEAR ARRESTER AN EIGHTEEN
MONTH PROGRAMS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND SEVENTY PERCENT
OF THEM THEY'VE IDENTIFIED
AS PEOPLE OF COLOR OF THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE ALLOWING US
TO ADDRESS SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM NEEDS FUNDING TO DATE AND
PROPOSED FOR THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO OF FISCAL YEAR WILL
PROVIDE FOR ALMOST FIFTEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS TO EARN
FULL TEACHING CREDENTIALS AND
HELP US TO ADDRESS THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE UNDERGRADUATE AND
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS ARE GROWING
CRITICAL STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
BY ESTABLISHING STABLE PATHWAYS
INTO TEACHING RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS IN PARTICULAR ARE
HELPING TO DEVELOP LDA CAPACITY
TO DEVELOP THEIR OWN TEACHERS
AND THESE PROGRAMS HAVE VERY
STRONG POTENTIAL TO CONTINUE
TO INCREASE THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR TEACHING WORKFORCE
I THINK I'LL CLOSE THERE IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY
OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
ADMINISTERING WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER THOSE AND WE ENTHUSING
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THANK YOU
FOR THAT IN THROUGH THE ASPIC
SUPPORT -- WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THE QUESTIONS UNTIL THE
END OF ALL THE PRESENTATIONS
THANK YOU DOCTOR SANDY
-- ELLIE GARDNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THANK
YOU ALEXANDER AND YOU HAVE THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION MANY OF THE TEACHER
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
PROGRAMS ARE ADMINISTERED
THREE CTC BUT THE CITY IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THESE INVESTMENTS
IN OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
EDUCATION WORKFORCE TEACHERS
ARE OUR GREATEST ASSET IN
CLOSING THE OPPORTUNITY GAP AND
WE NEED TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
OUR BEST AND BRIGHTEST TEACHERS
SPECIFICALLY WE NEED TO MAKE
INROADS FOR MALE TEACHERS OF
COLOR AND TEACHERS IN THE FIELD
OF SCIENCE MATH AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION JUST TWO QUICK
ITEMS TO HIGHLIGHT TO SHOW
THE MEANINGFUL IMPACT THESE
PROGRAMS ONE IS THAT EARLY
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS HAVE MORE
THAN DOUBLED THE PROPORTION
OF TEACHER CANDIDATES OF
COLOR WHEN COMPARED TO THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR TEACHER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IT ALSO
SHOWS THAT TEACHERS PREPARED
IN A RESIDENCY PROGRAM STATE OR
ARE RETAINED AT THEIR SCHOOLS
AND IN THE TEACHING PROFESSION
AT HIGHER RATES PARTICULARLY
IN SCHOOLS WITH HISTORICALLY
HIGH TEACHER TURNOVER RATES
IN ADDITION THE CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL AS A
AS A PATHWAY INTO THE TEACHING
PROFESSION ESPECIALLY FOR
EDUCATORS OF COLOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE ROLES
THESE PROGRAMS PLAYING AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU MS GARDNER -- ANY LEAD
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS A
NEARLY WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE
WANTED TO SHARE OUR ASSESSMENT
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S TEACHER RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION PROPOSALS
STARTING WITH THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANTS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION POP NINETY EIGHT FOR
ADDITIONAL GRANTS TO ESTABLISH
NEW AND EXPAND EXISTING TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS JUST AS
A QUICK REMINDER TEACHER
RESIDENCIES BORROWED FROM
THE MEDICAL RESIDENCY MODEL
WE'RE TEACHER CANDIDATES TEACH
ALONGSIDE A MENTOR TEACHER
FOR AT LEAST ONE HALF THE TIME
WHILE PURSUING COURSEWORK THE
LEGISLATURE FIRST ESTABLISH A
TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANT PROGRAM
AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
INTERSEGMENT WE FOUND THAT
TEACHER RESIDENCY MODEL MAY
IMPROVE TEACHER PREPARATION
BUT CAN BE CHALLENGING TO
INITIATE AND SUSTAIN FOR
INSTANCE THE DISTRICTS WE SPOKE
TO MENTION ISSUES ESTABLISHING
A RELIABLE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE UNIVERSITY PROVIDING
THE COURSE WORK ATTRACTING
RESIDENTS TO THE PROGRAMS IN
FINDING SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
AFTER THEIR GRANDPARENTS
ADDITIONALLY CDC WAS ONLY
ABLE TO AWARD TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION OUT OF THE FIFTEEN
MILLION ALLOCATED FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION IN THE INITIAL
FUNDING ROUND THEIR MEANING
TO FUNDS WERE SWEPT AS PART
OF THE STATE'S COPING NINETEEN
RESPONSE IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET DUE TO THESE REASONS
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED AND REDUCED AMOUNT
OF FIFTEEN MILLION FOR THE
TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANT THIS
AMOUNT REFLECTS THE AMOUNT
THAT CDC HAS BEEN ABLE TO
AWARD TO DATE AND THE LIKELY
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE PROGRAMS THAT MIGHT
DAMPEN INTEREST MOVING ONTO
THE CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL PROGRAM THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO PROVIDE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION PROP
NINETY EIGHT FOR ADDITIONAL
GRANTS TO SUPPORT CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES TO PURSUE
THEIR TEACHING CREDENTIAL
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES INCLUDE
TEACHERS AIDES BUS DRIVERS
CAFETERIA WORKERS OFFICE
WORKERS ELIGIBLE PARTICIPANTS
WOULD RECEIVE UP TO TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS UNDER THE POLLS ALL WE
FIND OF A CLASSIFIED PROGRAM
IS IN HIGH DEMAND AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY SEVEN APPLICATIONS FROM
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION WERE UNFUNDED
FROM THE FIRST TWO FUNDING
ROUNDS SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
IN SUPPORT OF OF THE PROGRAM
AND CONSIDER IT A LONG TERM
GROW YOUR OWN WHICH RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION STRATEGY HOWEVER
IT A CLASSIFIED PROGRAM DOES
NOT APPEAR TO BE TARGETED
TO SCHOOLS MOST AFFECTED
BY TEACHER SHORTAGES IN OUR
ANALYSIS WE FOUND THAT OF
THE TWENTY THREE DISTRICTS
THAT APPLIED INDIVIDUALLY
SEVEN HAD LOWER SHARES OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
ON EMERGENCY CREDENTIALS
COMPARED TO STATEWIDE AVERAGE
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE PROPOSED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION TO THE CLASSIFIED
PROGRAMS THAT ALSO INCLUDE
CHANGES THAT WOULD PRIORITIZE
AND TARGET DISTRICTS MOST
AFFECTED BY TEACHER SHORTAGES
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH HOW
THE STATE FUNDS -- MOST OTHER
TEACHER WORKFORCE INITIATIVES
LAST WEEK MOVING ON TO THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANTS
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO
PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
NOT A PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR ADDITIONAL
GRANTS AT THIS TIME AND THE
FIRST ROUND OF GOLDEN C.
TEACHER GRANTS HAS NOT YET
BEEN AWARDED WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO MEASURE THE IMPACT
OF THIS PROGRAM ON TEACHER
SUPPLY FOR THIS REASON WE
CONSIDER AN ADDITIONAL ROUND
OF FUNDING TO THE PROGRAM
TO BE SOMEWHAT PREMATURE
FURTHERMORE THE IMPACT OF THIS
PROGRAM AND ADDRESSING THE
RECRUITMENT CHALLENGES THAT LOW
INCOME SCHOOLS MAY EXPERIENCE
MAYBE WHEN IT FIRST THERE IS
NO GUARANTEE THAT A TEACHER
CANDIDATE WILL ULTIMATELY TEACH
AT A LOW INCOME SCHOOL OR BE
ABLE TO KEEP BACKGROUND FUNDING
IF THEY ARE UNABLE TO MEET THE
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS AND SOME
OF THESE FACTORS MAY SIMPLY BE
OUT OF THE TEACHERS CONTROL THE
VICTIM IS OF THIS FUNDING AS A
RECRUITMENT INCENTIVE IS ALSO
LIMITED SINCE SOME TEACHERS
WOULD HAVE TAUGHT AT A LOW
INCOME SCHOOL EVEN WITHOUT THE
GRANT FUNDING LAST WEEK SCHOOLS
TARGETED UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
HAVE RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING FROM THE THREE FEDERAL
KOPET NINETEEN RELIEF PACKAGES
TOTALING TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA GIVEN
THE FLEXIBILITY OVER THESE
FINE SCHOOLS HAVE A BROAD
RANGE OF OPTIONS TO HIRE
AND RETAIN QUALIFIED PREPARE
TEACHERS INCLUDING PROVIDING
TEACHERS SERVICE AWARD SIGNING
BONUSES OR STUDENT DEBT
PAYMENTS MUSIC PURCHASED ME
BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO LOCAL
NEEDS THAN DOUBLE THE STATE'S
FUTURE GRANTS PARTY'S REASONS
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE GULF GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROPOSAL SHOULD
THE LEGISLATURE BE INTERESTED
IN INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS FOR TEACHERS WE
SUGGEST FOCUSING EFFORTS ON
EXPANDING THE TOTAL SUPPLY
OF TEACHERS IN SHORTAGE AREAS
FOR INSTANCE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD INSTEAD TARGET FUNDING TO
EXPAND ENROLLMENT IN INTEGRATED
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS
AT THE UNDERGRADUATE LEVEL THIS
ALLOWS EIGHTY UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS TO PURSUE A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL ON SITE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN FOUR YEARS MANY
OTHER STATES CURRENTLY OFFER
THIS ROUTE INTO TEACHING UNDER
THIS APPROACH THE STATE COULD
INCREASE THE TOTAL SUPPLY OF
TEACHERS BY ENCOURAGING MORE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS TO
PURSUE TEACHING AND A HIGH
NEED SUBJECT AREA WHEN THEY
MIGHT HAVE OTHERWISE RECEIVED
ANOTHER PROFESSION WITH THAT
I WILL CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU LESLIE
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
RIGHT LET ME ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS THEM FIRST ONE
IS OR WHY THE CHANGE IN
THE DEFINITION OF PRIORITY
SCHOOLS TO CONCENTRATION GRANT
SCHOOLS OVER SCHOOLS WITH
HIGH PERCENTAGES OF TEACHERS
WITH EMERGENCY PERMITS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION CONCERNED THAT
THIS POLICY CHANGE COULD PUSH
THE LEAST EXPERIENCED TEACHERS
INTO STRUGGLING SCHOOLS
FOR
COMMITTEE MAJORITY LEADER
-- COVER LIKE CHÁVEZ BUT
THE BOMBING OF FINANCED THE
CHANGING THE DEFINITION AND
-- WAS THE BECAUSE THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE THE VICE A PRIORITY
SCHOOL A ONCE THAT HAS AT
LEAST ONE OF THE REPRESENTED
TO CHECK OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD TO BETTER CAPTURE
THE INTENT FOR THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO CHANGE THE DEFINITION TO
BE TIED TO SCHOOLS WITH AT
LEAST FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF
HIGH NEED STUDENTS AND THIS
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND
DEFINITIONS ARE MOVING TO
DECIDE CHANGE -- -- TO A
FIFTY FIVE PERCENT FESTIVAL
WILL ESTIMATE THE GOAL OF
INCREASING THE STATEWIDE SUPPLY
ON YOUR SECOND QUESTION --
THE GROUND -- BACKGROUND
PROGRAM HAS CURRICULUM AND
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS IF
THE STUDENT DOESN'T COMPLY WITH
THE CURRICULUM OR CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS THE CITY WILL HAVE
TO PAY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
THE TOTAL RECEIVED GRANTS AND
ONLY UP TO A FULL REPLACEMENT
FOR EACH YEAR THAT THE STUDENT
FAILS TO MEET THE SPECIFIED
REQUIREMENTS THIS POLICY
FOCUSES ON PROVIDING GRANTS
INCENTIVES FOR PROFESSIONALS
TO SERVE IN PRIORITY SCHOOLS
WILL BE GRANTED OFFER
STUDENTS A DISTURBANCE NEED
TO COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATION
SUCCESSFULLY PASS THE STATE
FARM HAS REQUIREMENTS AND
ULTIMATELY APPLY IN THE
HIGH BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THANK YOU MISTRAS
MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO ASK YOU A QUESTION YOU FOR
FILLING AND LYFT ATTEMPT OUT
REAL QUICK IN THIS INTERESTING
JOB WE HAVE SOMETIMES --
YES IF YOU COULD -- JUST GO
DOWN THE LIST AND HELP US
UNDERSTAND -- BUT MORE ABOUT
THE GOALS TAKE GRANTEES AND
AND THE COMPLETION ISSUES AS
WELL AS GET INTO THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AS WELL
AND CHECK A RELIC CHÁVEZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- THAT
KARIM A REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
PROGRAM IS THAT THERE'S STUDENT
MUST BE ENROLLED IN A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM AB MUST HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPETED AT THE
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM
APPROVED BY THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING
I WILL NEVER ROLLED INTO
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM
THE STUDENT MUST MAINTAIN
A GOOD ACADEMIC STANDING UP
ON COMPLETION OF THE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM AT THE
STUDENT WAS SATISFIED THE STATE
BASIC SQL PROFICIENCY TEST
REQUIREMENTS IN CURRENT LONG
AND MUST COMPLETE THE REQUIRED
TEACHING SERVICE FOLLOWING
COMPLETION OF THE RECIPIENTS
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM
OKAY THE NEXT ABOUT THE M.
THE DEMAND FOR THE
TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAM
YES HELLO GOOD MORNING -- SO
THE COMMISSION -- YOU SHOULD R.
F. P. LAST YEAR TO EXPAND ITS
REMAINING FUNDS FOR RESIDENCY
GRANTS WE RECEIVED SEVENTEEN
LETTERS AT THAT TIME -- LETTERS
OF INTENT TO APPLY AND THAT
WAS JUST PRIOR TO THE FUNDING
BEING SWEPT BACK INTO THE
BUDGET SO WE IN ADDITION TO
THOSE SEVENTEEN ELLIE GAYS THAT
WERE INTERESTED IN APPLYING
FOR THESE FUNDS HI WE BELIEVE
THERE WERE MORE -- EVALUATIONS
BY WEST ED IN THE LEARNING
POLICY INSTITUTE REPORTS
ARE -- ARE HIGHLIGHTING THE
SUCCESS OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
GETTING TESTIMONIALS FROM THE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE OPERATING
THEM THERE'S MORE AND MORE
GOOD NEWS EMERGING FROM THIS
INVESTMENT IN THIS DEVELOPMENT
I AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
IS GOING TO BE COMPELLING FOR
OTHER DISTRICTS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO GET ON BOARD WITH THIS
WORK MMHM SO THE THE ONE OF
THE OTHER QUESTIONS THAT WAS
RAISED IN THE AGENDA HAD TO DO
WITH WHETHER OR NOT ONE TIME
FUNDS ARE HELPFUL IN POINT OF
FACT THERE ARE HELPFUL BUT A
PARTICULARLY IF THEY COULD BE
EXPENDED OVER SEVERAL YEARS ARE
WE DO BELIEVE THAT CONTINUOUS
FUNDING IS NECESSARY IF WE
WANT TO AGGRESSIVELY ADDRESS
THE STATE'S DEEPENING TEACHER
SHORTAGES ON THEN WE WOULD
AGREE WITH -- THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE LEGEND UNLISTED
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS DO TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO DEVELOP
AT THE START OF BUT THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE DEVELOPING
A FULL TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAM ARE APPLYING ADAPTING
IT TO AN ALLEY A CONTEXT ON
THE AVAILABILITY OF FUNDS TO
BUILD CAPACITY IS EXTREMELY
HELPFUL AND NECESSARY
REALLY TO TO BUILD OUT THIS
PROGRAM ACROSS THE STATE
-- PHILANTHROPIC FUNDS HAVE
BEEN USED TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHER RESIDENCY
LAB WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A
COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE THAT
IS INVOLVING ALL OF THE
GRANTEES IN OPPORTUNITIES TO
WORK TOGETHER TO SHARE THEIR
SUCCESSES TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
AND CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE
FACING -- AND WE BELIEVE THAT
IS ANOTHER KEY DRIVER TO --
EXPAND THE SUCCESS OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND WE WE HOPE THE
DEMAND FOR THESE PROGRAMS
OKAY I WANT TO SWITCH HERE TO
THE -- ASKING QUESTIONS ON THE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE POTENTIALLY
PROGRAMS THAT ALSO YOU AS WELL
YEAH WHERE IS THAT CORRECT OKAY
I'LL I'LL DO MY BEST THANK YOU
CERTAINLY I'M FAMILIAR WITH
THIS AS AS YOU KNOW WE WE DID
LEGISLATION A TO CREATE THIS
NEW WEEK -- -- SHIFTED IN AND
JUST FOCUSED ON INCLUDING MONEY
IN THAT IN THAT BUDGETS OVER
TWO YEARS IN THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
-- SO CAN YOU JUST GIVE US
-- -- THE HIGHLIGHT OF OF HOW
THOSE -- YOURS WENT IN ROLLING
OUT MONIES ACROSS THE STATE
AND OF COURSE YEAH THERE'S A
PROPOSAL TO TEAR TO RE UP AT
TEN JUST WHAT DO YOU THINK
THAT THAT THE DEMAND IS AND
AND THAT AND WHAT ELSE WOULD BE
POTENTIALLY DO TO THIS PROGRAM
BESIDES PUT MORE RESOURCES IN
THERE SHOULD BE ADJUSTED OF ALL
SO THANK YOU AND -- WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED WORKING WITH
YOU TO EXPAND THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE STATE IT IS ONE OF THE
MOST POPULAR GRANT PROGRAMS
-- THAT THAT WE'VE BEEN --
BUT DISSIPATING AND OTHER
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
INVESTED TO DATE HAVE ALLOWED
US TO AWARD GRANTS FORTY FOUR
GRANTS TO LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES ARE SUPPORTING THE
PREPARATION OVER TIME OF
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY CLASSIFIED STAFF THUS
FAR IN LAST YEAR'S REPORT --
WE INDICATED THAT THERE ARE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
RUSSIAN ALSO CLASSIFIED STAFF
WHO EARN THEIR CREDENTIALS
THUS FAR MORE THAN HALF OF
THEM IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
THIS POPULATION ALSO TENDS
TO BE MORE DIVERSE THAN --
TEACHERS COMING THROUGH OTHER
TEACHING TRADITIONAL TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS HAS BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL IT IS IN THE
IN CONTINUOUS DEMAND -- WE
BELIEVE THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- PROVIDED THAT WOULD
BE PROVIDED THIS NEXT YEAR WILL
ALSO BE OF VERY SUCCESSFUL BE
ABLE TO GET THOSE FUNDS OUT
AND AND BRING MORE FOLKS FROM
THE CLASSIFIED BRINGS INTO
THE TEACHING PROFESSION WE
THINK WE NEED TO WATCH THAT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CONTINUED
TO RESPONSE TO DEMAND AGAIN
THE NEED FOR TEACHERS IN THE
STATE IS GREAT AND IT'S GROWING
THIS YEAR IS THE YEAR WHERE
IN THE COLD WITH YOUR WORK
AND IS SOMEWHAT UNPREDICTABLE
IN TERMS OF WHERE WE WILL BE
WITH RESPECT RETIREMENTS WHERE
DEMAND WILL BE AS WE MOVE INTO
RE OPENING NEXT YEAR IN THE
OUT YEARS -- AND KEEPING OF
THESE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THE
RECRUITMENT AND DEVELOPMENT
OF TEACHERS IS GOING TO BE
A ESSENTIAL IF WE WANT TO
ADDRESS SHORTAGES IN THE FUTURE
AND AS FAR AS OTHER ELIGIBILITY
BEFORE BESIDES CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ANOTHER OTHER
BIT OTHER SUGGESTIONS --
EARLY LEARNING PRE K.
TEACHERS AFTER SCHOOL -- THIS
OFFENSE DO YOU THINK THAT THAT
COULD BE UTILIZED OR IS THIS
IS IT IS IT IS THAT IS THE
FOCUS THAT WE SHOULD KEEP ON
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
RIGHT I ACTUALLY WOULD SAY
THAT THIS IS A MODEL A MODEL
PROGRAM REALLY FOR THAT CAN BE
AS AS WE ALL ARE WELL AWARE
WITH THE -- THE ISSUANCE OF THE
NEW MASTER PLANNED FOR EARLY
LEARNING CARE THERE'S A GREAT
DEAL OF ATTENTION OF DEVELOPING
AND MOVING FORWARD IN AROUND
THAT THE PREPARATION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT WORK FORCE
-- AND WE DO WE DO BELIEVE THAT
IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY USEFUL TO
PUT TOGETHER A PARALLEL PROGRAM
FOR THE RECRUITMENT OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS -- THE
FUNDING AND SALARY STRUCTURES
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY
ARE ARE MORE CHALLENGING
THAN EVEN IN THE K.
TWELVE COMMUNITY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS KIND
OF SUPPORT TO MOVE INTO THE
WORK FORCE IN EARLY CHILD
CARE YEAH DEVELOPMENT WOULD
BE EXTREMELY USEFUL -- WE
HAVEN'T TALKED MUCH ABOUT THE
AFTER SCHOOL SPACE -- BUT BUT
WE ARE OPEN TO CONSIDERATION
AGAIN WE THINK THIS MODEL
CAN BE ADAPTED WHERE THERE
ARE SHORTAGES -- THIS KIND
OF SUPPORT SEEMS TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE ENABLING PEOPLE
WHILE THEY WORK TO WORK TOWARD
THE CREDENTIAL OR CERTIFICATION
THEY NEED IS A USEFUL I
THINK AN IMPORTANT STRATEGY
FOR THE STATE OKAY THANK YOU
THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
ON THIS ISSUE NUMBER ONE IN
QUESTION CAME AS A MEMBER PRESS
THANK YOU IT AND GOING BACK
TO THE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
I JUST FIND THE SUCH IT AND
IT'S IMPORTANT HI BLIND IS A
IF YOU WILL -- WE HAVE SUCH
A SHORTAGE OF TEACHERS AND
FINDING WAYS TO TO BRING IN
THOSE WHO ALREADY LOVE TEACHING
AND BEING AROUND THE CHILDREN
AND HAVE PICKED THIS IS A
CAREER OF IT AND THE CHAIRS --
RECOMMENDATIONS OR SUGGESTIONS
ON THE THAT THE PRE K.
IN THE CHILD CARE WORKERS
BUT IT'S IN THE THE COMMENTS
FROM THE L. A. O.
-- IT DOES SAY THAT WE SHOULD
BE TARGETING THE LOW INCOME
AREAS AND TARGET WHERE THERE
ARE TEACHER SHORTAGES -- CAN
YOU TELL US PLEASE HAVE HELD
THE GRANTS ARE WHERE THE MONEY
IS GOING AND ARE WE SUCCEEDING
IN SENDING THIS MONEY AND YOU
INVESTING THIS MONEY WHERE
THERE IS TEACHER SHORTAGES
ARE WHAT WE HAVE THE LOWER
INCOME -- AREAS -- IT ARE
WE SUCCEEDING IN THAT REGARD
WELL THE IS SO I'M GOING TO
SAY THAT WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL IN IN -- IN
PRODUCING AND AND AND RELEASING
THESE FUNDS ACCORDING TO THE
SPECIFICATIONS ESTABLISHED
BY THE LEGISLATURE ALSO WHERE
THERE WERE PARAMETERS OF
REQUIRED FOR ELIGIBILITY WE
ADDRESS THOSE IN THE R.
F. P. I THINK THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S REPORT IS IS ACCURATE
THAT THAT MAY NOT HAVE GONE TO
THE HIGHEST NEED OR THE -- THE
LOWEST INCOME I DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE THAT CERTAINLY IS AN
ADAPTATION TO THE PROGRAM THAT
THAT WE COULD CREATE AS WELL
AS ONE OF THE PRIORITIES OF
I THINK EXPANDING THESE FUNDS
FULLY -- USE WOULD BE A GOAL
ON ANNUALLY AND AND WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT IF IF PARAMETERS
ARE INCLUDED OF LIKE THESE
THAT HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED THAT
THEY BE A LIST OF PRIORITIES
SO THAT WE DON'T HIT -- A BLOCK
WHERE WE CAN'T RELEASE ALL OF
THE FUNDS BECAUSE THEY THEY
CAN'T BE ABSORBED BY A SMALLER
GROUP OF OF THE L.
B. A.'S IF THAT MAKES SENSE X.
A LOT OF MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU
FURTHER QUESTIONS YES I
JUST WANT TO KNOW THIS THIS
IS SOMETHING THE IS TO ALL
OF THESE FOR SPECIFICALLY
THESE -- THAT THE CLASSIFIED
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IT WILL
TAKE A LOOK AT POTENTIALLY
DOING MORE WE HAVE A LOT OF
ONE TIME MONEY IN THIS BUDGET
AND LOOK AT EXPANDING TO TWO
OTHER CATEGORIES EVERYTHING
TO THAT THE SUMMER REYES
BRIEFLY MENTION IS THAT THIS
REALLY HELPS TO DIVERSIFY
OUR TEACHER WORKFORCE BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT SO MANY OF OUR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES -- LOOK
LIKE THE COMMUNITY FRANKLY
THEY LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY
SO IT FURTHER CONNECTS -- THE
LOCAL NEIGHBORHOODS TO THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE AT THOSE
SCHOOLS SO -- WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN WILL PROCEED NOW
WITH ISSUE NUMBER TWO EDUCATOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
THE E. AND L. A. L.
COMPLETELY
GOOD MORNING IN RELATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATORS HAVE
RISEN TO THE CHALLENGES OF
THE COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BY DEVELOPING AND DELIVERING
CURRICULUM AND DISTANCE
LEARNING OUR HYBRID CONTEST
PROVIDING INTENSIVE AND
TARGETED IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
IN SMALL GROUPS FOR THOSE
STUDENTS MOST DISADVANTAGED
BY DISTANCE LEARNING AND
ADDRESSING THE KID NEEDS
OF STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING ELEVATED LEVELS
OF STRESS AND ECONOMIC AND
SECURITY EDUCATORS AND STUDENTS
WILL FACE A WIDE RANGE OF
CHALLENGES AS THEY RETURN
TO IN CLASS INSTRUCTION THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING EDUCATORS WITH THE
TOOLS THEY NEED BOTH IN THE
SHORT TERM AND THE LONG TERM TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
COMPREHENSIVE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE
FOR EDUCATOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WITH EMPHASIS ON
DEVELOPING QUALITY TRAINING IN
HIGH NEED AREAS AND PROVIDING
TIMELY ACCESS TO TRAINING
SUCH AS XCELERATED LEARNING
STRATEGIES SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
LEARNING PRACTICES AND
INCLUSIVITY IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME AND GIVEN THAT YOUR AGENDA
PROVIDES AN EXCELLENT OVERVIEW
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
I WILL END MY PRESENTATION
HERE AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS PLEASE
ALEXANDER AND HAVE THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION THE CITY IS CLEAR
TO SEE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION INVESTMENTS IN TEACHERS
ON THE EDUCATOR COURSE NOT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WITH OUR
STUDENTS FACING THE CHALLENGES
OF THIS PANDEMIC IT IS CRITICAL
THAT OUR TEACHERS AND STAFF
ARE PREPARED IN THE AREA OF
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICES TO
HELP STUDENTS BOTH MENTALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY AT THE END AGENDA
INDICATES THE CD ALLOCATES
THE EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS
BLOCK GRANTS TO NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT EDUCATORS
BECAUSE THE BUDGET LANGUAGE
AUTHORIZING THIS PROGRAM WAS
SO BROAD THE DEPARTMENT DID
NOT COLLECT INFORMATION THANKS
INTERNATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS PURCHASED IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IF THIS LEVEL OF
DETAIL IS DESIRED FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS FUNDS TO INCLUDE
MORE INFORMATION REGARDING
DESIRED CONTENT FOR THE FINAL
REPORT IN THE BUDGET LANGUAGE I
HAVE WITH ME BARBARA MURCHISON
DIRECTOR OF THE EDUCATOR EQUITY
AND EXCELLENCE DIVISION TO
HELP ANSWER ANY PROGRAMMATIC
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU L. L.
IT WILL BE WHAT THE ALLEN NOW
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS WE HAVE
SOME GENERAL ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER FIRST
WE CONSIDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BLOCK GRANT APPROACH TO
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
BE REASONABLE FUNDING COULD
BE USED TO COMPENSATE STAFF
TIME SPENT ON TRAINING OR
OTHER ASSOCIATED COSTS THE
BLOCK GRANT ALSO PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY OVER THE TRAINING
TOPICS ALONG COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT TO BE TARGETED TO
AREAS THAT WOULD MOST BENEFIT
TEACHERS AND OTHER STAFF AT
EACH SCHOOL SECONDLY AND MOST
OF THE TARGETED PROPOSALS
ADDRESS SPECIFIC GAPS IN
TRAINING FOR INSTANCE THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION IS DUE TO
ADOPT A NEW ETHNIC STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM BY THE END
OF MARCH SINCE ITS GUIDANCE IS
NEW STATE FUNDED PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SEEMS REASONABLE
OTHER PROPOSALS SEEM TO ADDRESS
THE LACK OF EXIT EXISTING
RESOURCES SUCH AS THE EARLY
MATH INITIATIVE OR FURTHER
PROMOTES LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES
SUCH AS THE STATE'S CONTINUED
EFFORTS ON THE MULTI TIERED
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT AND EMOTIONAL
LEARNING WHERE LESS CLEAR
HOWEVER ON HOW THE FUNDING FOR
THE SUBJECT MATTER PROJECTS
WOULD ADDRESS EXISTING GAPS
FOR INSTANCE A TWO MILLION
PROVIDED FOR ITS SUBJECT
MATTER PROJECTS FIRST ETHNIC
STUDIES APPEARS DUPLICATIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OTHER
PROPOSAL AN ETHNIC STUDIES
THIRD THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CONTAINS VERY FEW DETAILS
ON SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS
FOR IT SINCE THE EARLY MATH
INITIATIVE AND THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING PROPOSALS
DO NOT SPECIFY THE TYPE OF
ACTIVITIES TO BE SUPPORTED
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING THE
SUBJECT MATTER PROJECT PROPOSAL
DOES NOT CLARIFY HOW THE ONE
TIME AUGMENTATION WOULD BE
USED DIFFERENTLY THAN ONGOING
FUNDING CURRENTLY PROVIDED
TO THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDS ARE SPENT AS INTENDED
WITH THE DESIRED OUTCOME WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE CLEAR DELIVERABLES
AND EXPECTATIONS TIED TO
FUNDING FOR THESE MORE TARGETED
PROPOSALS LASTLY WE NOTED
THAT FUNDS PROVIDED THROUGH
THE THREE FEDERAL COPING
NINETEEN RELIEF PACKAGES CAN
ALSO BE USED FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THE LEGISLATURE
ME JUST WANNA CONSIDER HOW THE
GOVERNOR'S PULLS ME COMPLEMENT
THESE FUNDS WITH THAT I'LL
CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTRETTA YES
AT THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
-- JUST A COUPLE COMMENTS HERE
WITH REGARD TO THE EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK GRANTS
I HOPE THAT I HOPE THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE LANGUAGE
ACTUALLY STE IT'S GOING TO
SAY BUT IT NEEDS TO BE PRETTY
SPECIFIC I MEAN TO ME IT IT
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AT SCHOOLS
PROBABLY -- OTHERWISE I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
AN EFFECTIVE USE OF MONEY IF
WE DON'T REALLY BE SPECIFIC
ON WHAT WHAT THE USE OF THOSE
DOLLARS ARE FOR INTRODUCTION
BECAUSE WE WE SHOULD PROBABLY
GOING TO IS SOME KIDS ARE US
DOWN WHEN WE SHOULD BE GIVING
DISTRICTS MONEY TO DEVELOP
BETTER ONLINE PROGRAMS I DON'T
WANT KIDS ONLINE QUITE FRANKLY
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT'S AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TEETH BUT SOME
ARE GOING TO REMAIN SO AND THE
CHARTER SCHOOL OPERATIONS FOR
THE MOST PART ARE NOT DOING
A GOOD JOB OF IT OF THOSE
THAT ARE OUT THERE SO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NEED TO BUILD THAT
CAPACITY THIS IS MY POINT I
SEE THERE'S FOR THE EARLY --
EARLY MATH INITIATIVE EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
THE SHOULD BE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHT POINT THREE THAT SHOULD
BE A HUGE PRIORITY -- HELPING
TEACHERS -- DELIVER MATH SKILLS
IN A MORE EFFECTIVE MANNER TO
STUDENTS EIGHT POINT THREE IS
LIKE NOTHING OKAY THAT JUST
SAYS HEY THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF MONEY -- WITH REGARD TO THE
UC -- SUBJECT MATTER PROJECT
ON LEARNING LOSS -- -- THEIR
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF OTHERS
FIVE MILLION -- DEDICATED TO
TO PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ON
LEARNING LOS I THINK WE NEED
TO GET OUT OF THE BUSINESS
OF GIVING THE UC MONEY -- --
TO -- TO ENHANCE -- TEACHER
CREDENTIALING CANDIDATES --
TEACHER SKILLS IN THE CLASSROOM
AND HE'S GOT THE CSU THAT IS
THE PLACE WHERE THE RUBBER
MEETS THE ROAD IN CALIFORNIA
THAT IS THE PLACE WHERE TEACHER
CREDENTIALED CANDIDATES COME
FROM BY AND LARGE THE UC DOES
NOT MUCH OF IT AND DOESN'T SEEM
TO ME EVEN HAVE AN INTEREST
IN DOING SO IT REALLY SHOULD
GO TO THE CSU BECAUSE THAT
IS REALLY THE WORK COURSE --
INITIAL HORSE -- WITH REGARD
TO TO TO TO THE PRODUCTION
OF EFFECTIVE TEACHERS MY MY
PERCEPTION IS THE UC PRODUCES
STUFF LIKE THIS IT'S IT'S ON
THE SHELF AND NEVER GETS ON THE
GROUND SO WE NEED TO GET OUT
OF THE BUSINESS OF GIVING MONEY
THE UC IT SHOULD GO TO THE CSU
BECAUSE THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TYPICALLY IN THE CLASSROOM
MORE TYPICALLY MORE CONNECTED
TO THEIR COMMUNITIES IT'S
JUST A FACT FROM MY FROM MY
PERCEPTION -- -- SO WITH THAT
-- ALL THE ON THE CHOIRMASTER
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS
I I JUST WANNA DRESS TWO ISSUES
ONE IS THE IT'S IT'S A SMALLER
AMOUNT HERE IN THE LAST ITEM
THE DRESSED IN OUR AGENDA THE
ETHNIC STUDIES PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT I KNOW SOMEONE
MEMBER MEDINA AND WOULD LIKE
TO BE HERE BUT I BELIEVE IT'S
CHIANG AT HIGHER ED SEX SPECIAL
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW ALONG WITH
A COUPLE OF OTHER MEMBERS AND
-- CERTAINLY IT'S A PRIORITY
TO IMPLEMENT ETHNIC STUDIES
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALREADY DOING
IT AND -- THERE IS OF COURSE
THE ONE SOMEONE TIME MONEY HERE
AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE WOULD I'D LIKE TO AND ARE
ASSEMBLY VERSION OF THE BUDGET
AND SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE SO
BE PREPARED THAT THIS WILL BE
A PRIORITY -- FOR THE FOR THE
ASSEMBLY AND I JUST WANTED TO
GO BACK AND ADDRESS WHAT --
EDUCATION CHERYL DONALD BRIEFLY
TOUCHED ON THE EDUCATOR BLOCK
GRANTS AND -- MORE TIGHTENING
UP THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW WE COULD HEAR FROM FINANCE
OR WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT DOING
IN OUR VERSION OF THE BUDGET
FOR THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT OUT
OF MONEY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION -- ONE TIME WHO KNOWS
MORE ONE TIME MONEY THEM THE
GOVERNMENT PROPOSED TO PUT
MARIN AND MAY I JUST WANT I
REMEMBER THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR
THAT YOU'RE THAT THE BUT THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN WE HAVE THIS PROPOSAL
AS NOTED HERE IN THE AGENDA --
JUST WONDERED IF IF IF L.
A. OUR FINANCER CD II --
HAS ANY INSIGHT ON ON HOW
THAT WENT THOSE YEARS AND --
WHAT WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT
DOING IN THE SECOND ROUND --
GOING OUT TO OUR DISTRICTS
AND UPPING THE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PLUS CERTIFIED
EDUCATORS AROUND CALIFORNIA
THIS IS KIMBERLY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
AM WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
ANECDOTALLY THAT EDUCATORS
AND ADMINISTRATORS OUT IN THE
FIELD ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE AND EFFECTIVE EDUCATOR
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM IT WAS
VERY WELL RECEIVED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN OF THE MONEY
-- ONCE AGAIN THIS THIS NEW
PROGRAM IS IS FACT AND AFTER
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
CHANGES OTHER THAN THE TOPIC
AREAS THAT THE MONEY CAN BE
SPENT ON TYPES OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OR PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING WELL IT THE GREAT
THING ABOUT THIS FUNDING IS IT
ALLOWS EACH LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY TO PROVIDE THE TYPE OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT
THEIR EDUCATORS LOOKING FOR
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES THEY CAN
USE THESE FUNDS TO SUPPLEMENT
THEIR FUNDS THEY CAN USE OTHER
FUNDS TO SUPPLEMENT THESE
FUNDS I'M IT'S VERY FLEXIBLE
AND WE FOUND THAT IN THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN PROGRAM
BASED ON REPORTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT
EDUCATORS ARE TEACHING ABOUT
THEM SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACTUALLY
APPLYING MORE FUNDING TO THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THEY
PROVIDED THEM TO SUPPLEMENT THE
EFFECTIVE EDUCATOR BOKER OUT
SOME DO THINK THAT THIS IS A
FANTASTIC WAY TO PROVIDE MONEY
THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO THEIR EDUCATORS
OKAY THE L. A. L.
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON ON THIS
APPROPRIATIONS COMPARED TO WHAT
WE DID SEVEN YEARS AGO AND AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD --
TAKE A LOOK AT THE JUSTANSWER
TIGHTENING THE LANGUAGE FOR
DISTRICTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
SURE ASSEMBLYMEMBER IMMEDIATELY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AGAIN IN OUR REVIEW OF
THIS PROPOSAL WE FOUND THAT
THAT APPROACH FOR BLOCK GRANTS
TO YOU FOR PERSONAL DEVELOPMENT
WAS A REASONABLE APPROACH
-- THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY THAT'S GIVEN TO
DISTRICTS OVER HOW TO USE THESE
FUNDS AND WHAT TOPICS TO CHOOSE
WITHIN A LIST THAT'S ALREADY
IN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ITSELF AND SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY INITIAL CONCERNS OR ANY
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS
IN TERMS OF THIS PROPOSAL
OKAY AND THEN LASTLY TO SOMEONE
I WANT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THAT IS NOTED IN THE STAFF
AGENDA AND WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF DONNA MENTIONED EARLIER
ABOUT THAT HOW THIS HE WIN
THIS THAT LEARNING LOSS ISSUES
DURING THIS -- PANDEMIC AND
HOW YOU KNOW THESE MONIES CAN
HELP ADDRESS -- THE THE ISSUES
THAT TEACHERS ARE GOING TO BE
FACED WITH HOW TO YOU KNOW GET
STUDENTS -- PACKET BACK AT --
AT PAR WITH THAT WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE ON THEIR LEARNING
HOW ABOUT SIX CD HERE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WITH THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION I I WOULD
ACTUALLY PREFER TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND HOW THEY
AND HOW THEY PERCEIVE THESE
GRANTS TO BE UTILIZED AT FOR
LEARNING LAWSUIT YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S BEEN QUITE A BIT
OF FUNDS ALLOCATED AS PART OF
THE -- RE OPENING AND AS EARLY
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAM THAT
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED RECENTLY
THAT THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
FOR EXTENDED LEARNING AND THEN
THE TWO BILLION FOR FOR THAT I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT SEEKS AT CCP
HAS BEEN FUNDED TO DO A LOT OF
THAT KIND OF WORK TO PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ON
THE LEARNING LAST PIECE AS WELL
THIS IS YOUR LIFE HE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- REGARDING IT
EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK
GRANT DUE TO THE FLEXIBILITY
OF THESE FUNDS WHAT -- THEN THE
TOPIC AREAS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
IN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
HELICASE CAN SPEND THIS MONEY
ON THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AREAS OTHER THAN -- LOST
MAYBE LEARNING LOS LEARNING
MITIGATION THEY THEY CAN
SPEND THIS ON SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING THEY CAN SPEND THIS
ON STUDENT ENGAGEMENT PRACTICES
THEY CAN SPEND THIS ON -- HOW
TO BETTER -- WORK WITH ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS IT'S I MEAN
THERE ARE SIX TOPIC AREAS
WITHIN WHICH THE APARTMENT
THAT THE L. E. A.
CAN CHOOSE TO PROVIDE --
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SO THAT THE FLEXIBILITY IS
THE KEY WITH THIS PROGRAM
THAT ALLOWS THE ONLY A IS
TO ADDRESS THEIR LOCAL NEEDS
WHICH ARE OBVIOUSLY NOT THE
SAME ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE
OKAY
OF THIS FIGURE THIS INITIATIVE
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT THE
POTENTIALLY -- ADJUST DURING
OUR FINAL ASSEMBLY ADOPTED
PLAN IN MAY AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARRESTS THANK MISTER CHAIR ON
THE ISSUE THAT THE BY CALLING
FROM LONG BEACH BROUGHT UP
I THINK IT SEEMS THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD EASILY
LOOK INTO TO DETERMINE WHERE
OUR TEACHERS ARE COMING FROM
AND IF THEY ARE COMING FROM THE
CSU CLEARLY THIS NEEDS TO BE
ADJUSTED SO THAT WE PROVIDE THE
FUNDING FOR THE FOR OUR C.
S. USED TO PROVIDE THE SUBJECT
MATTER TRAINING OR TEACHING
FOR FOR TEACHERS -- BUT I
WANTED TO ASK ON THE EARLY
LITERACY BLOCK GRANTS -- I
COME FROM A DISTRICT THAT
QUALIFIES FOR SO MANY OF THESE
ARE VERY PROUD OF RIALTO UNITS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
THEIR SPECIFIC INTEREST IN
THIS BUT MY QUESTION IS ON
THE EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS
BLOCK GRANTS COULD IT THIS
FUNDING ALSO APPLIED TO THE
EARLY LITERACY PILOT PROGRAMS
KIM LACEY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AT THE WAY THE TURN
OF THE LANGUAGES WRITTEN AT
PRESENT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WOULD BE -- AND ACCEPTABLE --
EXPENDITURE UNDER THE PROGRAM
GUIDELINES IN THE TRAILER BILL
HOW WOULD THE LANGUAGE HAVE
TO CHANGE SO THE COULD APPLY
GIVEN THAT I DON'T HAVE THE
PROGRAMMATIC DETAILS FOR THE
EARLY LITERACY GRANT I WILL
NEED TO DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ON THE DETAILS
OF THE EARLY LITERACY GRANT
YOU CAN ONLY GARNER WITH THE
PART THE PART OF EDUCATION I'M
GOING TO HAND IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE BARBARA JUST AND HE
WAS THE DIRECTOR AND CO HEAD
BACK HI GOOD MORNING BIPARTISAN
EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE AND EQUITY
AT THE DEPARTMENT OR WE DO
ADMINISTER THE EARLY LITERACY
SUPPORT BLOCK GRANT AND THAT
GRANT WAS WRITTEN SPECIFICALLY
TO SUPPORT THE SEVENTY FIVE
SCHOOLS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
ON FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
PARTICULARLY THEIR THIRD GRADE
CASF ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
READING READING SCORES SO THAT
PROGRAM IS UP AND RUNNING --
WE'VE SELECTED EXPERT LEADING
LITERACY TO SUPPORT THEM TO
DEVELOP PLANS TO GO AHEAD AND
IMPROVE LITERACY OUTCOMES BUT
IT'S LIMITED TO JUST THOSE
SEVENTY FIVE DISTRICTS I
ANTICIPATE IN THE COMING YEARS
THAT THE LEARNING THAT WILL
HAPPEN AS THE SEVENTY FIVE
DISTRICTS WORK TOGETHER WITH
THE EXPERT LEADING LITERACY
WILL BE SHARED MORE WIDELY
ACROSS THE STATE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT -- WE'RE ALREADY
JUST IN THE PLANNING PHASE IS
LEARNING A LOT ABOUT WHAT SOME
OF THE BARRIERS TO HIGH QUALITY
ON LITERACY INSTRUCTION ARE
IN HELPING THESE DISTRICTS WHO
I GUESS WE CAN THINK OF IS A
PILOT FOR THIS KIND OF WORK --
TO BE ABLE TO IMPROVE THEIR
LITERACY OUTCOMES WILL TAKE
THOSE LEARNINGS AND SHARE
THEM MORE WIDELY BUT -- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AS THAT
STATUTE WAS WRITTEN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET -- THAT PROGRAM
IS LIMITED TO THE SEVENTY
FIVE IDENTIFIED GOALS IT AND
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR YES
THAT WAS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
ALSO IS WHAT IS THE STATUS OF
THE EARLY LITERACY PROGRAMS
WONDERFUL SO AGAIN THIS IS
THE ONE EARLY LITERACY SUPPORT
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM I'M TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES
HAPPENING WITH LITERACY AT
THE MOMENT THE S.
SEVENTY FIVE SCHOOLS WERE
IDENTIFIED NINETEENTH AND
INVITED TO PARTICIPATE SEVENTY
THREE OF THE SEVENTY FIVE ARE
CURRENTLY PARTICIPATING WE
SELECTED THE EXPERT LEADING
LITERACY THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THROUGH
A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS
WAS PULLED TOGETHER -- THEY
ONE AND ARE NOW WORKING WITH
THOSE SEVENTY THREE DISTRICTS
PROVIDING A LOT OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WORKING ALONGSIDE
THEM AS THEY DEVELOP THEIR
PLANS AND WE ARE FULL ON IN
YEAR ONE WHICH IS A PLAN HERE
FOR THEM TO DO SOME ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSES OF NEEDS ASSESSMENTS
WORK WITH THEIR LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT IT IS THAT THEY WANT TO
DO TO IMPROVE LITERACY WITHIN
A RANGE OF OPTIONS THAT WERE
SET FORTH IN THE AUTHORIZING
LANGUAGE -- WE ANTICIPATE
THAT NEXT YEAR THEY WILL BEGIN
IN EARNEST IMPLEMENTING THE
PLANS THAT THEY'RE WORKING
ON NOW BUT WE FEEL THAT THAT
PROGRAM IS OFF TO A REALLY
GOOD START -- SACRAMENTO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
IS DOING AMAZING WORK AND THE
SEVENTY THREE DISTRICTS ARE
REALLY IN IT FOR THE LONG HAUL
SO IT'S GOING QUITE WELL AND
DURING THIS PANDEMIC DID THAT
BECAUSE ANY OF THE ANY ISSUES
OF COURSE THERE ARE ADJUSTING
THE PANDEMIC YES OF COURSE
BECAUSE MANY ISSUES AND --
EVERYONE HAS PIVOTED TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE IMPACTS OF
LITERACY INSTRUCTION IN REMOTE
CONTACTS LIKE SOMEONE ALLUDED
EARLIER IN THIS HEARING TO THE
FACT THAT FOLKS WILL LIKELY BE
-- DOING SOME KIND OF REMOTE
LEARNING OR SOME KIND OF
BLENDED LEARNING MOVING FORWARD
THE PLANS THAT ARE BEING
DEVELOPED ARE TAKING VARIOUS
CONDITIONS THAT THE SEVENTY
THREE DISTRICTS ARE R.
SEVENTY THREE SCHOOLS ARE
ARE FACING AS WE MOVE THROUGH
AND OUT OF THE COOK AT
NINETEEN RESPONSE AND THE
SEVENTY THIRD IF I MAYES
IT'S SEVENTY THREE SCHOOLS
THAT WERE SELECTED WERE THOSE
WITH THE LOWEST ACHIEVEMENT
STANDARD LEVEL ON STATE
SOME OF SUMMATIVE ASSESSMENT
IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
IS THAT HOW THEY WERE SELECTED
OR WERE SCHOOLS INVITED TO
PARTICIPATE NOW THE STATUTE
REQUIRED THE DEPARTMENT TO
IDENTIFY THE SEVENTY FIVE
SCHOOLS WHO HAD -- STRUGGLED
THE MOST WITH THE STATE'S
AMID REPORTS -- AND THEY
WERE IDENTIFIED NOTIFIED
THAT THEY WERE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM --
IN SEVENTY THREE OUT OF THE
SEVENTY FIVE ARE CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
I WANT TO GO BACK AND ASK ONE
QUESTION RELATED THE MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT
MTS ASK -- I ALSO REMEMBER
LIFE MY OUR FIRST YEAR HE
SAID SIX SEVEN YEARS AGO WE
STARTED THIS WITH -- ONE TEN
MILLION DEVELOPMENTS GOING TO
THE ORANGE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION PART OF EDUCATION
AT JUST ONE JUST WONDERED
YOU KNOW YEARS LATER IS IS IT
NOW THAT WE'VE EVOLVED HERE
RETURNING PROVIDE GRANTS IS
IS IT APPROPRIATE FOR LOCAL
ELLIE EIGHT TO BE -- LEADING
THIS OR -- CITY EVE WHICH
WE DO WITH MOST OTHER DATE
EDUCATION GRANT PROGRAMS
AMBER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT IT IS APPROPRIATE
WE WOULD NOTE THAT -- YOU
KNOW THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
INVESTMENT -- IN THE MULTI
TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT IN
THAT FUNDING HAS BEEN GOING
TO ORANGE COUNTY INTERVIEW
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW FOR THIS
EFFORT -- THIS IS THIS THIS
WOULD NOT BE NEW PRACTICE FOR
THAT AND TO PROVIDE GRANTS
TO OTHER ELEAZAR -- AND WE
WE DO CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THAT IT'S AN APPROPRIATE ROLE
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO SIR
OKAY
HOW ABOUT L. A. L.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
DEALING WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AGAIN SO WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
JUST SHARED -- DOC THAT
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS BEEN DOING THIS
WORK FOR A FEW YEARS NOW AND
THEY DO HAVE A FAIR AMOUNT
OF TECHNICAL EXPERTISE WITH
HELPING BOTH COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION AND DISTRICTS
ENDS AND NOW AT THIS POINT
SCHOOL SITES ROLL OUT MTS ASK
READING THESE CONTINUED EFFORTS
-- ARE REASONABLE APPROACH
IN TERMS OF THE STATE'S
EFFORTS IN CONTINUING DESIRE
IN CONTINUING AND YES ASK
OKAY THANK YOU OF WILL PROBABLY
REAP REVISIT THIS LATER IN
THE SPRING OF THE CASING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS ON ISSUE
NUMBER TWO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING
GOOD MORNING BEGAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AS INDICATED IN YOUR AGENDA
MATERIALS THE COMMISSION
IS CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
STANDARDS BOARD RESPONSIBLE
FOR CREDENTIALING THE
EDUCATION WORKFORCE ACCREDITING
APPROVED SPONSORS OF EDUCATOR
PREPARATION AND ENFORCING
STANDARDS OF PRACTICE AND
CONDUCT FOR CREDENTIALED
EDUCATORS IN ADDITION THE
COMMISSION ESTABLISHES AND
MAINTAINS EXAMINATIONS AND
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS FOR
EDUCATORS AND ADMINISTERS
TEACHER RECRUITMENT GRANTS THE
COMMISSION'S OPERATING BUDGET
IS SUPPORTED BY CREDENTIAL
AND EXAMINATION FEES HAVE I'M
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT WE ARE
IN REASONABLY GOOD SHAPE ALL
THINGS CONSIDERED OUR YEAR
TO DATE REVENUES ARE DOWN
BUT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COVER GAPS
THIS YEAR WHO ARE EXISTING
RESERVES AS NECESSARY THE
FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR WE
RECEIVED SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER
CREDENTIAL AND SUBSTITUTE
PERMIT APPLICATIONS THAN USUAL
WE ATTRIBUTE THIS TO SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND EXPECT THAT OUR
SCHOOLS REOPEN THIS SPRING
AND INTO THE FALL WE WILL
BEGIN TO BOUNCE BACK THIS TIME
LAST YEAR THE COMMISSION WAS
PLANNING FOR A SIGNIFICANT
INFUSION OF FUNDING TO SUPPORT
TEACHER RESIDENCIES AND OTHER
RECRUITMENT PROGRAMS TO WORK
TOWARD ELIMINATING TEACHER
SHORTAGES WE HAD RECEIVED
FUNDING UNDER THE PRESCHOOL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT RENEWAL TO
LUNCH SIGNIFICANT DO WORK IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WE
WERE WORKING WITH PREPARATION
PROGRAMS TO FULLY IMPLEMENT
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS AND
ENGAGED IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE FIELD ABOUT OUR
CURRENT TEACHER EXAMINATIONS
ON MARCH NINETEENTH WE HAD A
HARD STOP SCHOOLS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS CLOSED
THEIR BUILDINGS AND MOVED
QUICKLY TO IMPLEMENT ONLINE
INSTRUCTION AND FINISH OUT THE
SCHOOL YEAR AS BEST THEY COULD
OUR EMPLOYEES TRANSITION TO
TELEWORK AND LIKE EVERY OTHER
ENTERPRISES WE WERE FACED
WITH THE QUESTION WHAT DO
WE DO NOW IMPACTS ON STUDENT
TEACHERS COMPLETING CLINICAL
PRACTICE AND ON THE CLOSURE
OF TESTING CENTERS WHERE TWO
OF THE MOST IMPACTFUL ISSUES
WE FACED EARLY ON THE PIPELINE
INTO TEACHING WAS ESSENTIALLY
SHUT DOWN TEACHERS ARE NEEDED
TO COMPLETE STUDENT TEACHING
AND PASSED THE RICA AND A
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT TO
ACCEPT PREPARATION COULD NOT
DO SO NEITHER COULD PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS WHO NEEDED TO TAKE
BASIC SKILLS AND SUBJECT
MATTER TESTS TO ENROLL IN
TEACHER PREPARATION MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS IN EARLY JUNE THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER POSTPONING THE DATES
BY WHICH TEACHERS WOULD NEED
TO MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS
TO ENTER PREPARATION AND
COMPLETE BASIC SKILLS AND
SUBJECT MATTER TESTS LATER
AND ALLOWING STUDENT TEACHERS
WHO WERE CLOSE TO FINISHING TO
EARN THEIR CREDENTIALS BEGIN
TEACHING IN THE FALL INCOMPLETE
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT CENTER
RIGA DURING THEIR FIRST
YEARS OF TEACHING LAST YEAR'S
TRAILER BILL EXTENDED THESE
ALLOWANCES FOR ANOTHER YEAR
AGAIN PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT
AND IMPORTANT SUPPORT FOR
THE PIPELINE INTO TEACHING IN
ADDITION THE COMMISSION WORKED
WITH PREPARATION PROGRAMS TO
IDENTIFY OTHER REQUIREMENTS
THAT COULD BE SUSPENDED MOVED
OR ADJUSTED TODAY TO COULD
NOT FINISH ALL REQUIREMENTS
LAST SPRING ELIGIBLE TO BEGIN
TEACHING IN THE FALL ON A
WAIVER AND COMPLETE THOSE
REQUIREMENTS WITHIN ONE YEAR
WE ARE FORTUNATE IN CALIFORNIA
TO HAVE A CREDENTIALING
STRUCTURE THAT INCLUDES A TWO
YEAR REDUCTION PROGRAM FOR NEW
TEACHERS RECEIVE SUPPORT AND
MENTORING WHILE THEY ON BOARD
IN THE PROFESSION THE STAFF
HAVE BEEN WORKING INTENSIVELY
WITH THE PREPARATION AND
INDUCTION COMMUNITIES TO
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION FOR
TEACHERS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
THESE INTERRUPTIONS IN THEIR
PREPARATION PATHWAYS AND WE'RE
ENCOURAGED DEEPLY SO BY THE
COMMITMENT OF EDUCATORS ACROSS
THE CONTINUUM TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT NEEDED TO SUSTAIN NEW
TEACHERS HAVE BEEN THROUGH
THIS YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS TO EXPAND PATHWAYS
TO DEMONSTRATE BASIC SKILLS
AND SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCE
ARE A WELCOME RELIEF TO THE
BOTTLENECK FUSSED BY TESTING
CENTER CLOSURES OR TESTING
PROGRAMS FOR TEACHERS NEED TO
BE REVIEWED AND UPDATED WITH
AN EYE TOWARD THEIR CURRENT
RELEVANCE IN BOTH CONTENT AND
FUNCTION WITH THE ADVENT OF
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS IN
RECENT YEARS AND PROPOSALS
THAT MAKES STANDARDIZED TESTING
ONE OF SEVERAL OPTIONS WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE AND
RIGHT SIZE THEIR IMPACT ON THE
INCOMING TEACHING WORKFORCE THE
GOVERNOR'S FUNDING PROPOSALS
TO UPDATE AND EXPAND PATHWAYS
INTO TEACHER PREPARATION ARE
BOTH NECESSARY AND TIMELY
ALSO THE PROPOSALS TO EXPAND
RESIDENCIA CLASSIFIED GRANT
PROGRAMS AND GROW THE SIZE OF
OUR TEACHING WORKFORCE IN SHORT
WE FULLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WE'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU
OKAY LESSONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NOW I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE -- THE THE DATE
TEEKAY CREDENTIALING --
DISCUSSIONS YOU KNOW WE'VE
CERTAINLY ALREADY HAVE --
THOUSANDS OF TWO K.
TEACHERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND -- ATTENTIVELY MORE WITH
WITH IT WITH EXPANSION AND
YOU WE HAVE THE TRADITIONAL --
TEACHER CREDENTIALING FOR K.
TWELVE TEACHERS AND SO THERE'S
BEEN SOME DISCUSSIONS OF
HAVING ONE THAT FOCUS ON
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS FOR TO
CANCEL CAN YOU DISCUSS THAT
YES ABSOLUTELY WE WERE -- WE
WERE DELIGHTED WITH THE REST OF
THE COMMUNITY TO SEE IT BEING A
MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE AND ITS BROAD VISION
FOR -- KIND OF A TEN YEAR GOAL
FOR RICIN FOR HOW WE KIND OF
COULDN'T REORGANIZE THE WHOLE
SET OF SERVICES AND SYSTEMS
AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE UNDER WAY
IN THE EARLY CHILDHOOD SPACE
SO WITH ALL THAT IN MIND THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN WORKING --
WE'VE HAD A DESIGN TEAM THAT
WORKED WITH US FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS ON HOW SHOULD WE
STRUCTURE PREPARATION FOR THE
WORK FORCE WE'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS MASTER PLAN AND THAT
THAT CHANCE TO GAUGE WHERE
PUBLIC OPINION IS ABOUT HOW WE
SHOULD -- SET REQUIREMENTS FOR
WORK IN EARLY -- THE PRESCHOOL
NTK WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AS THEY HAVE BEEN CONSIDERING
OF THE POSSIBILITY OF
REGULATIONS AROUND THE T.
K. PORTION IN PARTICULAR
AND REALLY WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO DO AND AND WE THESE
CONVERSATIONS RELATING FOR
THAT IS WORK COLLABORATIVELY
TO MAKE THIS A MORE SEAMLESS
PROCESS OF PREPARATION FOR
TEACHERS WORKING IN THE
PRESCHOOL SPACE THE T.
K. SPACE IN THE EARLY EARLY
GRADES -- SO WE HAVE SOME IDEAS
ON THE TABLE WHERE WE TAKE THE
MULTIPLE SUBJECT CREDENTIAL
AND -- EXPAND ITS END AND
STRENGTHEN IT FOR ITS -- ITS
ABILITY TO WORK WITH AN EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE ENVIRONMENT
AND TO TAKE THE EXISTING
CHILD DEVELOPMENT PERMIT AND
STRENGTHEN IT SO THAT THERE
IS A PATHWAY AND AND POSSIBLY
EVEN A NICE BRIDGE TO MOVE
FROM ONE TO THE OTHER ALTHOUGH
THESE ARE BIG IDEAS IT AND
IT'S IT'S A DEVELOPMENT SO IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY ATK CREDENTIAL
IT'S THAT EARLY IT'S EARLY
GREAT SO LIKE A P.
THREE THREE CREDENTIAL HOW
THE DIFFERENT THE MULTIPLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIAL SO WE DON'T
HAVE A P. A T. K.
THROUGH GRADE THREE CREDENTIAL
YET ON THE BOOKS NOT ONLY HAVE
MEANT THAT THE IS THE IDEA
TO CREATE SIX NOT NECESSARILY
TEEKAY CREDENTIAL BUT I CREEK
AND I'M KIND OF PARALLEL
CREDENTIAL FOR P.
THROUGH THIRD GRADE P.
THREE THREE THAT IS ONE OF THE
IDEAS ON THE TABLE WE REALLY
NEED TO GAUGE THE -- THE THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION'S
SUPPORT FOR THAT IDEA WE THINK
GOOD A TKA THROUGH GRADE THREE
CREDENTIAL COULD ADD A LOT TO
OUR SYSTEM -- AND THE MULTIPLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIAL YOU KNOW
ALREADY TO WORK IN TKA REQUIRES
THAT THAT TEACHERS HAVE SOME
PREPARATION IN EARLY -- CHILD
CARE AND EDUCATION BUT AGAIN
WE WE NEED TO STRENGTHEN THAT
WE ARE ALL WE ARE AT THE EDGE
HERE OF BEING ABLE TO REALLY
DIG IN AND AND LOOK AT WAYS
TO STRENGTHEN THE OTHER AT A
PRESCHOOL THROUGH GRADE THREE
PRUDENTIAL COULD HELP WOULD
REPLACE THE MULTIPLE SUBJECTS
PROVINCIAL LIKELY NOT I IN
TERMS OF WORKING T.
K. THROUGH GRADE THREE BUT WHAT
IT NEED TO ALIGN TO THAT AND
AND ALLOW A STEP MULTIPLE WAYS
TO ASSIGN TEACHERS TO THESE
-- THESE TYPES OF LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE ABLE OKAY THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY ADONIS
YES TO KIND OF DIG INTO THIS --
TOPIC A LITTLE FURTHER YOU KNOW
THE EARLY LEARNING COMMUNITY
-- AND EARLY LEARNING PROVIDERS
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS ON FOR
DECADES NOW HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF I'M
NOT JUST CARE BUT TEACHERS AND
THERE ARE TEACHERS MORE AND
MORE TEACHERS AT A PRESCHOOL
TEACHERS HAVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREES SOME ONLY HAVE A
SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF UNITS OR --
ED EARLY LEARNING THEIR CHILD
CARE PERMITS -- SO I THINK
THAT WE DO NEED TO CONSIDER
-- THE EXISTING WORK FORCE AS
A PIPELINE AND THIS PIPELINE
A I DON'T I WOULDN'T WANT TO
DECIMATED BECAUSE OF SEEING
A STRINGENT RESTRICTIONS SO
I'M DEFINITELY OPEN TO TALKING
ABOUT WHAT A -- P.
THREE THREE OR PRESCHOOL T.
K. CREDENTIALING PROCESS COULD
LOOK LIKE WELL KEEPING IN MIND
THAT THERE IS AN EXISTING WORK
FORCE -- THAT HAS WORKED HARD
TO IMPROVE QUALITY SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THAT STATEMENT
THERE AND WOULD LOVE YOU KNOW
ANY ADDITIONAL UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT FLEXIBILITIES WE COULD
GIVE TO THE EXISTING WORK FORCE
TO GET THEM TO A PLACE WHERE
THEY COULD BE T. K.
TEACHERS SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER -- EIGHT N.
AND BE REALISTIC ABOUT WHAT
THE COST MAY MAYBE TO THAT
WE COMPLETELY AGREE WITH WITH
THE POINT YOU'RE MAKING --
AND YOU KNOW THIS IS WE WE'VE
WE'RE GOOD BUT WE'RE RIGHT AT
THE EDGE NOW WITH THE MASTER
PLAN PROVIDING A BROAD CONTEXT
AND REYES AND WE'RE I THINK
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
NOW TO THINK ABOUT THIS AND
WORK TOGETHER -- TYPICALLY
THIS IS A TECHNICAL QUALITY OF
CREDENTIALING IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ONCE SOMEBODY IS CREDENTIALED
TO DO SOMETHING WE DON'T TAKE
THAT CREDENTIAL AWAY SO ANY
CHANGES WE MAKE GOING FORWARD
IN PREPARATION OF LICENSURE
FOR THIS COMMUNITY WILL NOT
REMOVE THEIR THE ABILITY OF THE
EXISTING WORKFORCE TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING BUT AS WE
ARE DEVELOPING SYSTEMS THAT
ARE INTERNET STANDARDS FOR
PREPARATION AND WORKING WITH
PREPARATION PROGRAMS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS TO STRENGTHEN
AND BRING SOME CONSISTENCY
AND AND SYSTEMATIC ORDER TO
THE PREPARATION IS WORKFORCE
WE THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITIES
TO INVEST IN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE EXISTING
WORKFORCE AND TO CREATE ON
RAMPS FOR THIS WORK FORCE
TO MOVE INTO A DEEPER INTO
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE PRE K.
THROUGH GRADE THREE SPACE
WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT THE
CLASSIFIED GRANT PROGRAM
POSSIBLY BEING ADAPTED FOR THIS
PURPOSE OF BRITISH POPULATION
WE THINK THAT'S A FIRST A
GOOD IDEA -- AND SO IT'S BUT
ALL OF THIS OF THE MOMENT
IS REALLY IN THE CONCEPTUAL
STAGE I WILL BE GETTING
SOME WORK -- ON AS I SAID ON
STANDARDS AND AND LOOKING AT
HOW TO STRENGTHEN PREPARATION
PROGRAMS WE'RE BUILDING A
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT FOR
PRESCHOOL THROUGH T.
K. TEACHERS ARE ADDED AND
THAT PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
WILL BECOME A TOOL THAT CAN BE
USED TO STRENGTHEN PREPARATION
AND DIAGNOSTICALLY TO ASSESS
THE NEEDS OF THE EXISTING
WORKFORCE SO WE CAN FOCUS
INVESTMENTS AND AND REYES SAID
THAT THE STRENGTH OF THE WHOLE
OF THE WHOLE POPULATION SO A
LOT OF IDEAS AND PROGRAMS --
UNDER WAY WE DON'T WANT TO
DISENFRANCHISE THE EXISTING
WORKFORCE AS WE DO THIS SO
ATTENDING TO TRANSITIONS --
BETTER TIMELY AND APPROPRIATE
AND WELL SUPPORTED WILL BE A
CRITICAL PART OF WHAT WE DO
NEXT AND ONE MORE QUESTION IF
YOU WILL I'M JUST TO KIND OF
BROADEN THEM THE THAT TOPIC
HERE THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE MAKES NUMEROUS
CHANGES TO ALLOW FLEXIBILITY
FOR INDIVIDUALS WORKING TOWARDS
A TEACHING CREDENTIAL TO
DEMONSTRATE BASIC SKILLS AND
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCY I'M
CAN THE CTC COMMENT ON SOME
OF THE POTENTIAL BARRIERS TO
ENTRY FOR TEACHER CANDIDATES
THAT THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
IS ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
AND HOW WILL THESE CHANGES
IMPACT THE CAREER PATHWAY FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL INTERESTED IN
BECOMING A CREDENTIALED TEACHER
WELL WE APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH THE PROPOSALS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE FIRST
HAS TO DO WITH THE BASIC SKILLS
REQUIREMENT EVERY TEACHER NEEDS
TO DEMONSTRATE THEIR BASIC
SKILLS COMPETENCE MOST TEACHERS
ARE TAKING THE CALIFORNIA BASIC
EDUCATIONAL SKILLS TEST THE C.
BEST -- AND WE FOUND OF
SIGNIFICANT BERRIER THIS YEAR
WHEN TESTING CENTERS WERE
CLOSED AND PEOPLE COULD NOT
GOING TO TAKE THOSE TESTS
SO FOR YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN
ALTERNATIVES TO THE TEST
ITSELF TO BEAT THIS REQUIREMENT
INCLUDING SCORES ON THE
SAT OR THE ACT -- AND OTHER
MEASURES THAT THE LEGISLATURES
ADOPTED OVER THE YEARS THE
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR IS TO
ALLOW RATES OF THE B.
OR BETTER AN UNDERGRADUATE
UNDERGRADUATE COURSEWORK
FOCUSED ON READING WRITING
AND MATHEMATICS TO COUNT
-- AND THAT WE THINK WILL
RIGHT SIZE IN SOME WAYS THIS
REQUIREMENT WHERE TESTERS
KEPT PEOPLE OUT OF -- OUT
OF PREPARATION ALLOWING
CONFIDENCE DEMONSTRATED
IN YOUR UNDERGRADUATE
COURSEWORK AT A GRADE OF B.
OR BETTER OF ME IS THAT YOU'VE
GOT BASIC ROLES THIS IS BECAUSE
COMPETENCE AND YOU SHOULD BE
MOVING FORWARD INTO TEACHER
PREPARATION IF THAT'S YOUR
GOAL OF PARALLEL TO THAT IS
THE SUBJECT MATTER REQUIREMENT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT EXAMINATIONS
FOR TEACHERS THE C.
SET OF WHICH MEASURES ACT OF
POTENTIAL TEACHERS SUBJECT
MATTER COMPETENCE THE LAW
CURRENTLY ALLOWS THEM TO
COMPLETE A FULL PROGRAM OF
PREPARATION IN THAT SUBJECT
MATTER AS AN ALTERNATIVE
TO THE TEST WITH THIS OF
PROPOSAL WOULD DO IS ALLOW
FOR THE MIXING AND MATCHING
UP TESTS INCLUDES FORCE WORK
SO IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T PASS A
PARTICULAR SUB TEST THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT UP BY
TAKING A COURSE IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW PREPARATION PROGRAMS
TO EVALUATE TRANSCRIPTS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER COURSE WORK
HAS BEEN TAKEN THAT ADDRESSES
THE MAJOR DOMAINS OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER AREA TO BE
TAUGHT SO THE POSTER CHILD
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY MIGHT
BE A MATHEMATICS MAJOR WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TEACHER
OF MATHEMATICS THE QUESTION
IS SHOULD THEY HAVE TO GO
BACK AND TAKE A C.
SET TEST OR COULD WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOMEONE WITH
A MATH DEGREE HAS MET AND
EXCEEDED THE STANDARD AND JUST
LET THE MOVING TO TEACHING THIS
HAVE BEEN MONOLITHIC ROADBLOCKS
FOR PEOPLE -- THAT THAT ONCE
YOU CAN'T GET PAST THAT THEN
WE'RE LOSING PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE
THIS IN SOME OTHER WAY AND
THAT IT AND AND WE ARE NOT
IN ANY WAY SEEKING TO REDUCE
THE RIGOR OR UNDERVALUE THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUBJECT MATTER
KNOWLEDGE OF BASIC SKILLS BUT
THESE ARE REQUIREMENTS THAT
ONCE MET IN ONE OF THESE MYRIAD
WAYS SIMPLY MEANS SOMEBODY
IS READY TO BEGIN LEARNING
HOW TO TEACH THEIR CONTENT
BESTIVAL IT SHOULD PLAY IT
SHOULD NOT PLAY THE KIND OF
ROADBLOCK HE SAID SHOULD NOT
PLAY THE KIND OF ROAD BLOCK
THAT THEY HAVE PLAYED AT THE
CANDIDATE CAN DEMONSTRATE
THEY HAVE THE SKILLS WE SHOULD
MOVE LIMITED PREPARATION AND
INTO THE WORKFORCE AND THIS
IS THE SET OF PROPOSALS WILL
HELP US DO THAT THANK YOU THE
OKAY I THINK IT WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OFF THE NEXT WITH
MOVE ONTO THE NEXT ITEM WAS
RELATED TO CTE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION ALWAYS A HOT TOPIC
AMONG LEGISLATORS WILL HAVE
THE L. A. L. C. D.
E. AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL CURTIS
WITH THE L. A. L.
YOU WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE STATE'S
KAITLYN TOLD CITY PROGRAMS
SO I'LL GET RIGHT INTO IT I
STORY PLEASE THE STATE HAS
SUPPORTED FIFTY ORACLE PROGRAMS
PRIOR TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF -- CFF AND TWENTY THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
CENTERS AND PROGRAMS WITH THE
STATE'S LARGEST HIGH SCHOOL
CTE PROGRAM WHICH COST ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THE STATE
SHIFTED REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
CENTERS AND PROGRAMS INTO
ALTHEA OF TO COVER THE COST OF
LCS APPROACH I MEAN SORRY CITY
PROGRAMS THERE WAS A TWO POINT
SIX PERCENT AUGMENTATION TO
THE ELF YOURSELF BASED GRANT
FOR STUDENTS IN GRADES NINE
THROUGH TWELVE BUT IT'S CLOSE
THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF LTFS
IMPLEMENTATION DISTRICTS WERE
REQUIRED TO SPEND LESS ON C.
T. UNIT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
TWELVE THIRTEEN FOR REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS AND
PROGRAMS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN THE STATE ESTABLISHED
THE CITY CENTER GRANT
OR CT TO FUNDS K.
TWO COAL CITY PROGRAMS FOR
A PERIOD OF THREE YEARS THIS
THE ALLOCATED A TOTAL OF NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE PROGRAM OVER THE COURSE
OF THOSE THREE YEARS BUT THE
MANAGING FUNDING OVER THE
PERIOD ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THREE HUNDRED
MILLION AT TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND TWO HUNDRED NINE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE STATE CONVERTED C.
TAKEN TO ONGOING PROGRAM AND
CREATED THE HIGH SCHOOL STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM SOMEWHAT
TECHNICALLY EACH PROGRAM IS
I'VE ALLOCATED UNDER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND I'M GOING
FUNDING EACH WITH A LOCAL
MATCH UP TO THE ONE THAT IS
SO LIAISING WITH SPEND TWO
DOLLARS FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR
IN STATE FUNDING ONE OF THE
MAIN DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THESE
TWO PROGRAMS THAT THAT SEEKS
TO GIVE THE MINISTER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT
CORRECTLY TO ELEAZAR BY A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS ON
THE OTHER HAND THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM IS ADMINISTERED
BY THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND AWARDS GRANTS TO STRONG
WORKFORCE CONSORTIA USING A
FORMULA THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THE TENDENCY SEVEN TO TWELVE
AS WELL AS REGIONAL WORKFORCE
NEEDS IS CONSORTIUM AND TURNED
RIGHT TOWARDS THE LOCAL ELEAZAR
ON A COMPETITIVE BASIS JUST
TO TALK A LITTLE BRIEFLY ABOUT
CITY ACCOUNTABILITY UNDER L.
CFO EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS REQUIRED TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGIC PLAN KNOWN AS
A LEARNING CONTINUITY IN
ATTENDANCE PLAN OR EL CAP
THAT SETS PERFORMANCE GOALS
AND THE GUY
TELL THE SPEND THE L.
SIP OF DOLLARS L.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MUST REPORT
CERTAIN ON ATKINS DID NOT COME
THROUGH THE STATE WHAT ARE
DISPLAYED ON A PUBLIC WEBSITE
KNOWN AS THE SCHOOL DASHBOARD
-- WHICH IS CALLED IN ON IS
THE DASHBOARD THE DASHBOARD
INCLUDES AGAIN AN INDICATOR OF
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
UNDER THIS INDICATOR THE STATE
PROVIDES DISTRICTS WITH VARIOUS
OPTIONS TO BE IN THEIR STUDENTS
PREPARE FOR COLLEGE AND CAREERS
EACH HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE IS
SEEM TO BE PREPARED APPROACHING
PREPARED OR NOT PREPARED FOR
COLLEGE AND CAREER ALL JUST
FOR SOME CONTEXT THE GRADUATING
CLASS OF TWENTY NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR PERCENT OF STUDENTS
ARE PREPARED FOR COLLEGE
AND CAREER SEVENTEEN PERCENT
ARE APPROACHING PREPARED
AND THIRTY NINE PERCENT ARE
NOT PREPARED IF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT DOES NOT DO WELL ON
DASHBOARD INDICATORS IT MUST
EXAMINE THE THROUGH PERFORMANCE
AND SHOULD ISSUES AND ACCESS
SUPPORT TO HELP IMPROVE ON THAT
INCLUDES OUR COMMENTS ON WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WHAT ARE WE GONNA HAVE THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
DVD PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN ORGANIZED INTO
FIFTEEN INDUSTRY SECTORS
COVERING FIFTY EIGHT PATHWAYS
THAT IDENTIFY THE KNOWLEDGE
AND SKILLS STUDENT MEET
STUDENTS NEED PARTNERSHIPS
ARE USUALLY DEVELOPED IN HIGH
SCHOOLS BUSINESSES AND POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS PROVIDING
PATHWAYS TO EMPLOYMENT AND
ASSOCIATE BACHELOR'S AND
ADVANCED DEGREES C.
T. E. PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE
WORLD OF WORK BY INTRODUCING
THEM TO THE WORK TO WORKPLACE
COMPETENCIES AND MAKES ACADEMIC
CONTENT ACCESSIBLE STUDENTS
YOUR HANDS ON EXPERIENCE THE
AGENDA OUTLINES THE MANY MANY
BENEFITS OF AT THE C.
T. PROGRAMS VERY VERY WELL
AMONG THIS EASY PROGRAMS THAT
CD ADMINISTERS IS THE TECH
AT CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANTS WITH POLICY
TECH AS THE L. A.
-- MENTIONS THE SEA THE
SEA TECH PROGRAM HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN ONGOING DOLLARS
SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
IN EACH OF THESE THREE YEARS
THE REQUESTED AMOUNTS OF
CTP FUNDING HAS EXCEEDED
THE FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR BOTH
PROGRAMS THERE WAS A TOTAL
OF THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
APPLICATIONS TO THE SEA TECH
PROGRAM FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ROUND OF FUNDING
WITH TOTAL GRANTS REQUEST
TOTALING THREE HUNDRED ELEVEN
MILLION THE S. B.
E. APPROVED FUNDING OF A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR THE
THREE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR THREE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS THE K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM RECENTLY RECEIVED THREE
HUNDRED AND FOUR APPLICATIONS
TOTALING TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO MILLION REQUESTED BUT
IT'S TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
KATE STRONG WORKFORCE GRAHAM
AND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
APPLICATIONS WERE AWARDED FOR
A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION THERE THE REQUEST FOR
THE K. TWELVE C. T.
GRANT FUNDING TOTALED FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
MILLION HOWEVER ONLY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IS AVAILABLE
BETWEEN THE TWO PROGRAMS TO
FUNDS ET EAT THE CHART IN YOUR
AGENDA SHOWS THE DEMANDS FOR
THE TWO PROGRAMS WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE C.
T. E. ENROLLMENT INCREASED
BY TWELVE PERCENT DURING THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD OF FUNDING
TO TO SEE TAKE PROGRAM SO
WITH THAT I WOULD CONCLUDE
CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION I
WILL NOTE THAT I HAVE MICHELLE
MCINTOSH FROM THE CAREER
TRANSITION COLLEGE AND CAREER
TRANSITION DIVISION TO HELP ANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AMBER ALEXANDER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MAINTAINS
THE LEVEL OF FUNDING THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FOR BOTH THE CITY AND CENTER
GRANT PROGRAM AND THE CAKE ALL
COMPONENT OF THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY I
BELIEVE HER HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A HUNDRED MILLION
IN ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
IS PROVIDED FOR LOCAL GRANTS
UNDER EACH PROGRAM DIGITAL
TWELVE MILLION AN ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND IS PROVIDED TO
SUPPORT A REGIONAL LEADERSHIP
STRUCTURE TO ASSIST TEACHERS
AND INDUSTRY PARTNERS IN
IMPLEMENTING THEIR HIGH QUALITY
CTE PROGRAMS AN ADDITIONAL TWO
MILLION IS PROVIDED TO SUPPORT
THE RESEARCH REGIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ADMINISTERING
THE KICKOFF COMPONENT I'LL BE
KEEPING MY COMMENTS BRIEF AS
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
PROPOSE TO MAKE ANY CHANGES
TO THE LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR
EITHER PROGRAM I'M NOT TO
MAKE ANY STATUTORY CHANGES TO
THE STATUTE THAT GOVERNS LIKE
A PROGRAM WE WOULD HOWEVER
NOTE THAT IN ADDITION TO
THESE PROGRAMS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET CONTINUES TO PROVIDE
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND OUTSIDE
AT THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA TO SUPPORT FOR OTHER
HIGH SCHOOL CTE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OPERATED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION THOSE INCLUDE
TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
ACADEMIES FIFTEEN POINT FOUR
MILLION FOR THE CTE PATHWAYS
PROGRAM FOUR POINT NINE MILLION
FOR THE SPECIALIZED SECONDARY
PROGRAMS IN FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION FOR THE AGRICULTURAL
CTP INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY WITHIN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
ITSELF AN AMOUNT EQUAL TO
TWO POINT SIX PERCENT OF THE
LCS BASED GRANT IS PROVIDED
THROUGH THE NINE FOR TWELFTH
GRADE SPANISH JUST MEANT TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE HIGHER COST
OF PROVIDING CTE PROGRAMS
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
SPACE GRANT JUST MINIMUMS TO
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE MILLION AN ONGOING
FUNDING HAS BEEN BUILDING ON
TOP OF THE LCS BASED AND CAN
BE USED TO SUPPORT REFUGEE
PROGRAMS TO THE EXTENT THAT
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE LOCAL
PRIORITY BUT THAT WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY THANK YOU QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THROWDOWN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
REITERATE -- CONCERNED --
THAT I HAVE WITH REGARD TO
THE THE TWO PARTS OF THE CAR
TECHNOLOGY CATION MONEY ONE
GOING TO -- THE FIRM EDUCATION
FOR DOLING OUT OF THE CAGE
WELLS ANOTHER GOING TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I I'D BE
MY PREFERENCE AT THOSE ARE
PUT INTO ONE POT -- OF BECAUSE
IT JUST THERE'S NO REASON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM SHOULD
BE ADMINISTERING K.
TWELVE MONEY THERE'S NO
PRACTICAL REASON FOR THAT FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE -- BUT AS FAR AS
THE THE FUNDING ALLOCATED THE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ON THE
CITY SIDE -- I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT
WE HAVE A LOT OF ONE TIME MONEY
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY AND WHY DO I SAY
THAT BECAUSE AS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER I KNOW THAT C. T.
PROGRAMS ENGAGE KIDS AND ENGAGE
STUDENT IS A STUDENT SHOWS UP
TO SCHOOL AND OFTENTIMES -- C.
T. PROGRAMS CAPTURE THAT
STUDENT THAT MIGHT NOT BE
SO ACADEMICALLY INCLINED
OR ENGAGED IN -- BUT THAT
STUDENT MIGHT BE IN THE CARS
THAT STUDENT MIGHT BE INTO
CONSTRUCTION THAT STUDENT MIGHT
BE INTO SOMETHING OTHER THAN
GOING ON TO A FOR UNIVERSITY
WE NEED TO SERVE THE STUDENTS
AS WELL WHEN YOU SERVE THAT
STUDENTS ALSO SERVES OUR
ECONOMY GOING FORWARD TO SAID
TO ME INVESTING IN C.
T. PROGRAMS IS A NO BRAINER
IT GIVES BACK SOME OF
THE QUALITATIVE SOME OF
QUANTITATIVE FOR SURE
BUT IT SHOULD BE -- AN
EXTREME PRIORITY -- FOR THE
LEGISLATOR TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADEQUATELY FUND CAREER
TECHNOLOGY XIN IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE SEATED PROGRAM
-- RECEIVED THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY NINE APPLICATIONS
TOTALING THREE HUNDRED AND TEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
YET THERE WAS ONLY A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS -- --
AVAILABLE SO I CAN TELL YOU YOU
KNOW JUST BY THAT THAT ALONE
SHOWS YOU THAT THERE IS A HUGE
NEED AND HUGE WANT AND I HOPE
WE CAN MAKE A LARGER PRIORITY
THAT I SEE ON MY FAVOURITE
HERE BEFORE ME -- TODAY MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
-- GALLAGHER YEAH AND I WANT
TO JOIN IN THE COMMENTS -- FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH
-- YOU KNOW THESE PROGRAMS YOUR
TRULY DO KEEP KIDS ENGAGE AND
I JUST I'LL TELL YOU A QUICK
STORY -- WE STARTED DOING AN
EVENT ONE ABLE TO DO IT -- THIS
IS LAST YEAR BUT -- WE STARTED
DOING EVENT TWO YEARS AGO
-- WE DID A SIGNING DAY FOUR
KIDS WERE GRADUATING AND GOING
INTO A CEO FROM A C.
T. PROGRAM GOING INTO A
NO TECHNICAL OR VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM I MEAN YOU
SHOULD HAVE SEEN THE LOOKS
ON THESE KIDS FACE BECAUSE
WE ALWAYS TWO SIGNING DAYS
FOR PEOPLE TO SIGN TO GO PLAY
SPORTS YOU KNOW AT A THE BIG
COLLEGE -- YOU KNOW SOMEONE
THAT AND THAT'S GREAT BUT HOW
OFTEN DO WE ACTUALLY RECOGNIZE
THE STUDENTS WHO WERE YOU KNOW
THEY'RE GOING INTO A TECHNICAL
VOCATIONAL LEAD PROGRAM THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING THEY'VE THEY'VE
BEEN GETTING A GOOD BACKGROUND
IN THESE IN THESE BASICS TO GO
TO GO DIRECTLY INTO THE WORK
FORCE YOU KNOW ONCE THEY GET
THIS THIS TRAINING DONE AND
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE THEY GO
INTO THE WORK FORCE WITHOUT A
LOT OF DEBT MANY TIMES WITH NO
DEBT WHATSOEVER BECAUSE THESE
PROGRAMS YOU KNOW PROVIDE FOR
THEM WHILE THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR INSTRUCTION -- AND THEN
GO DIRECTLY INTO A GOOD PAYING
JOB YOU KNOW THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILY AND
THEY CAN PROVIDE -- YOU KNOW
FIRST THE STAND WILL FEATURE
BUT YOU SHOULD'VE SEEN THE LOOK
ON A LOT OF THESE KIDS HAVE
TO STOOD TO BE RECOGNIZED YEAH
FOR GOING ONTO A PROGRAM LIKE
THAT WE OFTEN FOCUS ON THE FOUR
UNIVERSITIES WE OFTEN FOCUS ON
ON THE SPORTS -- -- BUT THESE
KIDS WERE EXCITED ABOUT WHAT
THEY WERE GOING TO THE FIELDS
THAT THEY WERE GOING INTO A
NAY VERY ACROSS THE BOARD I
MEAN FROM FROM HIGH TECH YOU
KNOW TO MANUFACTURING TO --
HEAVY EQUIPMENT OPERATION --
ALL THESE DIFFERENT THINGS AND
AND THEIR JOBS THAT WE NEED
WELDERS I MEAN THEIR JOBS THAT
WE NEED TO BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE STATE TO -- YOU KNOW
PROVIDE FOR -- AT A STRONG
WORK FORCE YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS CALLED -- AND YET
WE DON'T SEE ANY INCREASE
OR SEEN INCREASES IN EVERY
OTHER AREA OF EDUCATION
EXCEPT THIS ONE THIS DOESN'T
EVEN GET A CALL INCREASE
IN THIS BUDGET WHAT DOES
THAT SAY TO THESE KIDS
ARE THEY VALUED ARE THESE
PROGRAMS VALUED THAT ARE
GETTING THAT ARE LITERALLY
GETTING OUR CHILDREN INTO GOOD
PAYING JOBS WITH ALMOST NO DEBT
MANY CASES NO DOUBT AT ALL AND
STARTING THEM OFF TO A GREAT
AND BRIGHT FUTURE RESUMES OTHER
PROGRAMS AND I'M NOT KNOCKING
THEM YOU KNOW BUT KIDS ARE
GRADUATING WITH A HUGE AMOUNT
OF DEBT WITH NO JOB TO GO TO
WHERE ARE PRIORITIES YOU
KNOW I MEAN I THINK THAT
IS AN ABSOLUTE SLAP IN THE
FACE THAT THIS GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAS NO INCREASE
WHATSOEVER AND TO THE C.
T. PROGRAMS AND WE SHOULDN'T
I THINK RESPOND ACCORDINGLY
BY SAYING NO WE VALUE THESE
KIDS WE VALUE THESE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE PREPARING PEOPLE FOR
A BRIGHTER FUTURE AND THEY'RE
GETTING THEM INTO A STRONG
WORK FORCE AND I THINK IT WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD DEFINITELY
BE LOOKING AT INCREASING THAT
FUNDING AND MAYBE LOOKING
AT HEY HOW DO WE MOVE MOST
EFFICIENTLY YOU KNOW GET THAT
FUNDING DOWN TO THESE PROGRAMS
THAT THAT ARE CLEARLY WORKING
THANK YOU SOMEONE EVER LEAVE
THAN MR MEDINA THANK YOU SIR I
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUES AND I
DEFINITELY WANT ALSO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR INCREASING CZ E.
FUNDING WE HAVE REMARKABLE
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
HAVE PROVEN SUCCESS AT NOT
ONLY OF COURSE ISN'T AS THEY
SAID SERVE OUR STUDENTS AND
SET THEM UP FOR SUCCESS BUT
ALSO SERVE OUR ECONOMY AND
THAT OUR ECONOMY UP FOR FUTURE
SUCCESS AS WELL I'M ACTUALLY
PROUD THAT IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY FIVE WE HAVE ONE CITY
CENTER THAT SERVES MULTIPLE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS OTHER
SOMEBODY DISTRICTS AS WELL THAT
IS A HUGE PRIORITY FOR US --
AND YOU KNOW I I UNDERSTAND
THAT DEFINITELY WHEN WE
CHANGE THE L. C. F.
F. FUNDING THE CENTERS LOST
OUT ON ADA FUNDING AND CENTERS
SHOULD NOT BE DISADVANTAGED
BUT SHOULD BE MADE A PRIORITY
IN CITIES WHEN THEY EXIST
TO MAXIMIZE THE DOLLARS AND
OPPORTUNITIES STUDENTS THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE THEIR FUTURE
-- SHE'S EXISTENCE THREATENED
AT ALL -- BUT ALSO CONNECTS
TO MY COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES
MADE I WANT TO ASK CD HAVE
YOU CONSIDERED PROVIDING
PRIORITY OR LARGER PERCENTAGE
TO CENTERS THAT SERVE SEVERAL
DISTRICTS ESSENTIALLY FUND
THE SEVENTEEN EXISTING CENTERS
FIRST AND THEN TALK ABOUT THE
REST OF THE CITY AND CENTER
READ DOLLARS TO GO TO THE
REST OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SALLY'S WERE FINDING WHAT WE
KNOW EXISTS AND WORKS ALREADY
THE GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF EDUCATION TONY THURMOND
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT THAT WE'RE
HEARING FOR THE C.
T. PROGRAM AND THE C.
TAKE DOLLARS I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE
MICHELLE MCINTOSH ABOUT
PRIORITIZING COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS OVER SINGLE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SITUATIONS BUT SHALL
BE TAKEN ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
SALLY AND SO I'M YES WE HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT THE AT THE
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE THOUGH IS
THAT IN LEGISLATION -- AND THAT
WE FOLLOW EDUCATION LEGISLATION
AND WE FOLLOW THE --
CALCULATION AND THE ALLOCATION
AND LEGISLATION -- SO THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE SOMETHING
IN LEGISLATION -- POSSIBLY A
POSITIVE CONSIDERATION THAT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO BE ADDED
AND JUST FOR MY BENEFIT WHAT
LEGISLATION WOULD WOULD YOU
BE REFERRING TO SO THAT WOULD
BE THE CTA THAT LEGISLATION --
SPECIFICALLY YES THANK YOU WELL
I I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT
BECAUSE EVEN IF FOR OPERATING
ASSUMPTION WE HAVE LIMITED
FUNDS WHICH OF COURSE ARE
PIE KEEPS GROWING FORTUNATELY
FOR US WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY TWICE THE AVAILABLE
TO THE DEMAND IS TWICE THE
EXCEEDING OF FUNDS WE EVEN HAVE
SO EVEN IF WE HAD TO PRIORITIZE
I WANT THAT TO BE CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD BE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IF YOU WANTED TO
PURSUE SOME LEGISLATION TO
CHANGE THE STATUTE ON THAT
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THAT
IT AMBER ALEXANDER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'D
ALSO LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT
AND AND JUST NOTE THAT THERE
IS QUITE A BIT OF FLEXIBILITY
IN THE STATUTE AND -- THERE
IS ACTUALLY A POSITIVE
CONSIDERATION CURRENTLY FOR
-- PROGRAMS THAT ENGAGE IN
REGIONAL COOPERATION WITH POST
SECONDARY PARTNERS -- OR OTHER
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES SO
I THINK THERE'S SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY THERE -- IT'S JUST
A MATTER OF HOW MUCH PRIORITY
DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
PROVIDING TO THAT CONSIDERATION
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE DISCUSSED PARTNER
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER I
JUST WANT TO VERY MUCH ECHO
REITERATE -- AND MY COLLEAGUES
ARE SAYING AND I I SAW FIRST
HAND THE THE NEGATIVE EFFECT
OF WHEN WE CLOSED -- SOME
OF THESE -- CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AT MY OWN
HIGH SCHOOL AND AND AS A MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH SAID
IN A STUDENTS COME TO SCHOOL
WITH -- DIFFERENT INTERESTS
DIFFERENT -- DIFFERENT --
-- TALENTS AND CERTAINLY OF
THOSE STUDENTS WHO COME WITH
-- WITH THAT INTEREST SHOULD
BE ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FLOURISH AND I LIKED -- AND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHICO'S SAID
GIVEN THE RECOGNITION AS WELL
BUT WE DON'T DO ENOUGH TO LET
STUDENTS KNOW THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM IN
THEIR FUTURE IN THE CAREERS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM
AND SO -- VERY MUCH WANT TO
SEE A MORE TIGHT ENDS WITH
THE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS AND
LETTING STUDENTS KNOW BETTER
WHAT THE TRADES ARE AND WITH
THOSE CAREER OPPORTUNITIES ARE
CERTAINLY THERE HIGH PAYING
JOBS A MUCH IN DEMAND AND SO
VERY MUCH SUPPORT BY FUNDING
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION OF
MORE THANK YOU YEAH MISTER MISS
REYES AND NOT BACK TO MISTER
DONNA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IT WAS I WAS VERY INTERESTED
IN SAYING THE STATISTICS THAT
ARE NOTED AT THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE TWENTY SIX THAT NINETY
ONE PERCENT OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES WERE IN TWO TO
THREE CTE CREDITS ENROLLED IN
COLLEGE ALSO ABOUT -- AND WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT THE
THE FACT THAT THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE EXPOSED TO TWO CITIES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND ROLL INTO
YOUR COLLEGE BUT THE ONE THAT
I WAS MOST INTERESTED IN IS
THAT STUDENTS TAKING MORE CTE
CLASSES ARE JUST AS LIKELY
TO PURSUE A FOUR YEAR DEGREE
AS THEIR PEERS THIS SEEMS A
LITTLE UNLIKELY TO ME BUT CAN
SOMEBODY COMMENT ON THAT PLEASE
ABSOLUTELY L. A. GARNER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT EDUCATION IN THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION WE WOULD NOTE THAT
NOT ALL CTE CAREER PATHWAYS ARE
JUST ABOUT GOING TO THE CAREER
THERE ARE MANY IN THE STEM
FIELDS OR IN THE HEALTHCARE
FIELD THE END UP LEADING TO
A FOUR YEAR DEGREE A TWO YEAR
DEGREE OR EVEN HIGHER EDUCATION
SO IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THE
PATHWAY AND INDUSTRY SECTOR
SO THERE ISN'T NECESSARILY
-- UP FOR LEASING TO SIMPLY
GOING STRAIGHT TO CAREERS BUT
IN AS STEPS TOWARD CAREERS
VIA COLLEGE AS WELL I THANK
YOU IT SO IT SEEMS THAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT
TO ME IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T PIGEONHOLE A STUDENT
AND TELL THEM THIS IS THE
YOUR ONLY PATH YOU SHOULDN'T
GO TO COLLEGE HERE YOU JUST
GO GET A CAREER OR GO GET A
PROFESSION BUT THE FACT THAT
THEY CAN HAVE EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TAKE THESE COURSES THEY
CAN BEGIN TO TO ESPECIALLY WITH
THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
OR YOU KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO
JOIN A UNION AND THEY'RE GOING
TO GET GOOD PAYING GOOD PAYING
WAGES BUT I THINK MAKING SURE
THAT WE LET OUR STUDENTS KNOW
THAT EVERY OPTION IS AVAILABLE
TO THEM IT DAYS IT'S NOT THAT
THEY ONLY QUALIFY FOR ONE OR
ONLY QUALIFY FOR ANOTHER BUT
THAT WE WE WANT THEM TO SUCCEED
WHEREVER THEY WANT TO BE BUT
MAKING SURE THAT ALL DOORS
ARE OPEN TO THEM THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL I THANK YOU
ARE MISTER CHAIR LARGEST A
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HOW MUCH TO CD AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVE
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
AMBER ALEXANDER WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO SPECIFIC TO THESE
TWO PROGRAMS AND THERE'S TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S PROVIDED
FOR THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
STRUCTURE I'M BUT IT IS A
REGIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TRACTORS SO THOSE PROVIDERS
ARE AND THEY'RE SEVENTY TWO
WORKFORCE PATHWAY COORDINATORS
AT LEAST SEVENTY OF THOSE
POSITIONS ARE FILLED I'M AS
WELL AS EIGHT AND CAPE OR
FOURTEEN TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS AT THE ATM PROCESS
THAT'S GOING TO BE -- THOSE
CREDITS ARE CURRENTLY SELECTED
BY THE SUPERINTENDENT AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE -- BUT IT
IS NOT A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
I'M STRUCTURE THAT EITHER THE
DEPARTMENT OR THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE PROVIDES IN ADDITION
TO THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION -- IS THAT RECEIVES
TWO POSITIONS AND TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
SPECIFIC TO THE E. M.
C. T. AND CENTER GRANT PROGRAM
SORRY SORRY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS WHAT I'M SORRY
I APOLOGIZE TWO POSITIONS IN
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ON GOING FUNDING --
FOR THE CITY INCENTIVE GRANT
THAT'S TO SUPPORT TWO POSITIONS
AND THEIR -- CULKIN CAREER
DIVISION SO CD GALLAGHER ON
BEHALF OF THE GOVERNOR ON THAT
THE STATE'S DIFFERENT HAVE
PUBLIC SECTION IF I MADE THAT
PUTT ASSEMBLY MEMBER YES YES
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WORK FOR MUCH OF THIS
SPACE -- SPECIFICALLY HAS
BEEN TRANSFERRED TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SINCE
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
CHANGE THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE -- HAVE THIS EASY
EAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS THAT ARE CHARGED
WITH PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SEE TAKE
PROGRAM AND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE IS PROVIDING TWELVE
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR THEIR
EIGHT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS AND THE SEVENTY TWO
PATHWAY COORDINATORS THAT DO
SUCH WORK HOWEVER WE WOULD
NOTE OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
SINCE THE TRANSITION THE SEATS
CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER THE CTT
PROGRAM WHILE ALSO SPENDING
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
DIRECTLY TO THE ALLEY A GRANT
RECIPIENTS CD DOES NOT AND HAS
NOT RECEIVED ANY FUNDS FOR THIS
T. PAY WHILE THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE STRONG WORK
FORCE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS AND CATHOLIC
MARKETERS HAVE BEEN PREPARING
AND TRAINING TO PROVIDE
THIS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GO SYSTEMS THAT -- THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED BY CVS STAFF
INCLUDES ANSWERING MULTIPLE
DAILY PROGRAM RELATED PHONE
CALLS AND EMAILS PROVIDING
MULTIPLE DATA REPORTING AND
EXPENDITURE REPORTING WEBINARS
AND REPORTING WITH ELEAZAR
ONE ON ONE TO ENSURE THAT
DATA AND EXPENDITURES ARE
REPORTED CORRECTLY APPROVING
CAPITAL OUTLAYS OUTLAY REQUEST
AND APPROVING THE RAISE
EXPENDITURES DISEASED STAFF
HAS PROVIDED TRAININGS SHE THEY
AT THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS AND THE CATHOLIC
PARTY DOES ABOUT THE SEA TECH
PROGRAM DURING THE FIRST AREN'T
ONBOARDING PROGRAMS DURING THE
SUMMER AND IT DURING THE FALL
OF TWENTY TWENTY AND STAFF
HAS ALSO PROVIDED TRAININGS
TO DATE THAT TRACK TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND THE
PC'S REGARDING THE EXPENDITURE
REPORTING AND DATA COLLECTION
THAT IS REQUIRED FOR C.
TAG HOWEVER EVEN WITH THESE
TRAININGS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED OUR TEAM BELIEVES THAT
MUCH MORE TRAINING IS REQUIRED
TO GET THOSE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAMS THAT TAPS AND HE SEES
TO A LEVEL WHERE THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO BE THE SOLE PROVIDER
OF SERVICES AT THE SAME TIME
AS OUR CD HAS PROVIDED THAT
WORK GREAT THANK YOU I I THINK
WHAT YOU'VE SAID AND JUST
WILL HIGHLIGHT HERE IS THE CD
GETS A COUPLE HUNDRED THOUSAND
BUCKS TO COMPLETE THE TASK OF
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BUT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM GETS ABOUT TWELVE TO
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO OTHERS AS SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITY THAT MEANS THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT GAP IN THE ABILITY
OF THE TWO ORGANIZATIONS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF A LOCAL
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO WE NEED TO HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THANK YOU WITH
THANK YOU I'M JUST
LAST COMMENTS OFF ON
THIS OBVIOUSLY C.
T. IS A EXTREMELY POPULAR WITH
LEGISLATORS BOTH REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRATS ALWAYS THIS IS
A TOP PRIORITY TO INCREASE
FUNDING I JUST WANTED TO ADD
ON THE COURSE OF A FEW THINGS
IS THAT YOU KNOW ALL THIS TALK
ABOUT COLLEGE AND CAREER WHAT
WE DO KNOW IS THAT ALL THE
REQUIRE MORE THAN A HIGH SCHOOL
DEGREE SO WHETHER IT'S COLLEGE
OR A CAREER TECHNICAL PROGRAM
THROUGH OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND OTHER VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS
CITY IS REALLY THE LINK TO
THAT -- FOR THE WORK FORCE
ERIC FOR EMPLOYERS AND NEED
PEOPLE TO FILL THESE JOBS AND
RECENT REPORTS ALL THE TIME
AS FAR AS NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
TO FILL THE BLUE COLLAR JOBS
-- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT TEXAS OF
COURSE WE'LL JUST SI'S REPORTS
RECENTLY IN TEXAS THEY COULDN'T
FIND A PEOPLE TO FIX ALL THE
PLUMBING WHEN THE PIPES BURST
BECAUSE AS I'VE PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO TAKE JOBS SOMETIMES
PAR SIX FIGURE JOBS AND CAN
THAT REALLY HAVE A REAL BAD
CAREER A LADDER TO TO -- GOOD
PAYING -- POSITION THEY CAN
YOU KNOW CHANGE THE TWO TRACTOR
OF YOUR FAMILY AND SO FORTH SO
WE NEED THESE -- -- BUT ALSO
YOU KNOW IT KEEP KIDS -- FROM
DROPPING OUT EVERYTHING ELSE
SO I'M ALL FOR THAT I THINK WE
SHOULD PROVIDE THE FULL CALL
OUT AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM EAST
NECKLACE NOTED AND I I I KNOW
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON THIS FOR
FOR YEARS TO I CAN CARE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH SAID
HAVING A UNIFIED PROGRAM IN THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION IS BETTER
GOING TO OUR SCHOOLS THEY KNOW
WHAT SENIOR VAST -- IT ALL
SOUNDS GOOD WITH THESE LOCAL
REGIONAL COLLABORATIONS AND --
BUT I THINK THEY GET THE WAY
FROM WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING
ON THE GROUND SO -- I WOULD
SUPPORT CONSULTING BACK TO CD
AND THAT'S A LITTLE I THINK
THE SOUND IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO PUSH SO WITH THAT WELL THIS
ISSUE OPEN PROCEED NOW WITH
THE NEXT ISSUE NUMBER -- FIVE
THIS IS A WAY TO OUR -- ON THE
BEST TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS
GOOD MORNING LISTENING WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- THE
GENERAL ALREADY LAID OUT THE
ITEMS IN DETAIL SO I'LL JUST
QUICKLY RUN THROUGH THE LIST
OF GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TRAILER
BILL FOLD OLES AS DISPLAYED
IN THE AGENDA ON PAGES THIRTY
AND THIRTY ONE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES LANGUAGE TO
CLARIFY WHICH PROGRAMS SERVING
ADULT STUDENTS IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS COULD GENERATE LCF
BATH I'M REQUIRES ANNUAL
REPORTING AND GRANDFATHERS AND
-- CHARTER SCHOOLS CURRENTLY
SERVING ADULTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE EXISTING STATUTE TO BE
CAPPED AT THEIR NINETEEN TWENTY
UPCOMING LEVEL IT ALSO PROVIDES
THREE POINT ONE MILLION IN
ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
THE FOURTH YEAR COST OF THE
STANDARDIZED ACCOUNT CODE
STRUCTURE SYSTEM REPLACEMENT
PROJECT -- PROVIDES FOR
MILLION IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND THE FOR SPECIAL OLYMPICS
OF NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR VARIOUS
PROGRAMS CLARIFIES CHANGES TO
THE PROCESS BY WHICH COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION BUDGETS
ARE CERTIFIED AND OVERSEEN
BY THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION -- INCLUDES
LANGUAGE TO CHANGE THE MAXIMUM
OR PAYMENT HERE YET FOR FUNDS
OLD BY DISTRICTS TO SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAMS FROM FIVE
YEARS TO TWENTY YEARS ALIGNING
WITH THE REPAYMENT HANG ON
EMERGENCY APPORTIONMENT --
LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CONTROL OVER LIFE STATION
PROCESS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
LANGUAGE THAT REVISES THAT
CALCULATION OF PENALTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING ATTENDANCE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE FUNDING CALCULATION FOR
PIONEER UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND PARADISE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT PROVIDE FUNDING
RELIEF RELATED TO NATURAL
DISASTERS IN WHICH TO SUSPEND
THE CALCULATION OF ALLOCATING
CHARTER SCHOOL EIGHTY EIGHT TO
A SPONSORING SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR AND LANGUAGE TO
REDUCE FUNDING A PORTION TO
-- CHARTER SCHOOL THAT CLOSED
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEAR AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY OVERVIEW I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND I ALSO HAVE
MY COLLEAGUES AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
MAY HAPPEN YES PROPOSALS
JUST MENTIONED THANK YOU
THANK YOU L. A. R.
MICHAEL WITH THE L.
A. L. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THESE BILLS AT THIS TIME
BUT HAVE BEEN ANSWERED A
QUESTION THE CORPORATE THANK
YOU OKAY PART OF EDUCATION
SALLY NINE ON BEHALF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AS
THE PREVIOUS PANELIST ON THE
AGENDA NOTED MANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE SUCH AS THE AB TWELVE
HUNDRED CLEAN UP OR CLARIFYING
THE FINANCIAL PENALTIES FOR
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH DISTRICT
LEARNING STEPS AND DISTANCE
LEARNING STATUTES EXCUSE ME
WE WILL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION ON ANY
NECESSARY TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THESE PROPOSALS THAT CONCLUDES
MY TESTIMONY AND I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
BUT THE PROBLEM IS FOR MANY
MEMBERS PLAYED ANY THOUGHT OF
WITH THE MEDIA ON ON THE ARM
CAP ON A CHARTER SCHOOLS --
AND THE CAP ON SERVING ADULTS
PENSION I SEE THAT THAT SOME
WOULD BE GRANDFATHERED IN
WHAT WHAT EFFECT WITH WITH
THESE WOULD THIS HAVE ON FOR
EXAMPLE THE FIELD PROGRAM
WHAT'S THE AND WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO --
SO FAR THE PROGRAMS WE ARE
GRANDFATHERING IN EXISTING
PROGRAMS OUT THERE NINETEEN
TWENTY FUNDING LEVELS SO IF
THEY WERE SERVING ADULTS ABOVE
THE AGE LIMITS -- YEAH PURSUANT
TO OUR NEW NEW PROPOSAL PRIOR
TO THE JULY TWENTY TWENTY THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO SER
UP TO THAT NUMBER OF STUDENTS
STOP BY ANY -- ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE NEW REQUIREMENTS SO WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO CONTROL
THE GROWTH OF THESE PROGRAMS
BUT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO START
UP TO THEM NOW THAT THEY WERE
SERVING IN NINETEEN TWENTY SO
A PROGRAM LIKE THE FEEL PROGRAM
WOULD BE ABLE TO EXPAND CORRECT
CORRECT THEY COULD STILL STAND
UP TO THE PROGRAMMATIC ELEMENTS
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE --
THAT HAVE NOT CHANGED I I I
THINK I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THEN -- WHAT AN EXCELLENT JOB
I BELIEVE THE FIELD PROGRAM IS
DOING WITH THE ADULT POPULATION
THAT THEY'RE WORKING WITH OF
MANY TIMES RURAL OF FARMWORKER
POPULATION SO -- JUST TO
SHARE MY CONCERN THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
DONALD I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I APPRECIATE THE LANGUAGE
IN THE TRAILER BILL MY CONCERN
IS NOT AGGRESSIVE ENOUGH THAT
MAYBE IT'S A PLACE WE CAN
LAND IN THE END -- I THINK BUT
PEOPLE NEED TO REALIZE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE OPENING SERVING
ADULTS ENROLLING THEM AS FIRST
GRADERS AND ESSENTIALLY TAKING
MONEY AWAY FROM THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM -- IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THERE ISN'T A PLACE
FOR THIS TYPE OF LEARNING
BUT I DON'T THINK IT WAS EVER
INTENDED THAT COME FROM THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM -- SO THAT THAT
THAT'S THE CONCERN WERE REALLY
TRYING TO ADDRESS AND SOME OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN CONDUCTING THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY SOMETIMES HAVE SOME
ISSUES OF THEIR OWN QUITE
FRANKLY -- SO -- THIS IS ABOUT
PROTECTING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT I DO I WANT TO SERVE
ADULTS YES -- BUT SHOULDN'T
NECESSARILY COME FROM -- YOU
KNOW SIX GRADERS CLASSROOM
BECAUSE AN ORGANIZATION HAS
CHOSEN TO ENROLL FOUR YEAR OLD
IN FIRST OR SECOND GRADE --
I DON'T THINK SO AND THAT'S
REALLY THE ISSUE THEY'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS IT ISN'T THAT IT
ISN'T A JUDGMENT ON THE FIELD
PROGRAM I DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
IT -- AS MUCH IS A STATEMENT
AND SOME POLICY ASSOCIATED WITH
PROTECTING -- THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER VITAS
-- WHAT WILL THE CDC BE ABLE TO
USE ENROLLMENT DATA TO INFORM
THE LEGISLATURE SHIFTS BETWEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND NON ENROLLMENT
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SCHOOL YEAR AND IF THOSE
ENROLLMENT PATTERNS CHANGE --
WELL THE RETURN OF AND WITH THE
RETURN OF AN IN PERSON LEARNING
I'M SORRY I THINK YOU WERE
ASKING US C. B. E.
A QUESTION CAN YOU REPEAT
YOUR QUESTION I APOLOGIZE
YEAH WILL THIS CD E.
BE ABLE TO USE THE ENROLLMENT
DATA TO INFORM THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT THE SHIPS BETWEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND NON ENROLLMENT
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SCHOOL YEAR -- AND IF
THOSE ENROLLMENT PATTERNS
CHANGE WITH THE RETURNED
TO AND PERSON INSTRUCTION
WE WILL CERTAINLY BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ENROLLMENT DATA
THAT WILL INFORM WHAT THAT
CAN INFORM THE LEGISLATURE
ABSOLUTELY I WILL I WILL
TELL YOU THAT THERE WAS SOME
EXTENSION ON SCHOOLS PROVIDING
THEIR ENROLLMENT DATA LATE THIS
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE CHANGES
THAT WERE TAKING PLACE IN THE
IN THE SCHOOL YEAR SO WE ARE A
LITTLE BIT BEHIND IN PROVIDING
A MOMENT OUT OF WHAT WE WILL
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT TO
THE LEGISLATURE VERY SOON
THANK YOU AND AND WHEN WAS THE
LAST TIME STATE FUNDING WAS
PROVIDED TO SUPPORT FOR THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS OF NORTHERN
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
I BELIEVE I'M GONNA DEFERRED
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ON ON THAT ALEXANDER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
THINK THERE WAS A SIMILAR
PREPARATION INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AND
NOT THAT OF THE MOST RECENT --
APPROPRIATION -- YOU KNOW APART
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL THANK YOU I JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU KNOW -- HAVING
BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS PREVIOUSLY IN MY
ROLE AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR AUTISM SPEAKS -- IT'S
A PROGRAM AN OPPORTUNITY --
THAT REALLY IS IS AS INCLUSIVE
AS IT GOT SENT A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM SO -- WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IN CONSIDERATION
OF MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO EVER --
GALLAGHER YES EARNS
THE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
ON THE CHARTER SCHOOL
-- SERVING STUDENTS ARE
PARTICIPATING IN STATE AND
FEDERAL JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS
THAT TO ME SEEMS LIKE A
REASONABLE WAY OF ENSURING
THESE PROGRAMS NEED -- THE
GOALS INTENDED -- BUT THE THE
TRAILER BILL RIGHT NOW KIND
OF GOES BEYOND CLARIFYING
-- CURRENT LIVE ACTION CAPS
FUNDING ON THESE CHARTERS AT
THEIR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
LEVELS AND SO MY CONCERN HERE
IS IF A CHARTER SCHOOL AND
HERE'S TO THE NEWLY CLARIFIED
REQUIREMENTS WHY ARE WE
PLANNING TO IMPOSE A FUNDING
CAP BASED ON THE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE IN PLACE BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC YET IT LOOKS
TO ME FROM WHAT WE'RE SEEING
THAT ACTUALLY -- WE'RE SEEING
MORE DROPOUTS IN HIGH SCHOOL
-- AND THAT COULDN'T THAT'S
LIKELY INCREASING DURING THIS
TIME SHOULD WE HAVE SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS IN PLACE --
AND AGAIN AS LONG AS THEY'RE
ABIDING BY THE REQUIREMENTS
WHY PUT A CAP ON THE
WHAT'S THE AND WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE
PURPOSE OF THE GRANDFATHERING
CLAUSE IS WE WANT TO LIMIT
THE FISCAL IMPACT EXISTING
ADULT PROGRAMS RECEIVING LCS
FAST BUT IT'S ALSO OR INTENT
TO ENSURE THAT K.
TWELVE I'LL SEE IF FUNDING
IS PRIORITIZE FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN -- SO THIS IS REALLY
TRYING TO CONTROL THE GROWTH
OF THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ARE --
SERVING A DOUBLE STEP RECKLESS
FELL EDUCATION PROGRAM AND NOW
SQUEEZING OUT THE L. C.
ABOUT THAT WOULD OTHERWISE K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS
RIGHT AND I MEAN IN THIS WHEN
I CALLED FROM LONG BEACH AND I
AGREE ON MANY THINGS EDUCATION
BUT I I DO DIVERGE FROM HIM ON
THE ON THE ADULT EDUCATION I
THINK THAT IS IMPORTANT -- AND
YEAH WE CERTAINLY HAVE A LOT OF
SPECULATION THAT YOU KNOW FOR
WHATEVER REASON DID NOT GET THE
EDUCATION -- THAT THEY NEED ARE
NOW TRYING TO GET YOU KNOW BACK
INTO -- NO MORE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE NEED NEED THAT EDUCATION
GET THAT THIS IS YOUNG ANOTHER
PATHWAY I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE -- I MEAN
ARE WE UNDULY LIMITING THAT
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW OR WE
HELLO I'M KIND OF CONFUSED ON
THAT ARE WE ALLOWING FOR THAT
ARE WE NOT ALLOWED FOR THAT
THAT QUESTION YEAH
THE ENGLISH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE WE'VE BEEN
SEEING TREND THAT -- LCF AB
GOING TOWARDS ADULTS HAS BEEN
INCREASING IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS EACH YEAR SO I THINK
WE WE JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT -- WANT TO CONTROL FOR
THIS GROWTH BECAUSE WE DO
SEE IT YOU KNOW TAKING A
LARGER BITE OUT OF LCF AFTER
YEAH
CAN I INTERJECT FOR A
FEW SECONDS ON THIS SO
YOU KNOW THIS IS A REAL
INTERESTING TOPIC THAT WE
TRY TO TACKLE LAST YEAR
DURING COVER NINETEEN AND
WE COULDN'T AND WE DID HEAR
FROM SOME OF THESE -- ADULT
ED CHARTER SCHOOLS IN OUR
DISTRICTS ARE DOING GREAT
WORK ONE HERE IN OUR AREA MR
GALLAGHER'S HIGHLANDS CHARTER
WHICH IS SERVICE YEP AND THE
PART BE YOUR PART DISTRICT
IN MIND WHICH TAKES ADULTS --
PREDOMINATELY -- YEAH EASTERN
EUROPEAN IMMIGRANTS LATINOS
SOME AFRICAN AMERICANS WELL
FORMER INCARCERATED AND HAS
A TREMENDOUS SUCCESS RECORD
AND I THINK THEY WENT FROM
THE LAST FIVE YEARS FROM THREE
HUNDRED STUDENTS TO MAYBE THREE
THOUSAND SO A MASSIVE INCREASE
SO THEY'RE DOING GOOD COULD
WORK BUT I THINK THE QUESTION
THAT THAT WE'RE ASKING IS
IS THERE GETTING L.
CFF DOLLARS AND I'M GONNA
PAINT A BROAD STROKE HERE
AND ASK FINANCED TO CLARIFY
IT BUT THEY'RE GETTING HURT
STUDENT LIKE WELL WELL NORTH
OF TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
STUDENT MAYBE LIKE TWELVE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A STUDENT FOR LCS PATH
CLASSIFYING THEM AS A FOURTH
GRADER AT TENTH GRADER A
FIRST GRADER BASED UPON THEIR
LANGUAGE SKILLS WE HAVE THIS
TRADITIONAL ADULTS SCHOOLS AND
MY DISTRICT IN YOUR DISTRICT
IN YOUR DISTRICT WHICH SERVE
THE SAME POPULATION SAME ADULTS
AND ADULTS SCHOOLS BY NICHOLAS
DISTRACT SOME TO WERE IN LONG
BEACH SAC CITY SO FORTH AND
THEY GET ABOUT HALF OF THAT
MONEY OR LESS AND SO THESE
THESE ADULT CHARTER SCHOOLS
IF I WAS THEM I DO THE SAME
THING IF THERE'S TWO WINDOWS
AND YOU WANT TO SERVE AN
ADULT IS THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD
EARNING ENGLISH YOU CAN GET
REIMBURSED FROM THE STATE FOR
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENT OVER HERE
FOR FOURTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
WHY WOULD THEY GO TO THAT
WINDOW THEY'RE GONNA GO TO THIS
WINDOW AND SO WE'RE SEEING THIS
INCREASE INCREASE SO IF YOU DID
NOTHING THESE ADULT ED PROGRAMS
WOULD GO OUT OF BUSINESS
BECAUSE IT JUST HAPPENED THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO GO TO THE
WINDOW NUMBER TWO RIGHT AND SO
I THINK WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
NOT THROW THE BABY OUT WITH THE
BATHWATER TO RECOGNIZE THESE
ADULT SCHOOLS BUT YOU KNOW
HAVING THIS MASSIVE INCREASE
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR IS
IT FAIR TO DO TRADITIONAL ADULT
SCHOOLS AND IT CHIPS AWAY AT
THE FUNDING FOR LCS FAST AND SO
I THINK WHAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS COME UP WITH A FAIR
COMPROMISE SO IF YOU CAN JUST
UNRAVELING IN CCD E.
OR R. OR AT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WHAT'S ROUGHLY
THE -- PER STUDENT --
REIMBURSEMENT FOR TRADITIONAL
ADULT SCHOOLS THROUGH SKIP
THREE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSPECTION I'M GOING TO
DEFER BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON THAT ONE
PRETTY MUCH --
WHEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- UNFORTUNATELY
I DON'T HAVE THOSE NUMBERS
PUBLIC HAND FOR THE AT THE
-- EDUCATION PROGRAM THERE
IS -- ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED FOR ON THE COMPLETE
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM --
BUT FOR THOSE SPECIFIC NUMBERS
WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT GET
BACK TO YOU YEAH AND AND HOW
MUCH DO STUDENTS WITH THESE
AT THE ADULT CHARTER SCHOOLS
GET ROUGHLY PER STUDENT
HE WAS
YEAH WELL LUCKY I K.
SEEMS THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THE
CORRECT ANSWERS THE DOLLARS
AMOUNT BUT IF IF YOU CAN
GIVE A BALLPARK THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL BUT BUT YOU CAN
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG THAT
THE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
YOU GET THROUGH TRADITIONAL
DAHLE SCHOOL LIKE SAC CITY
HOUSES CHARLES JONES SCHOOL
SKILL CENTER HERE ON STOCKTON
BOULEVARD THREE MILES DOWN THE
ROAD AND THEN JUST DOWN THE
STREET THERE'S A CHARTER ADULTS
SCHOOL AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS YOU GET ALMOST THREE
TIMES MORE IF YOU GET THE --
TELL CFF AMOUNT THROUGH THE
CHARTER ADULT SCHOOL VERSUS
A TRADITIONAL DAHLE SCHOOL
IS THAT CORRECT OR AM I WRONG
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROUGHT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
A MARRIAGE THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
DOING ALL THE DESCRIPTION
OF IT I THINK IT IS ACTUALLY
TRUST WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE
USING ONE OF THE AFFECT
YOU ARE GENERATING A HIGHER
AMOUNT OF FUNDING UNDER MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER STUDENT RANGE ALSO NOTE
THAT AND RAFI APART IF IT
CONTINUES TO APPROPRIATIONS SO
IF AND ONLY IF THE ATTENDANCE
GO UP AND DOWN BALLOT IS
AUTOMATICALLY PROVIDED IF
YOU DON'T GET THE PROGRAM
BACK FROM JUST ABOUT IT TOO
DIFFICULT SOCIAL WHO THEN
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS AMONG
THE MEMBERS OF THE PREFERRED
FUNDING MODEL NOT A GREAT
LIFT THE GROWTH FUNDING IS
PROVIDED WITHIN THE BUDGET I'M
IF NOT AUTOMATICALLY THAT IS A
DIFFERENT YES SO THEY E.
SOMEONE COULD GET BACK TO US
WITH THE EXACT NUMBERS BUT
YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY SAYING
THAT MY CHARACTER RACE AND
CHARACTERIZATION IS IS FAIRLY
ACCURATE AND I THINK THAT
THE PROOF IS IN THE IN THE
PUTTING HERE IS THAT -- A
CHAR EDUCATION SHERM MAN FROM
LONG BEACH SAYS DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH WE SHOULD GET RID OF ALL
THIS AND WE DON'T HAVE SOME OF
THE EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS
YOU KNOW BANGING ON OUR DOOR
RIGHT NOW THEY COULD BE LINING
UP BUT WE'VE HEARD THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THEM WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT FIELD
-- ARE SUPPORTIVE OF HAVING THE
GRANDFATHER CLAUSE AND HAVING
YOU KNOW BASICALLY STABILIZE
THIS THIS THIS PROGRAM LET
THE CURRENT ONES THAT ARE
OPERATING AT STILL DO WELL --
HAVING MORE REQUIREMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
LINKED UP WITH -- ENTITIES
THAT PROVIDE ACTUALLY QUALITY
PROGRAMS AND MODELS THAT
ACTUALLY WORK AND SO ON YEAH
WE'RE GONNA KEEP WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE BUT POTENTIALLY THIS
IS A -- A DECENT -- COMPROMISE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VIDAK: SO MY
QUESTION IS JUST IF IF WE'VE
CLARIFIED THE RULES AND THE
CHARGERS ARE ABIDING BY THE
LAWS RULES THAT WE'VE CLARIFIED
WHY ARE WE GONNA CAPIT
SAME WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- LOWER CLASS CLEARING
THE RULES BECAUSE CURRENT
LAW IS KIND OF VAGUE ON THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE EXCLUSIVELY IN PARTNERSHIP
WE ALSO DON'T CURRENTLY
COLLECT ANY INFORMATION BUT
AT THE SAME TIME -- YOU KNOW
WE WE ARE TRYING TO CONTROL
THE GROWTH OF THESE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE COMPETING WITH ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND THAT
IS THE REASON FOR FOR THE CAP
THANK YOU
YEAH AGAIN I THINK THIS IS
A FAIR COMPROMISE AND IF WE
DID NOTHING YOU WOULD SEE
THESE CONTINUE TO PROLIFERATE
HAVE A TENFOLD INCREASE AND
I THINK NOW IT'S NEARLY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WE
SPENT AND IT WAS JUST MILLIONS
OF YEARS AGO SO IN THREE OR
FOUR YEARS WE COULD BE GETTING
CLOSE TO A BILLION AND THERE
WILL BE NO ADULTS AT BECAUSE
WHY WOULD AN ADULT AT SCHOOL
STAINED BUSINESSES IT'S LIKE
A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM OR HIGHER
EDUCATION PROGRAM IF YOU COULD
GO TO ONE WINDOW FROM THE
STATE AND GET A REIMBURSEMENT
AND THE OTHER ONE GET TWICE
AS MUCH MONEY OVER THERE WHY
WOULD YOU HAVE A GOOD ONE AND
WE DON'T NUMBER ONE SO -- --
AND AND AND AGAIN THIS IS ONE
OF SEVEN ISSUES HERE ON OUR
ON THE BEST LIST BUT THIS IS
THE ONE THAT CERTAINLY HAS
THE MOST INTERESTING AND WE'LL
SEE IF WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT TO MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE WAS AS MUCH CONSTERNATION
FROM THE OPERATORS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA EXCEPT FOR FIELD
WHICH FOR CONTINUE TO TO TO
TO LOOK INTO -- WITH THAT NO
MORE QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE ISSUE NUMBER SIX
WE WILL HOLD UP IN ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE CLARIFICATION
THANK YOU ISSUE NUMBER SIX
-- CHAIRMAN NOT CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUILDING UPON THE THE THE
INVESTMENT IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
-- PROVIDES TWELVE MILLION
ONGOING AT THREE MILLION
ONE TIME A GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM -- THIS THIS INVESTMENT
IS ALSO CORRESPONDING WITH A
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO ESTABLISH AN OFFICE CHIU
ADMINISTERED THE THE SYSTEM
A WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY AS WELL AS
THAT TRAILER BILL CLARIFIES THE
GENERAL GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
OF THE SYSTEM ADDITIONALLY
ARE BUILDING UPON THAT SYSTEM
WHICH HAS TWO COMPONENTS AN
ANALYTICAL AND OPERATIONAL
A COMPONENT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION UP AN ONGOING
AUGMENTATION THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION -- PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE COLLEGE AND CAREER
GUIDANCE INITIATIVE -- WHICH
ASSIST STUDENTS AND PARENTS --
ADDS THE TRANSITION FROM THE
CAPE FROM TWELVE SYSTEM AND
A COLLEGE AND CAREER -- AND
ADDITIONALLY IT -- I WOULD NOTE
THAT WE HAVE SUBMITTED A JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE A
LETTER REQUESTING THE USE OF A
SIX BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS A
PART OF THE APPROPRIATION MADE
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
DATA SYSTEM -- TO SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS TO CONTINUE DEVELOPING
THAT DATA SYSTEM -- WITH THAT
-- ALL I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS HONG
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
MY NAME IS CATHY BOOTH AND
I'M WITH WEST AT THE PROCESS
FACILITATOR FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE DATA SYSTEM I'M HERE
TO GIVE YOU A VERY BRIEF
UPDATE ABOUT PROGRESS ON ON
THE PLANNING PROCESS TO DATE
IN DECEMBER YOU RECEIVED A
REPORTS THAT -- WAS COVERING
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME
THROUGH AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
PLANNING PROCESS THAT'S
INCLUDED MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE TO DATE THAT INCLUDES
ALL OF THE AGENCIES THAT WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE PROVIDING DATA
AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD BE THE USE
OF THE DATA SYSTEM ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WAS REALLY
STRIKING ABOUT THE PLANNING
PROCESS WAS THAT THE PANDEMIC
MADE CLEAR HOW CRITICAL IT
WAS TO HAVE THIS DATA SYSTEM
THE PLANNING PARTNERS EASILY
COULD HAVE SAID WE REALLY
NEED TO ATTEND RUN THE FRONT
LINES BUT INSTEAD THEY DOUBLE
DOWN ON THE PLANNING PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY REALISE THEY
REALLY NEEDED THE INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE
BY LINKING EXISTING DATASETS
-- AND THEREFORE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT BECAME A REALITY
FOR THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
ARE IN THE PROPOSAL REFLECTS
ON BASE IS WITH EVERYTHING THAT
WE KNOW THAT IS WORKING WELL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY C.
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH OTHER
STATES AND NATIONAL EXPERTS
AS WELL AS FOLKS RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THEY'VE DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB OF LINKING DATA
ON A SMALLER SCALE IN ORDER TO
COME UP WITH THE BEST OF BREED
MODEL FOR CALIFORNIA WE WERE
ABLE TO BRING THIS MODEL OUT TO
THE PUBLIC WE HAD A SERIES OF
WEBINARS IN THE FALL THAT WERE
VERY POSITIVELY RECEIVED MORE
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE PEOPLE PARTICIPATED IN
THE SESSIONS AND THE RESPONSE
WAS WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE THEY
REALLY APPRECIATED THE SCOPE
OF THE TOOLS THAT THEY WOULD
BE VERY USEFUL FOR THEIR
IMMEDIATE NEEDS TO THE REPORT
THAT YOU RECEIVED IN DECEMBER
IS VERY COMPREHENSIVE INCLUDES
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING THAT
THE LEGISLATION IDENTIFIED
NEEDED TO BE COVERED FOR THE
DATA SYSTEM -- THERE WILL BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE REMAINDER OF
-- THAT NEXT THREE MONTHS ALL
THIS IS PRETTY MUCH LOOKING
AT OPERATIONAL CONSIDERATIONS
SO ISSUES LIKE -- FARMING BUT
THE THE LEGAL AGREEMENTS OR
EXPLAINING THIS THE SECURITY
POLICIES -- IN ADDITION -- AS
WE HEARD THERE WAS A REQUEST
FOR AN ADDITIONAL SET OF FUNDS
THAT WERE ALREADY APPROPRIATED
IS TO BE TO DO A PROOF OF
CONCEPT AND THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT WILL SHORE UP THE
UNDERLYING DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
AT CD EAT THAT'S NECESSARY
FOR IMPLEMENTING BOTH THE
TOOLS THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
FOR FAMILIES AS WELL AS FOR
THE ANALYTICAL DATASET I
MODEL SORT OF LOOKING AT WHAT
WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES FOR OUR TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE HAVING THIS
GROUP OF CONCEPT ALLOWS TO
GET MUCH MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT
ONGOING COSTS THE DATA SYSTEM
AND PROBABLY WANT TO SHARE
THAT THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FULLY REFLECT THE WORKGROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS THE VALLEY GOT
A COMPLETE PACKAGE TO LOOK AT
TOGETHER THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS BAKER
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS PAUL STEEN HOUSING
WHERE THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE FIRST SPOON FED HER
WEST A TEAM SHOULD REALLY BE
COMMENDED FOR ALL THE WORK
THEY PUT INTO THIS FOR SO TASTY
MANY MEETINGS AND PRODUCING
A FIRST REPORT ANYWAY THAT
WE SEE IS A GOOD STARTING
POINT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
BEGIN WEIGHING IN ON THIS YEAR
PAGE THIRTY SEVEN OF THE
AGENDA LIVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS
AND I WILL BRIEFLY ADDRESS
A FEW OF THEM AS THEY ALIGN
WELL WITH OUR COMMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE FIRST
QUESTION ABOUT THE MAKE UP
OF THE GOVERNING BOARD YES
WE BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE
THAT THE BOARD SHOULD CONSIST
OF MORE A PUBLIC MEMBERS WE
RECOMMEND THE NUMBER TO BE
EQUAL TO IF NOT GREATER THAN
THE NUMBER OF SEATS -- HELD
BY DATA PROVIDERS HAVING
MORE PUBLIC REPRESENTATION
IS IMPORTANT BUT MEDICATE THE
POSSIBILITY OF DATA PROVIDERS
USING THE DATA SYSTEM -- USING
THE DATA SYSTEM PRIMARILY FOR
SEGMENT US SPECIFIC INTERESTS
WE FURTHER RECOMMEND THAT
THE PUBLIC MEMBERS INCLUDE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
BIPARTISAN REPRESENTATION
FROM THE LEGISLATURE BOB
REGARDING THE SECOND QUESTION
ON PAGE THIRTY SEVEN OF YOUR
AGENDA SO FAR THE INTEGRATED
EDUCATION DATA SYSTEM HAS
NOT BEEN PLANS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY USED
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
OR PAL PROCESS ADMINISTRATION
HAS INDICATED IT'S THEIR
EXPECTATION THAT THE DECK IS
A STONE ACCENTURE THIS OUT
PROCESSES SOME POINT IT'S NOT
CLEAR EXACTLY WHEN THAT WOULD
OCCUR GIVEN THE STATE'S MIXED
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY I.
T. RECORD GIVEN THE AMBITIOUS
NATURE OF THIS PROJECT THE
PROPOSAL WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE SPECIFY IN STATUTE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION BEGAN
NOW USING THE POWER PLANNING
PLANNING PROCESS AS WELL AS
AGREED TO INDEPENDENT OLDER
STUFF RIGHT ONCE THE PROJECT IS
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY FINALLY IN RESPONSE
TO THE THIRD QUESTION ON PAGE
THIRTY SEVEN OF THE AGENDA YES
THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL COSTS
FOR THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM BEYOND WHAT THE GOVERNOR
IS CURRENTLY PROPOSING BUT THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT KNOW YET
WHAT THE COSTS WILL BE THIS
BILL MENTIONED -- THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE A REPORT LATER ON
IT'S GOING TO COME OUT IN JUNE
-- MAYBE EARLIER WE'LL GET A
BETTER SENSE OF THE ON GOING
COSTS FOR THIS PROJECT BECAUSE
IT IS A MULTI YEAR PROCESS IN
THE MEANTIME THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER APPROVING SOME
AMOUNT OF THE REMAINING SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING THAT
MR FERGUSON MENTIONED AND USE
THAT FOR GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
STAFF TO BEGIN THE POWER GOT
THE APPELLATE PROCESS AND WE
WOULD KNOW THAT BY USING THE
POWER PROCESS LEGISLATURE WOULD
ALSO HAVE THE BENEFIT OF HAVING
BETTER COST ESTIMATES FOR THIS
PROJECT THANK YOU AND HAPPY
JANET ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THIS AGENDA ITEM -- MISTER
MCCARTY YES THE STOCK DOWN
ON THE MISTER SMITH BY IT
AS YEAH I THANK THANK YOU I
MISS MCCARTY I YOU KNOW I WAS
GONNA SHARE MY OPINION ABOUT
THIS EFFORT -- I DON'T KNOW
WHY WE'RE DOING THIS IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME WHY WE NEED THIS
I HEAR OTHER STATES HAVE A
HAS GREAT JUST BECAUSE OTHER
STATES HAVE IT SOME OTHER
STATES HAVE DOESN'T MEAN WE
NEED TO HAVE IT I JUST YOU
KNOW I THINK I'M WITNESSING A
BOONDOGGLE ON A MONEY SUCK AND
IT'S STARTING RIGHT NOW AND
I DON'T THINK IT'S GONNA AND
-- THAT'S MY OPINION ON THIS
THIS MONEY SHOULD GO INTO THE
CLASSROOM THIS MONEY SHOULD
GOING TO SUPPORTING STUDENTS
-- OR OR OR SOMETHING MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVE THAN HAS BEEN
PRESENTED HERE I KNOW OTHER
PEOPLE ADVOCATING FOR THIS NON
PROFITS EXCITED THAT PROBABLY
BENEFIT FROM IT BUT I DON'T
SEE -- THE NEED FOR THIS MYSELF
NOR DO I SEE THIS AS A WISE
EXPENDITURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA THAT
IS YEAH THE PROPOSED GOVERNING
BOARD HEAVILY WEIGHS ON DATA
CONTRIBUTORS ADAM AS WELL AS
EDUCATION SEGMENTS BUT THERE'S
NO BOARD POSITIONS DESIGNATED
FOR THE EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE -- AND OBVIOUSLY THERE IS
AN UNDERSTANDING THAT CD NDSS
WOULD HAVE SOME UNDERSTANDING
OF THE TOPIC BUT -- AND THEY'RE
ALSO ONLY TWO BOARD POSITIONS
SPECIFIC TO THE WORK FORCE
AND THERE'S ALSO AN IMBALANCE
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
FOUR APPOINTEES -- AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S TWO APPOINTEES
IS THERE OPPORTUNITY -- NEED
TO TO DO THIS A LITTLE MORE --
FAIRLY BALANCED AND AND GIVING
CONSIDERATION TO THE EARLY
LEARNING I'M COMMUNITY AND AND
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE -- HOW CAN THERE
BE BROADER SO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FINANCE HOW CAN
THERE BE BROADER REPRESENTATION
ALONG THE CRADLE TO CAREER
CONTINUUM -- VIA THIS BOARD
AND WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDER SIX ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATIVE APPOINTEES
THAT WOULD BALANCE THE DATA
CONTRIBUTORS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AS WELL AS PROVIDE EACH
HOUSE WITH FOUR APPOINTEES THE
SAME NUMBER AS THE GOVERNOR
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH FINANCE
SO I I THINK WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS WE WOULD
NOTE IS THE TRAILER BILL
DOES ALLOW FOR THE BOARD TO
HAVE EX OFFICIO MEMBERS AND
TO INCREASE PARTICIPATION
ADDITIONALLY ALL OF THE BOARD
MEETINGS WOULD BE TRANSPARENT
THEY WOULD BE SUBJECT TO BACK
MAKING THE PUBLICLY NOTICED
THERE WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC INPUT
-- INTO -- DECISIONS THAT
WOULD MOVE FORWARD -- AND
CERTAINLY -- YOU ARE CORRECT
THAT THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
GUNS -- LARGELY REPRESENT OTHER
THAN THE CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS
-- OR THE CONTRIBUTING DATA
PROVIDERS -- TO THE SYSTEM SO
I I MEAN AGAIN AN EX OFFICIO
IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN A MEMBER
-- AND I WOULD APPRECIATE
CONSIDERATION FOR ALLOWING THE
LEGISLATURE WHO WE SHOULD BE
A PARTNER IN THIS EFFORT AND I
WOULD ALLOWING US TO HAVE EQUAL
REPRESENTATION -- I I THINK
WOULD BE A GOOD MOVE THANK YOU
OKAY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM
SEEING NONE WILL
HOLD IT'LL OPEN
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
ADULT EDUCATION
WE SHOULD HAVE THIS RIGHT
OUT IN THE MORNING CARE
YES PLEASE PROCEED GOOD MORNING
TERRY MEMBERS JENNIFER CROCKETT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
EIGHT POINT ONE MILLION I'M
GOING TO PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO REFLECT
THE ONE POINT FIVE PERCENT
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO PROPOSES A ONE A ONE
MILLION ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
FOR PURPOSES OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM RECEIVED
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THE FUNDING
WAS USED FOR A THREE YEAR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT CONTRACT
WITH THE FACT COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES THIS INVESTMENT TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY TECHNO WHAT
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
ADULT EDUCATION PROVIDERS SUCH
AS HOSTING STATEWIDE WEBINARS
PROVIDING WORKSHOP AN ANNUAL
SUMMIT AND RESPONDING TO OTHER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE REQUESTS
CALIFORNIA DAHLE EDUCATION
PROGRAM SERVES VULNERABLE
ADULT POPULATION ESPECIALLY
DURING A TIME WHERE THE STATE
IS LOOKING TO REBUILD THE
ECONOMY AND PREPARE ADULTS
TO RE ENTER THE WORKFORCE
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS K.
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE
HE IS THAT'S THE ALLEY
GARNER ON ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
CALIFORNIA HAS A HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE YEAR HISTORY OF ADULT
EDUCATION WITH A FOCUS ON IS
SERVING IMMIGRANTS WITH ENGLISH
ENGLISH LANGUAGE INSTRUCTION
AND CITIZENSHIP PREPARATION
SERVING INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT
TO IMPROVE BASIC LITERACY
AND NUMERACY SKILLS ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDES EDUCATION
TO ADULTS WANTING TO COMPLETE
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR PASSED
HIGH SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY EXAM
WITH THE PURPOSE OF FINDING
A JOB ADVANCING A CAREER ARE
TRANSITIONING TO POST SECONDARY
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
HISTORY OF ADULT EDUCATION THE
MAJORITY OF THE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN SITUATED IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES AND COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION CURRENTLY SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE PROGRAM
SUPPORTED BY THE STATE AND
OR FEDERAL FUNDS ARE IN
ELEAZAR WERE IN THOSE COUNTY
OFFICE AT ONE YEAR AGO THE
ADULT EDUCATION AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA WERE ABLE TO SHIP
QUICKLY TO REMOTE LEARNING
OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS THIS
IS ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH
THE EFFORTS OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SERVICES PROVIDED
TO OUR PROGRAMS BY CD WELL
WE HAVE SEEN A DRAMATIC
DECREASE IN ENROLLMENT IN
OUR LOWEST LEVEL LITERACY
PROGRAMS AGENCIES ARE REPORTING
AN INCREASE IN STUDENTS
WANTING TO COMPLETE THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR SUCH
INEQUIVALENT SEAT ANECDOTAL
AND DATA DRIVEN INFORMATION
SHARED BY OUR INSTRUCTORS
AND ADMINISTRATORS ARE THAT
STUDENTS ARE LIKELY AT THAT
SEEMS LIKE THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
REMIT LEARNING HAS PROVIDED
TO THAT IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
THE STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP
ACTIVITIES AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND OF
COURSE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND PROGRAM EVALUATION BUT
THE ADULT EDUCATION CONSORTIUM
CONSORTIUM WHICH THERE ARE OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND ADULT
EDUCATION STUDENTS THE CD WOULD
REQUEST ADMINISTRATION THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER PROVIDING THE C.
E. WITH ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDS STARTING IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO TO CONTINUE PERFORMING
THESE DUTIES AND IT'S ALL
FUNDING OF FIVE MILLION WAS
APPROVED FOR THREE YEARS TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
AND ENDED IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THE CDC WOULD
NEED THIS FUNDING STREAM TO
CONTINUE AT TI AND PD NEEDED
FOR THE STATE ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS CONTINUED SUCCESS
ADDITIONALLY THE CITY WOULD
REQUEST THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE CONSIDERING
CONSIDER PROVIDING THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TO COLLECT FOR
CALIFORNIA EDUCATE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS GET THE SAME
LEVEL OF THE KEY THROUGH TWELVE
LCF COLA OF THREE POINT EIGHT
FOUR HE TOLD THE DON'T SCHOOLS
SIMILAR TO OTHER K.
THROUGH TWELVE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THE
INCREASE COSTS FIRST SCHOOLS
SHOULD BE OPEN SAFELY AND
ARE FACING SIMILAR COSTS AS
UNDER ALL PROGRAMS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IT IS BELIEVED THAT
THE PANDEMIC HAS HELPED CREATE
AN EVEN MORE NIMBLE ADULT
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
YOU CAN MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS STILL SET FOR AT
ICING'S FOR COLLEGE FINANCE
AT THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SINCE ITS INITIAL
IMPLEMENTATION THE CALIFORNIA
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM
HAS CONTINUED TO EVOLVE
OVER THE LAST ELEVEN MONTHS
PROGRAMS AT BOTH THE K.
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
I'VE BEEN CHALLENGED BUT
THROUGH THIS COMPLEX PERIOD
WE'VE LEARNED THAT CALIFORNIANS
NEED US MORE THAN EVER WELL
COMPLETE ANALYSIS IS STILL
MONTHS AWAY SOME INITIAL
FINDINGS INDICATE THAT THE
ROMANS HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN CRAP TURN TO OUR
PROGRAMS FOR DIGITAL LITERACY
ORDER ACCESS TO STUDENT
SERVICES AND WE WE ARE SEEING
THAT INTERESTS AND SHORT TERM
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS HAS INCREASED OUR
PROGRAMS ARE AN IMPORTANT
SAFETY NET WILL COMPEL ADULTS
TO GREATER OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORT
PROVIDING PARITY IN THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO
CALIFORNIA ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ADDITIONALLY GIVEN THE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO TEACHING
AND LEARNING MODALITIES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR ONE
MILLION AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT COULD NOT BE MORE
TIMELY THE PORTIONS HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED WITH GUIDANCE TO
DEVELOP SPENDING PLANS ARE
FOR THIRTY MONTHS AND BASED
ON OUR RECENT FISCAL ANALYSIS
OVERALL CARRY OVER IS THAT TEN
PERCENT AND EXPECTED TO DECLINE
TO FOUR PERCENT IN THE COMING
MONTHS FINALLY THE TEAMSTERS
OFFICE IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION HAVE MADE
POSITIVE PROGRESS ON TIMELY
ALLOCATIONS OF ANNUAL RESOURCES
AS A PLANNER STATES RECOVERY
AND RESILIENCY WE CONTINUE
TO BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE
TO BE PIVOTAL THANK YOU AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY THANK YOU L. A. L.
THANK YOU BOSTON HOUSE AND
AGAIN WITH THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WITH REGARD TO THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
PROPOSAL WE HAVE NO CONCERNS AN
AUGMENTATION COULD HELP ADULT
ADD PROVIDERS IN OPERATING
THEIR PROGRAMS THE LEGISLATURE
LIKELY WILL SEE A REVISED
PROPOSAL -- PROPOSED RATE AT
THE MAY REVISION AFTER THE
STATE RECEIVES UPDATED ECONOMIC
DATA SO LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE
A DECISION ON A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AT THAT TIME WITH
REGARD TO THE PROPOSED ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
FOR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE
LEGISLATURE WILL JUST WANT TO
GET CLARIFICATION ON WHETHER
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
CONTENT TO PUT OUT A REQUEST
FOR APPLICATIONS OR RFA SO
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND COUNTY OFFICES
DEDICATION CAN OPENLY PAIRED
ON THIS CONTRACT THAT'S HOW
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION WAS SELECTED TO
DO THIS WORK IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN IF THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND CD WERE PLANNING
TO AUTOMATICALLY RE AWARD
THE CONTRACT TO SACRAMENTO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO DIRECT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND CD EIGHTY YOU SEE
OUR FAVORITE PROCESS DOING
SO COULD HELP IDENTIFY OR
CONFIRM THE BEST CONTRACTOR
FOR THIS WORK THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR MEDINA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE -- CANCERS OFFICE FOR
THEIR PRESENTATIONS -- BESIDES
BEING A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER I
WOULD GO IN THE EVENING TEACH
ADULT ADD AND I TAUGHT ESL --
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPRESSIVE
THAN SEEING ADULT LEARNERS --
WHO'VE WORKED EIGHT HOURS A
COME TO SCHOOL IN THE EVENING
AND -- YOU KNOW THEY THEY MAY
BE TIRED AFTER EIGHT HOURS
OF WORK OF THE DAY COUNTY
-- EXCITED EXCITED TO LEARN
EXCITED TO LEARN ENGLISH SO
THAT THEY CAN HELP THEIR KIDS
WHO ARE IN SCHOOL AS WELL --
SO ADULT EDUCATION CERTAINLY
SO IMPORTANT TO THE STATE --
I APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS GIVEN ON THE DECREASE
OF ESL STUDENTS -- WITH WITH
THE LOSS OF -- IN PERSON
LEARNING AND SAY HOW DIFFICULT
IT MUST BE A FOR THESE LEARNERS
TO TRY TO LEARN ENGLISH A
REMOTELY -- SO ANYTHING WE
CAN DO TO HELP ESPECIALLY THAT
PART OF THE ADULT EDUCATION
BUT I STRONGLY SUPPORT -- AND
THEN HOPEFULLY -- AS AS OTHER
SCHOOLS RE OPEN ADULT EDUCATION
WILL BE ABLE TO GET BACK TO TO
IN PERSON BECAUSE I THINK THE
CHALLENGE -- OF OF TRYING TO
DO -- THAT KIND OF EDUCATION IS
MUST BE OVERWHELMING SO I I I
GUESS I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION
-- HOPE THE -- CONSORTIUMS
ARE ARE WORKING AND -- AND
VERY MUCH SUPPORT OF FUNDING
ADULT EDUCATION THANK YOU OKAY
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YEAH
I TO FULLY SUPPORT OUR ADULT
ED PROGRAMS AND NOT JUST --
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS BUT
PEOPLE LOOKING FOR A BASIC
SKILLS TO GET BACK IN THE
JOB MARKET ARE OR -- THAT
INSPIRED HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
ARE LOOKING TO GET THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA LIKE THIS DUDE
RIGHT HERE SO THIRTY ONE YEARS
AGO SO HI CERTAINLY BENEFITED
FROM OUR ADULT ED PROGRAM AND
I WANNA MAKE SURE WE CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
ADULT ADD WHICH IS WHY WE'RE WE
ADDRESS THE OTHER ISSUE EARLIER
WITH THE ADULT CHARTER SCHOOL
ISSUES WHICH I THINK WILL HELP
STABILIZE AND YOU KNOW I I
THINK THAT IT BEGS THE QUESTION
WE NEED TO KEEP LOOKING AT
EVEN MORE IS HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE WE HAVE PARITY AND EQUITY
BETWEEN THIS ADULT ED SO I KNOW
WE DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER SO I
WANT TO ASK L. A. L.
IF YOU CAN GO AND HELP US AND
COME BACK AND REPORT BACK ARE
YOU THERE PAUL D.
G. CAN JUMP UP ON THE SCREEN
I AM I AM YES SAID YOU COULD
HELP US FIGURE OUT THIS RIDDLE
HERE WITH THESE -- CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT SERVE THE DAHLE
POPULATIONS AND HOW MUCH
THEY'RE RECEIVING THROUGH
LCF FORMULA BY CLASSIFYING
YOUR STUDENTS AT WHATEVER THE
PROPER GRADE THERE AT GRADE
LEVEL VERSES ADULT ED AND TAX
I THINK THAT'S MORE OF A LARGER
ISSUE -- FOR US GOING FORWARD
HOW DO YOU BRING ABOUT PARITY
AND PROPERLY FUND -- -- -- FOR
STUDENT AND ADULT EDUCATION
SO HE COULD POTENTIALLY BRING
THAT TO THE FACT -- BEFORE WE
FINALIZE OUR WORK THERE THIS
SPRING WE APPRECIATE THAT --
THAT AS WELL I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE A FULL COLOR HERE
-- FOR THESE STUDENTS AS WELL
OKAY WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPENS
THING UP QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
HERE ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT PFAFF
SAID DREAM ACT REQUIREMENTS
THE CHAIN MEMBERS GABRIELA
CHAVEZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES STATUTES
TO REQUIRE ALL HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS TO COMPLETE IT
FASTER OR CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT APPLICATION BEGINNING
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO ACADEMIC YEAR THE STATE
HAS IN THE CLIENTS IN FIRST
SIGNED UP FRESHMAN FIVE
SIGN IN CALIFORNIA J.
MAC APPLICATION RATES THIS
EFFORT WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RECEIVE THE MAXIMUM
FINANCIAL EIGHT AND TO PURSUE A
HIGHER EDUCATION THANK YOU I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SENATE COMMISSION
IF GOOD MORNING CARE
MCCARTY MEMBERS J.
PARTNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION OF THE COMMISSION
WELCOMES AND SUPPORTS THIS
IS A PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
ALL TOO WELL THE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER THAT THE FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS THEMSELVES -- CAN
POSE TO STUDENTS THE CURRENT
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS
FEATURE OVER ONE HUNDRED
QUESTIONS MANY OF WHICH USE
VERY TECHNICAL LANGUAGE ABOUT
TAX ISSUES THAT CAN BE VERY
UNFAMILIAR TO STUDENTS -- AND
THEIR FAMILIES PARTICULARLY
THOSE WHO MIGHT BE THE FIRST IN
THEIR FAMILY TO ATTEND COLLEGE
EACH YEAR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS WOULD OTHERWISE BE
ELIGIBLE FOR IT IT DO NOT APPLY
AND LEAVE FEDERAL FUNDING ON
THE TABLE THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST THEM IN THEIR PURSUIT
OF HIGHER EDUCATION EXTERNAL
ESTIMATES HAVE INDICATED THAT
AS MUCH AS A FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE AND
FEDERAL AID IS LEFT ON THE
TABLE BY OUR STUDENTS EACH YEAR
DUE SIMPLY TO THE LACK OF THEIR
I'M APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL AID
I JUST DO NEED COMMISSION WERE
VERY PROUD TO LEAD SEVERAL
OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT SEEK TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS INSEMINATING
AND COMPLETING THEIR
APPLICATIONS FOR FINANCIAL AID
AND -- IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
I CAN CERTAINLY DISCUSS THOSE
FURTHER -- AND WE'RE LOOKING
FOR NOW TO SEE HOW WE CAN BEST
LEVERAGE THOSE PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT OUR LOCAL K.
TWELVE PARTNERS IN SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTING THIS REQUIREMENT
AND HELPING THEIR STUDENTS
APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID SHOULD
THE PROPOSAL BE ADOPTED SO ALL
STOP THERE AND -- I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU L. L.
ONE CHEN MEMBERS MAKE THE
KING LET THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IN GENERAL
WE THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL REQUIRING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO VERIFY THAT
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETED
FINANCIALLY APPLICATION
IS A PROMISING APPROACH TO
INCREASING FINANCIALLY THAT
TAKE INCLUDING IN THE FEDERAL
PELL GRANT PROGRAM IN ADDITION
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
DOES INCLUDE PROVISIONS THAT
ARE INTENDED TO REDUCE THE
ASSOCIATED BERGEN OF THIS
REQUIREMENT ON STUDENTS FOR
EXAMPLE THE LAST STUDENTS OR
THEIR PARENTS AND GUARDIANS
TO OPT OUT OF THE REQUIREMENTS
WHERE DISTRICTS EXEMPTS
STUDENTS IF THEY'RE UNABLE TO
COMPLETE THE REQUIREMENTS IT
DOES ALSO REQUIRE DISTRICTS
TO DIRECT STUDENTS TO EXISTING
OUTREACH PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
ONES THAT MISTER BROWN YOU
JUST DESCRIBED IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH ADEQUATE
SUPPORT IN COMPLETING THEIR
APPLICATIONS WHAT IS THE MIND
WE RECOMMEND ADOPTING COVERS
BECAUSE CONCEPTS WHICH IS A
COUPLE OF FISCAL ISSUES FOR
PLANNING PURPOSES ALLOTTEES
VERY BRIEFLY FIRST TO THE
EXTENT THAT THIS PROPOSAL
HAS ITS INTENDED EFFECT OF
INCREASING FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS WE WOULD EXPECT
TO SEE AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA SECONDS
BEGINNING IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR AND
SO WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
PLAN FOR THAT INCREASING HOW
CAN SPENDING WHERE IT CAN
ACT THIS PROPOSAL SECOND OF
THIS PROPOSAL IS ENACTED AND
DETERMINED TO BE A MANDATE
THAT THE STATE WOULD NEED TO
REIMBURSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FOR THE ASSOCIATED COSTS IN
IMPLEMENTING IT AND SO WOULD
RECOMMEND WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE
THAT THAT POST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DOESN'T CONTAIN ANY
UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR DISTRICTS
THANK YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION
IS AYE AYE WE HAD A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS WHEN
OUR HAD OUR OVERVIEW HEARING
A FEW WEEKS AGO I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS I THINK THEY'LL
DRAMATICALLY -- INCREASE AT
COLLEGE -- COLLEGE ACCESS THE
YOU KNOW FINANCIALLY THERE ARE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM WE TALKED
A FEW WEEKS AGO THAT IT'S AN
ENTITLEMENT FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN THE COMPETITIVE
WHEN YOU APPLY ONE OR TWO YEARS
LATER IT'S A SOMEBODY'S HAS
OKAY A GOOD CROP ROCK
CONCERT AND THAT AND THIS IS
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
IT'S AND THERE'S STILL A
QUESTIONS BUDGET BUT THE
REQUIREMENT IS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF HOW DOES THAT
HOW DOES THIS -- PLAY OUT THE
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
SEN AND -- MANDATE
REQUIREMENTS AND SO FORTH
HI KAMALA CHAMBERS WITH THE
CRIMINAL FINANCED OUT THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE INVITES
AT SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO GET
RESOURCES FROM THE STATE IN
THE COMMISSION THE REQUIREMENT
IS SOME OF THE SCHOOLS
DISTRICTS -- TO BUT THEY COULD
UTILIZE SOME OF THE RESOURCES
THAT -- SENATE COMMISSION
CURRENTLY OFFERS BY THE CASH
RECALL PROGRAM AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANY FEEDBACK THAT
YOU CAPTURE AND MEMBERS YEAH
I GUESS IT'S MORE OF A K.
TWELVE ISSUES SO MAYBE WE'LL
HEAR FROM C. S. B. A.
R. ACTS ABOUT THIS LATER MISTER
MISTER O'DONNELL YEAH I THINK
OF YOU KNOW ME YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M GOING TO SAY HERE I THINK
-- THIS NEEDS TO BE APPROACHED
VERY CAUTIOUSLY LISTEN -- THE
DATA SHOWS THE STUDENTS GO GO
TO COLLEGE BECAUSE THEY FILLED
OUT THE FASTER OKAY AND IF
ALL THE FASTER BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO COLLEGE GETTING THAT'S
WHAT ISSUE BUT WHAT I'M MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT HERE IS THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
SUCH A POLICY THAT COULD PUT
STUDENTS IN JAIL ULTIMATELY OR
HAVE THEM DEPORTED YES SOMEONE
IS ON THE GROUND I THINK WE
NEED TO HEAR FROM SOMEONE WHO'S
ON THE GRAHAM WHO'S BEEN ON
THE GROUND OKAY GOOD I HAVE --
HAD STUDENTS FALL THE FASTER
MY POSTURE MANY TIMES IN CANCER
COMMAND IT'S A TOMORROW OVER
THE COUNCIL'S COME IN EVEN IF
ALL THE FASTER -- BRING YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER BRING
YOUR NUMBER IF YOU HAVE ONE AND
AS I REPEATED IN THE PAST MANY
STUDENTS THAT MIGHT GO HOME
AND SAY HEY MOM DAD I NEED MY
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER AND FIND
OUT THEY ARE NOT DOCUMENTED
FOR THE FIRST TIME ANY OTHER
STUDENTS DON'T FIND THAT OUT
AND THEY PROBABLY GO AHEAD AND
FILL UP THE FAST THAT COULD
PUT THEM IN A PRECARIOUS LEGAL
SITUATION GOING FORWARD SO
I THINK HOW THIS IS EMPLOYED
ON THE GROUND -- EASE IS IT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
REALLY THAT THROUGH THIS REALLY
NEEDS TO BE THOUGHT THROUGH
BECAUSE I KNOW TO BE ON THE
OUTSIDE SOUNDS GREAT OH MY
GOSH FOR DOING A GREAT THING
BUT YOUR MIGHT REALLY YOU PUT
IN A CERTAIN GROUP OF STUDENTS
AND A VERY BAD SPOT AND THEY
MIGHT NOT KNOW EVEN FOR A
COUPLE YEARS RIGHT -- BECAUSE
THE THE THE LEGAL IMPLICATIONS
MIGHT I'D COME UP TO LATER
BUT I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
BE CAREFUL ABOUT THIS I KNOW
IT SOUNDS GREAT OKAY AND THE
MISSION IS GREAT THE GOAL IS
GREAT BUT HOW IT'S IMPLEMENTED
IS KEY HERE THERE NEEDS TO
BE -- IF YOU'RE GONNA DO THIS
GAME YOU'RE SO IN LOVE WITH
IT THERE NEEDS TO BE A LOT OF
EDUCATION ABOUT HOW THIS IS
GOOD THIS IS DONE ON THE GROUND
LEVEL AND STILL WE WILL BE
STATE SENATE AS SOME WILL FILL
IT OUT BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
BE QUOTE UNQUOTE A REQUIREMENT
RIGHT THEY'RE NOT EVEN GONNA
GET THEIR NOT GOING TO GET
THE MESSAGE OR SOMETHING'S
GOING TO HAPPEN LOGISTICS
ASSOCIATED WITH HAVING TO FILL
IT OUT WHATEVER -- ARE THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO CATCH THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T FILL IT OUT AND I
I KNOW THIS SOUNDS GREAT TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE AGAIN BUT I
JUST THINK YOU NEED TO LOOK
AT THE ALTMAN -- IMPLICATIONS
THIS FOR SOME STUDENTS BECAUSE
MAY VERY WELL BE NEGATIVE
I SAY THIS AS SOMEONE WHO'S
CONCERNED FOR THOSE STUDENTS
TO SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD STUDENTS
IN THE CLASSROOM THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS PROBABLY FILL OUT THE
FASTER AND IS HAD TO SAY TO
STUDENTS HEY IN A FEW DAYS YOU
HAVE YOUR NUMBER GO TO THIS
CLASSROOM TODAY YOU KNOW I
HAVE YOUR NUMBER STAY OVER HERE
BECAUSE WE WERE VERY CAREFUL IN
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS DIDN'T
FILL US OUT OF THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A NUMBER BUT ALL THAT
SOME STILL DO WELL BUT THEY
DID -- SO WITH THAT I I THINK
I PRESENTED MY CONCERN MULTIPLE
TIMES AND IT FROM SOMEONE WHO'S
DONE THIS AND I TURN IT BACK
TO YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GALLAGHER INVITED US
YEAH I WOULD ONCE AGAIN AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH -- AND I THINK THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC -- I I GET THE
INTENTION BEHIND IT BUT I THINK
-- YEP YET ANOTHER MANDATE
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE PUTTING OUR
SCHOOLS AT A TIME WHEN THERE IS
A WHOLE LOT TO MANAGE -- AND
AND LOOK I MEAN COMBINED WITH
THE BUT I THINK A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED -- BY
MISTER O'DONNELL -- IT AT SOME
POINT HOW MUCH TO EXPECT OF
PEOPLE TO HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
TO DO THIS THEMSELVES YEAH --
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OUT REACH THERE'S
A LOT OF INFORMATION OUT THERE
WE COULD ARGUE MAYBE THERE
SHOULD BE EVEN MORE -- BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY WITH PUTTING
THE RESPONSIBILITY ON THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU KNOW FOR
ENSURING THIS GETS FILLED OUT
INSTEAD OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS SEEKING THE AID SEEKING TO
GET THE YOU KNOW THE BENEFIT
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND TO TO
SEEK THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
TO ME SEEMS MISPLACED I THINK
IT YEAH LOOK I THINK AS WITH
MANY THINGS ACROSS THE BOARD
I STILL THINK THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE INDIVIDUAL RESPONSIBILITY
-- AND THAT THE ONUS SHOULD
BE ON THE INDIVIDUAL TO
ALTERNATELY ASSERT THEMSELVES
TO APPROACH -- WE CAN CERTAINLY
HAVE PEOPLE LETTING PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE
WHAT BENEFITS ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM BUT ULTIMATELY IF YOU
DO IT ALL FOR THEM THERE'S
REALLY NO INDIVIDUAL INCENTIVE
MOTIVATION -- AND I DON'T THINK
THAT ALL TO ME THAT'S GOING
TO BE A RECIPE FOR SUCCESS
-- SO I JUST THINK IT'S YOU
KNOW THE WRONG APPROACH TO
THIS AND A AND IN ADDITION
TO BEING WHAT I THINK WILL
PROBABLY BE A PRETTY EXPENSIVE
MANDATE -- AND REQUIRE A LOT OF
ADMINISTRATION TIME ON BEHALF
OF OUR SCHOOLS OKAY THANK YOU
CINEMA PROVIDE US I WANT TO
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE
AND YOU KNOW I I HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH GOVERNMENT CONSTANTLY
TELLING US WHAT WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO AND I MEAN WHY NOT IS THERE
A CONSIDERATION OF A WAIVER
IS THERE ARE FOR WAIVER AND OR
-- A SIMPLE NOTE TO RETURN FOR
STUDENTS OR PARENTS TO REJECT
I'M HAVING TO APPLY I MEAN IF
YOU ARE AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
AS A SENIOR OR EVEN A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD SINGER AND YOU'VE
DECIDED THAT YOU WANT TO GO
INTO THE UNITED STATES MILITARY
AND SAVE AND AND AND SERVE OUR
COUNTRY YOU KNOW WHY WOULD YOU
HAVE TO APPLY FOR THIS -- BE
REQUIRED TO APPLY FOR THIS SO
IS THERE AN OPPORTUNITY -- D.
TO TO WAIVE THIS REQUIREMENT
FOR STUDENTS AND PARENTS ONE
AND TWO WHAT WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE FAST
BUT AND AND THE C.
A. D. D. A. -- APPLICATIONS
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
-- COVER LIKE CHAO'S BUT THE
COMING UP FINANCED ON YOUR
FIRST QUESTION YES THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE ALLOWS A STUDENT OR
A PARENT TO OPT OUT OF THE
REQUIREMENTS TO APPLY FOR TOP
CENTER FOR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT APPLICATION ON YOUR SECOND
NO REGARDING THE DIFFERENCE
-- I WILL -- FORTY TWO OF OUR
COLLEAGUE -- AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION SO THEY CAN
TALK ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE TWO APPLICATIONS
HE MISSED CHÁVEZ J.
BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION -- THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATION IS
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO MIRROR
THE PROCESS SO THE QUESTIONS
ARE ALL THE SAME AS THAT ARE
PUT BEFORE STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
THE BASS THAT THE ONLY REAL
DIFFERENCE IS WHICH STUDENTS
-- ARE ARE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY
A STUDENTS WHO SUBMITTED
THE ABSOLUTE ARE THOSE WERE
ELIGIBLE UNDER A TITLE FOR --
AT THE END FEDERAL FINANCIAL
AID -- PARLANCE THIRD ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID AND
STUDENT THAT APPLIED IT THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION OUR STUDENTS THAT
QUALIFY FOR IN STATE TUITION
RATES -- BY -- DEMONSTRATING
THAT THEY NEED A NUMBER OF
CRITERIA -- THAT ALLOW LONG
TIME RESIDENTS OF THIS STATE
WHO MAY NOT BE U.
S. CITIZENS TO STILL APPLY
AND ACCESS STATE FINANCIAL
IT THANK YOU AND IS IT THE
ADMINISTRATION OPEN TO DELAYING
-- DELAYING THE REQUIREMENT
FOR A YEAR AS WE KNOW THAT
THE FEDERAL AND FAST THE
APPLICATION IS GOING TO CHANGE
IN THE TWENTY IS IT THE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AWARD
YEAR OF OUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WORK YEAR I MEAN
WHY IF WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
CHANGE AND AND THEREFORE ARE
DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO CHANGE IT WHAT WHAT WHAT
AND HOW WHY WOULDN'T WE DELAY
GOVERNMENT CHÁVEZ WITH
THE COMING OF FINANCE
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
FEEDBACK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
-- TO -- MY MANAGEMENT TEAM
THANK YOU
YEAH I DID I JUST WANT TO AND
INTERJECT ON THIS IF ANY OF YOU
EVER BEEN TO THOSE CAST RECALLS
WORKSHOPS THAT EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED FELT THIS FORM AND
-- GOING FROM A HUNDRED AND
EIGHT QUESTIONS A THIRTY SIX
I THINK WILL MAKE IT EASIER
WHETHER WITHOUT WE HAVE THIS
CHANGE BUT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO HAVE THEIR STUDENTS -- YOU
KNOW FILL OUT THIS APPLICATION
I THINK THIS IS THAT A GOOD
IDEA I KNOW SOMEONE MEMBER
REYES HAD BILLS ON THIS TO
TRY TO PUSH THIS DIRECTION
HER IDEA WAS GONNA MAKE A
REQUIREMENT STUDENTS HOW TO
DO THIS FOR FOR -- GRADUATION
AND WE GOT PUSHED BACK FROM A
LOT OF THE ADVOCATES OUT THERE
AND AND AND EQUITY GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA SAYS WELL YOU'RE
GOING TO PUNISH STUDENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE COUNSELORS AND HOW
HOW DO THEY HOW CAN THEY EVEN
KNOW WHAT TO DO ITSELF TURNING
IT AROUND WITH HAVING THESE
OPT OUT OPTIONS FOR DISTRICTS
AND STUDENTS I THINK MAKES
SENSE I LOOK WITH WE TALKED
A FEW WEEKS AGO ABOUT THAT
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM IN THAT
RESEARCH DONE SHOWS THAT IF
YOU ASK A STUDENT WHO DIDN'T
GO TO COLLEGE AND THEY'RE
LIKE EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE WHY
DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE THEY
SAY MONEY WITHIN ITS COST TOO
MUCH QUESTION NUMBER TWO DID
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS PROGRAM
CALLED THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT SAID ENTITLEMENT IF YOU
APPLY WHEN YOU'RE EIGHTEEN IN
HIGH SCHOOL NOW IT NOW SO THIS
REALLY IS A DIFFERENCE MAKER
SO WE WANT TO FOCUS ON INCREASE
COLLEGE ACCESS AND FOCUS ON
OUR NEEDS FOR EMPLOYERS TO
GET MORE COLLEGE GRADUATES
YOU KNOW I DON'T SEE WHY WE
WOULDN'T GO ALL IN FOR THIS --
I WE DO NEED TO BE CAREFUL TO
MAKE SURE THE STUDENTS DON'T
FILL OUT THE FASTER WHEN THEY
REALLY SHOULD BE FOCUSING
ON THE DREAM ACT APPLICATION
I'M CERTAIN DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO MANY LATINO AND
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ARE GOING
TO FIGURE THIS OUT RIGHT AWAY
TO MAKE SURE THE STUDENTS DON'T
PUT THEMSELVES IN LEGAL PERIL
BUT -- EQUITY GROUPS ADVOCACY
GROUPS SEE THE BENEFITS FAR
OUTWEIGH THE DRAWBACKS I KNOW
THE ONLY ISSUE THAT I WANT TO
ADDRESS I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM THE LAYER DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT IS A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND IS THIS AN
UNFUNDED MANDATE AND HEALTH
STAFF TALKS ABOUT THAT LITERATE
THAT'S A BIT TOO AS FAR AS --
PROP FOR FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE AND REIMBURSEMENTS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR LAWS
THAT WE THE LEGISLATURE -- AND
ACCEL -- MR -- I THINK WE'RE
ALL SET ON HERE SO WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN THE
QUESTION IS JUST JUST A NOTE IS
ELEVEN FIFTY ONE WE ARE GOING
TO ADJOURN I'M SORRY ROOM TO
RECESS AT NOON ACTUALLY RATE
WILL RECESS RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE THREE MORE ISSUES THAT
COME BACK TO AND FINISH AFTER
OUR RESPECTIVE CAUCUS -- --
COCCUS BRIEFINGS AT NOON --
WE HAVE THE STATE LIBRARY
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW AND
THEN LOWER THEN WE'LL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS UP ANTICIPATE
SOMEWHERE AFTER ONE -- SO
THE GOAL IS BETWEEN ONE AND
ONE THIRTY FOR RECONVENING
AND -- WE WILL -- KEEP YOU
POSTED THANK YOU RECESS
OKAY WE WILL RECONVENE HERE
AB WE HAVE THE STATE LIBRARY
TO ISSUES AND HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF LAW AND THEN PUBLIC COMMENT
SO ISSUE NUMBER NINE STATE
LIBRARY ON GOING PROPOSALS
IT'S GREAT LOCUSTS THE
STATE LIBRARIAN FROM
YES GO AHEAD OF SIXTY FOUR
THE STAFF WRITE UPS OF OUR
ISSUES ARE TERRIFIC AS ALWAYS
AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HOLD THE ITEMS OPEN SO
IF THEY'RE QUESTIONS ALL
ANSWERED THEM -- MADE IN THE
INTEREST OF YOUR TIME OKAY
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER
LOUISVILLE MISTER CHAIR
-- WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AT THE STATE LIBRARY'S
AUGMENTATION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OUR CONTINUATION OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EMPHASIS
ON ACCESS EQUITY AND BUDGET
RESILIENCY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A TOTAL OF
TEN POINT THREE MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION
OF WHICH OF THOSE FUNDS TWO
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ARE ON GOING -- THE STATE
LIBRARY'S ONGOING INVESTMENTS
INCLUDE THE CONTINUATION OF
THE ONLINE SERVICE SYSTEMS
ALSO KNOWN AS THE BOOKS THE
LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY AND
THE CONTINUATION SUPPORT FOR
BROADBAND ACCESS PROVIDED BY
THE CORPORATION FOR EDUCATION
NETWORK INITIATIVES IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO KNOWN AS SCENIC
AND WITH THE ACTUAL COMPLETE
WITH MY PRESENTATION I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS AS REQUESTED AND
OUR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALAIA FOR
I JUST A CONSTANT TORRICELLA
YELLOW AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES
BOTH RESIDENT BOOKS AND LUNCH
AT THE LIBRARY INITIATIVES --
HAVE BEEN RECEIVING ONE TIME
FUNDING FROM THE STATE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS SO THE PROBLEM
FOR YOU FOR THESE INITIATIVES
ARE WHAT EFFECTIVELY ON MAKE
THE -- WHAT WERE EFFECTIVELY
STATE PILOT PROGRAMS ON GOING
OUR KEY CONCERN HERE WITH
THESE INITIATIVES IS THAT THIS
IS SENSE OF MOST OPPORTUNE
TIME FOR THE STATE TO BE
MAKING PILOT PROGRAMS ARE
ONGOING I GIVEN THE PROJECTED
OUT YEAR DEFICITS FACING THE
STATE GENERAL FUND ALSO --
IN PREVIOUS YEARS WE HAVE
RAISED SOME CONCERNS WITH
BOTH OF THE BOOKS AND LUNCH
AT THE LIBRARY NO SHIPS -- WE
SHARED THESE CONCERNS -- IN
THE PAST WHAT THE COMMITTEES
-- FOR THE SECOND TIME ALL
ALL THE FOR THE Q.
AND A ON THAT IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS BUT OVERALL OUR ARE
RECOMMENDATION HERE IS SIMILAR
TO OTHER ONGOING PROPOSALS IS
TO REVISIT OF THE INITIATIVES
-- IN THE REVISION WHEN YOU
HAVE MORE INFORMATION ON THE
STATE'S BUDGET CONVENTION
OKAY HAVE A GOOD ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YEAH WELL MAYBE YOU
CAN JUST SELL MY UNDERSTANDING
YOUR TO CONCERNS ARE ONE
ONGOING VERSES ONE TIME AND IT
IS WE SHOULD BE CAREFUL DOING
ONGOING STAFF AT BUT TO CAN YOU
REMIND US YOUR I DON'T REMEMBER
THAT THIS THE FEEDBACK HE GAVE
US -- ON THESE TWO PROPOSALS
HE HAD SENT SOME CONSTRUCTIVE
CRITICISM ON ON ON -- THESE
EFFORTS IN THE PAST FEW YEARS
CAN YOU -- AND LIGHTNESS THERE
SURE FORCING FOR THE BOOKS
PROGRAM -- ARE CONCERNED WITH
A FEW CONCERNS FOR ONE CONCERN
IS THAT -- LIBRARIES ALREADY
SPEND A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
LOCAL RESOURCES TO PURCHASING
MATERIALS -- SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE FUNDING THAN WHAT WHAT HAS
BEEN PROPOSED IN PREVIOUS YEARS
-- IN TERMS OF ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING ON
SO IT IT DOES ARE DISCOVERING
THINGS THAT -- LIBRARIES TO
COVER OTHER LOCAL RESOURCES
-- ANOTHER CONCERN WE'VE HAD
FOR THE BOOKS PROGRAM IS THAT
ON SOME PREVIOUS ANALYSES
HAVE FOUND THAT THEY GENERATE
SAVINGS FOR LOCAL LIBRARIES
ARE WE THINK THOSE LIBRARIES
COULD USE THOSE SAVINGS TO
HELP SUPPORT OF THE BOOKS
PROGRAMMING ON ONE BASIS AND
THEN THERE ARE THEIR CONCERN
IT'S ABOUT THIS SORT OF ISSUE
EMISSIONS SCOPE SO -- IS THE
BOOKS PROGRAM WHAT WE THINK
COULD BE JUSTIFIED FOR SOME
OF WORLD LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS
THAT WAS SORT OF THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE PROGRAM WAS
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO LIBRARY
RESOURCES FOR WORK HOLD
LEVERAGE RESTRICTIONS THAT --
I CAN'T EASILY TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THINGS LIKE INTERLIBRARY
LOAN IT MIGHT BE VERY EXPENSIVE
FOR THOSE BY BURGER SECTIONS
ARE NOT ALL THE PARTICIPATING
PARTICIPATING JURISDICTIONS
ARE WORLD THERE ARE -- SOME
WESTWORLD JURISDICTIONS
CURRENTLY PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM SO WE THINK THAT THE
STATE CAN ALSO WORK WITH THE
STATE LIBRARY DO -- MAYBE YOU
FIND A WAY TO MAKE THE SCORE
BELOW MORE TARGETED ON OF THE
MOST WORLD THIS JURISDICTIONS
IN THE STATE ANALYSTS ON
THE LIBRARY INITIATIVE ARE
CONCERNED THERE IS ON MORE
THAT -- YOU JUST COMPARED TO
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
ARE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS A LOT
ABOUT THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
DOLLARS THE STATE RECEIVES IN
FUNDING FOR -- -- SUMMER LUNCH
PROGRAMS IT'S FUNDING WOULD BE
RELATIVELY SMALL HAVE A FAIRLY
SMALL IMPACT -- AND SO JUST FOR
THAT REASON IT MAY NOT BE SORT
OF THE HIGHEST ONGOING PRIORITY
FOR THE STATE'S MOTOR SOME OF
OUR PAST -- -- CONCERNS WOULD
RAISE AT BOTH A NATIONAL SURE
THANK YOU CAN I GO BACK TO OUR
STATE LIBRARIAN MISTER LUCAS
AND HAVE YOU RESPOND REALLY TO
THE SECOND SET OF ISSUES THE
FIRST ISSUE IS JUST A MONEY
THING FOR US TO DECIDE DO WE
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE BUDGET OR OR ONE TIME BUT
IF YOU CAN RESPOND TO THAT
THE THE POLICY -- CRITIQUE AND
FEEDBACK FROM THE L. A.
R. THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL THANK
YOU IT BE MY PLEASURE -- WELL
JASON'S RIGHT I MEAN INITIALLY
THE ZIP BOOKS PROGRAM WAS WAS
FIRST PILOTED IN RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR FURTHER REASONS
HE WAS ARTICULATING RIGHT SO
IF YOU LIVE IN A RURAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA GOING INTO TOWN --
IS -- ALL DAY AFFAIR AND SO IF
YOU CAN CALL THE LIBRARY AND
ASK FOR A BOOK AND THEY ORDER
IT SHOWS UP IN YOUR MAILBOX
-- THAT'S THE CONVENIENCE IT'S
ALSO AS JASON SAID IT'S ALSO A
CHEAPER WAY OF DOING BUSINESS
-- YEAH YOU KNOW I THINK IT
BE TERRIFIC IF LOCAL LIBRARIES
-- WE'RE FUNDED TO THE EXTENT
WHERE THEY CAN YOU KNOW TAKE
SOME OF THE SAVINGS THEY
ACHIEVE FROM THIS PROGRAM HELP
ALBEIT ONLY A MILLION DOLLARS
STATEWIDE AND PUT THAT TO --
IMPROVING THEIR LOCAL BUDGETS
SITUATIONS AND THEN THE THIRD
POINT I HEARD WAS YOU KNOW
THIS MAY WORK BETTER IN RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE AND WE DO
KNOW THAT IT DOES WORK BETTER
IN RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE BUT
IT WAS A PILOT PROJECT AND SO
WE EXPLORED USING IT IN OTHER
PLACES AND I WAS SURPRISED --
THE FEEDBACK I GOT FROM THE
GLENDA WILLIAMS THE THE LIBRARY
DIRECTOR IN LONG BEACH WHAT
SHE SAID THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
PROGRAM FOR US PARTICULARLY
IN RURAL AREAS WHERE YOU KNOW
MOST OF MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING SERVED BY THE LIBRARY
-- WHAT THEY'RE GETTING IN THE
MAIL ISN'T SOMETHING THAT THEY
REALLY WANT TO SEE SO HAVING
THESE BOOKS ARRIVES -- IS IS
BOTH YOU KNOW SAVINGS TO US THE
LIBRARY AND KIND OF THE SOCIAL
GOOD FOR THE PEOPLE WHO WE
HELP LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY WELL
YEAH YOU KNOW WE MEAN WE SPEND
A LOT OF MONEY FEEDING HUNGRY
POOR KIDS DURING THE SUMMER BUT
WE'RE STILL AT A POINT WHERE
FIVE ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE KIDS
WHO GETS A FREE OR SUBSIDIZED
SCHOOL MEALS DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR RIGHT ONLY ONE OF THEM IS
GET IN THE MAIL IN THE SUMMER
SO WHAT WHEN SAID SENATOR
MITCHELL AND HER STAFF THOUGHT
OF THIS CONCEPT I MEAN THEY'RE
THINKING WAS OKAY YES WE HAVE
PLACES WE HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
TWO THOUSAND LOCATIONS WHERE
SUMMER LUNCHES GET SIR BUT
THERE'S LOCATIONS THAT HAVE
A FALLING NUMBER OF PEOPLE
USING THEM SO WHY NOT BRING
THE POWER OF LIBRARIES I THINK
WHAT'S INTERESTING WHAT WHAT I
THOUGHT WAS EXTRAORDINARY WAS
THE LAST YEAR RIGHT LIBRARIES
ARE CLOSED NINETY EIGHT
LIBRARIES -- CONDUCTED YOU KNOW
WE HANDED OUT LUNCHES THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM AND PROVIDED
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEALS
SOMETHING LIKE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY KIND OF CREATIVITY CRAFT
KITS AND ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND FREE BOOKS SO
THOSE THREE HUNDRED MEALS THAT
THEY GAVE OUT LIKE AT CURBSIDE
DELIVERY AND DRIVE THRU SORT OF
OPERATIONS THAT'S TEN THOUSAND
MORE THAN HAPPENED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SO THANK I MEAN I'D BE
THE FIRST PERSON TO AGREE THAT
THE LIBRARIES AREN'T HAVING
LIBRARIES SERVE MEALS TO HUNGRY
POOR KIDS IN THE SUMMER ISN'T
GOING TO GET US FROM ONE OUT OF
FIVE KIDS HAVING A LUNCH BUT IT
BRINGS A LOT OF SECONDARY WELL
I DON'T THINK THEIR SECONDARY
BUT A LOT OF ANCILLARY BENEFITS
TO THE TABLE LIKE THE COOL
STUFF THAT YOU FIND IN EVERY
LIBRARY IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD
SAY AND I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK
TO ORGANIZE THIS BUT THERE'D
BE A LOT OF BENEFIT IN GETTING
EVERYONE ELSE INVOLVED IN
FEEDING HUNGRY POOR KIDS IN
THE SUMMER JUST SIT DOWN AND
TALK TO ONE ANOTHER TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN DO A BETTER
YEAH I I'D I'D LIKE THE CONCEPT
OF HAVING AND THE MEALS THAT
I'VE SEEN HERE IN SACRAMENTO
OR PUBLIC LIBRARIES AND TALK
TO OUR LIBRARIAN BECAUSE ASKED
ABOUT THEIR EFFORTS HERE AND
YOU KNOW I I I KNOW THESE ARE
AT THE TOP YEAH I KNOW THE
PROGRAM SOMETIMES ARE AT AT
SCHOOL SITES WHERE THERE SIMPLY
CLOSED AND PEOPLE JUST DRIVE UP
BUT I'M NOT GONNA SAY I'M NOT
GONNA SAY THAT EVERY FAMILY'S
GONNA PARK THEIR CAR GET SOME
LUNCH AND GO TO THE LIBRARY AND
CHECK OUT A BOOK AND SEE WHAT
ACTIVITIES THEY HAVE BUT MORE
LIKELY THAN NOT IF THEY DON'T
GO THERE TO PICK UP FOOD AND
SO JUST THAT JUST THE SPIN OFF
BENEFIT I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT IS CERTAINLY HELPFUL AND
AND THAT WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
YOU KNOW FEEDING MORE HUNGRY
KIDS DURING -- DURING THE
SUMMER FRANKLY ALL YEAR ROUND
YOU KNOW -- HAS A BIG IMPACT
ON ON HEALTH AND LEARNING AND
TO START HEALTH LIFESTYLES IN
CALIFORNIA SO -- YEAH THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DO SUPPORT
HE HAD GENERALLY AND WAS PART
OF ONE TIME AND -- IF WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ONGOING
LOOKED YOU KNOW MOST LIKELY --
PUT PUT FOR THIS THE REKO FROM
THE GOVERNOR -- IN THEM AFTER
THE MAY REVISE WILL HOLD OPEN
FOR NOW QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAYING
NONE -- THANK YOU SO NEXT
WE'LL GO TO THE SITE WITH STATE
LIBRARY ONE TIME PROPOSALS
SO START WITH BERMAN TO FINANCE
LA ON IN STATE LIBRARIAN
OKAY HELLO AT JENNIFER LOUIS
AGAIN -- MISTER CHAIR AT --
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
THE STATE LIBRARY'S ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AS MENTIONED EARLIER
REFLECTS EMPHASIS ON ACCESS
EQUITY AND BUDGET RESILIENCY
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS ARE ONE
TIME DINNER FINE ARE DEDICATED
TO THE LOCAL LIBRARY COMMUNITY
OUTREACH AND BOOK MOBILES
AND EARLY LEARNING AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AT THE COMPLETE
MY PRESENTATION ON THE STATE
LIBRARY'S ONE TIME PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU L. A. L.
OUR ASSESSMENT OF THE OF
THIS ITEM -- DIFFERS FOR THE
FIVE MILLION FOUR EDUCATION
ENRICHMENT GRANTS AND THE
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR BOOK
MOBILES SALT A TOUCH ON EACH
ISSUE FOR THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WHAT WE'RE CALLING
EDUCATION ENRICHMENT GRANTS
YOU TO BE THINGS FOR EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS AFTER SCHOOL
INITIATIVES -- WE THINK THAT
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT BECAUSE WILL
DUPLICATE A LOT OF ACTIVITIES
THAT THE STATE PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR -- TO K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS AND EARLY
EDUCATION PROVIDERS NOT ONLY
DUPLICATE IN TERMS OF THE
ON GOING FUNDING THAT STATE
PROVIDES BUT ALSO ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR LEARNING LOSS
BEING PROVIDED TO THE EDUCATION
AGENCIES I'M IN ADDITION IT
COMPARED TO THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WE PROVIDERS SCHOOLS
AND EDUCATION AGENCIES FOR K.
TWELVE EDUCATION EARLY LEARNING
FROM THIS INITIATIVE LIKELY
WHATEVER PRETTY SMALL IMPACT
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
RECOMMEND YOU REJECT ALL THE
PAUSE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN CONTRAST THE FOR THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR BOOK
MOBILES WE THINK THIS COULD
AMERICA GREATER CONSIDERATION
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET FOR ONE
THING THIS INITIATIVE IS MORE
TAILORED TOWARDS -- SPECIFIC
LIBRARY SERVICES WE ALSO THINK
IT'S IT'S POSSIBLE COULD HAVE
A CONNECTION TO THE PANDEMIC
AND SO FAR THAT IT HELPS OUR
LIBRARY PATRONS ACCESS LIBRARY
RESOURCES ON WHEN THEY CAN'T
ATTEND THEM THE MAYOR BRANCH
CAMPUS SO FOR THE THREE GREAT
REASONS WE RECOMMEND THAT FOR
THE THREE MILLION DOLLARS YOU
WAY THIS PROPOSAL -- AGAINST
RATHER ONE TIME PRIORITIES WHEN
YOU GET TO THE REDUCTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE HAVE MISTER
LUCAS FROM THE STATE LIBRARY
-- -- -- TESTIFY BUT ALSO
FOCUS ON THE THE L. A.
-- RECOMMENDATION ON THE SECOND
PROPOSAL TO NOT APPROVE THE --
THE -- FIVE MILLION FOR EARLY
LEARNING AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
RIGHT GREG LUCAS FROM THE
STATE LIBRARY THE EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IN ONE TIME MONEY
IT'S THE SECOND YEAR THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS DONE
MR MADE THIS INVESTMENT --
WE SKIPPED LAST YEAR BECAUSE
OF THE BUDGETARY ISSUES --
THE IT'S EXCLUDING THE LOCAL
LIBRARY AND REMOTE SOLUTIONS
TO PROVIDING LIBRARY SERVICES
THE THREE MILLION PLEASE
FIVE MILLION THE JASON WAS
DISCUSSING IS THAT IS WHAT
WE'VE BEEN SAYING TO HELP
PROMOTE LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN LIBRARIES AND OTHER
-- LOCAL AGENCIES SO THAT FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE BEST EXAMPLE
I CAN GIVE IS IN EL DORADO
COUNTY -- THEY HAVE FIVE
COMMUNITY HELPS YOU CAN GO ON
THE FIRST FIVE WEBSITE THERE
AND IT'LL SHOW THESE FIVE
COMMUNITY HUBS AND YOU CAN GO
TO THE COMMUNITY HELP BUTTON
ON A CERTAIN DAY YOU CAN GET
A WELLNESS -- YOUR KIDS CAN
GET A WELLNESS EXAMINATION ON
ANOTHER DAY THERE'S A FAMILY
LITERACY SPECIALISTS THERE
IS OTHER SERVICES TO HELP YOU
COORDINATE GETTING CHILD CARE
SIGN UP FOR WORK THAT KIND SO
IF IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAP RIGHT
IF YOU CLICK ON THE TO UNITY
HUBS ALL FIVE OF THE COMMUNITY
HUBS ARE THE LIBRARIES AND
CAN CALDERON ACCOUNT SO
CREATING THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS -- IS
KIND OF A NEWER THING FOR
LIBRARIES AND THE FIRST YEAR
THAT WE OFFERED THIS GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP PROMOTE THAT
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO THERE'S
A PIECE OF THAT THAT GOES TO
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMMING BUT --
WHO WE HAD BUDGET REQUESTS FROM
ALL PLACES ALL OVER THE STATE
THAT WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
LIKE WHAT EL DORADO WAS DOING
ALL RIGHT AND PASADENA FOR
EXAMPLE -- DECLARED THEMSELVES
TO BE A CITY OF KIDS AND WHAT'S
WORSE TRYING TO CREATE THE
SAME SORT OF RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN THEMSELVES ANOTHER
LOCAL SOCIAL SERVICES AGENCIES
SO THAT'S MAINLY THE INTENT
BEHIND THIS IS TO TRY AND
INCENTIVIZE -- LIBRARIES TO
WORK WITH OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES
AND AND AND IN FACT YOU CAN'T
GET A GRANT UNDER THAT PROGRAM
UNLESS YOU WALK YOU A LIBRARY
WALK IN THE DOOR WITH ANOTHER
LOCAL PARK WHETHER THAT'S
FIRST FIVE OR YOUR LOCAL
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THE WORD OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
OKAY WHAT WILL I I WILL NOTE
THAT IN IN GENERAL -- THIS
DECIDE COMMITTEE AND THE
ASSEMBLY HAS STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A STATE LIBRARY AN EARLY
LEARNING AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ARE TWO OF OUR TOP
PRIORITIES SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE CAN FOCUS ON THIS
AS A TRY FACT THAT SOMETHING
THAT IS IS THAT THE STRONG
INTEREST UP AT ME AND I THINK
OUR OUR OUR COMMITTEE SO
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
-- WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND --
REVISIT THIS -- AFTER THE NAY
REVISED THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO HOLD OPEN AND SINGLE
COMMENTS ON ON THIS ISSUE I
BEFORE WE GO TO THE LAST ISSUE
WITH HASTINGS CALLS A LOT
-- MAJORITY LEADER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I RAMOS -- YOU KNOW
WAS TAKE CARE OTHER BUSINESS
DURING THE PRESENTATIONS ON
-- THE -- ADULT EDUCATION
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS AS WELL
AS THE FAST THE PROPOSAL SO
WANTED TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS
ON THOSE TWO ISSUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR ON THE ADULT EDUCATION
ARE WE DID RECEIVE A LETTER
FROM THE -- LATINO CAUCUS
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
LATINO CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF A
PROGRAM THAT IS SPECIFICALLY
FOR ADULT FARMWORKERS IT'S THE
EPIC FEEL TO PROGRAM FOR ADULT
EDUCATION AND SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THIS PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED A VARIETY OF SERVICES
TO FARMWORKERS INCLUDING
ENGLISH AND CITIZENSHIP
PROGRAMS CAREER TRAINING AND
HIGH SCHOOL CLASSES IT WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF NOT
FUNDING THE EPIC PROGRAM THERE
IS SERIOUS CONCERN -- BECAUSE
THE THE EPIC AS A PRIMARILY
SERVES MIX STATUS ADULTS OVER
THE AGE OF TWENTY FOUR IF IT
IS THE IF HEALTH SPEND THEIR
REQUEST OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
AS WELL AS OTHERS THAT -- IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT WE PRESERVE
THE EPIC FIELD PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE MEETING
THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF ARE
DEALT FARMWORKER COMMUNITY
AT A MINIMUM THIS COMMITTEE
THIS COMMITTEE -- MAY WANT TO
RECONSIDER EXEMPTING FIELD OR
EPIC FIELD FROM THE PROPOSED
BUDGET CHANGE FOR DURATION OF
NO LESS THAN FIVE YEARS I THINK
NOW MORE THAN EVER OUR PRIORITY
MUST BE TO GIVE OUR WORK FORCE
AND THE CENTRAL WORKERS LIKE
I FARMWORKERS THE EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORTS THEY NEED TO SUCCEED
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADD THOSE COMMENTS -- MISTER
CHAIR ON ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
ELSE TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
THANK YOU FOR FOR GIVING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY ALSO TO MAKE
SOME COMMENTS AND I WAS ABLE
TO WATCH THE THE HEARING FROM
MY OFFICE AND THERE ARE FEW
COMMENTS -- AND I WANTED TO BE
SURE TO ADDRESS THEM -- PHELPS
FOR HIS THAT HAS BEEN OF GREAT
INTEREST TO ME AND I'VE AS AS
YOU KNOW HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF
BILLS IN THIS SPACE THERE'S
A COMMENT MADE THAT -- THAT
THIS CAN GET STUDENTS DEPORTED
OR INCARCERATED SHOULD THEY
FILL OUT THE FORM AND I WHILE
I APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IT'S THIS
TYPE OF FEAR MONGERING THAT
IS EXTREME TAILORING CAR OR
DEPORTATION MOST FAMILIES IN
THESE SITUATIONS THE SITUATIONS
DO FEAR -- IT AND WE DON'T
NEED TO ADD ANYTHING TO THIS
ACCORDING TO IMMIGRANTS RISING
IF YOU FILL OUT THE WRONG
APPLICATION THEY WILL PLACE
THE APPLICATION ON HOLD --
AND HOUSE OF NOW AND I HAVE
MY STAFF TO LOOK INTO THIS
WE ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH ANY
CASES OF INCARCERATION OR
DEPORTATION THAT IS HAPPENED
AS A RESULT OF ANYONE FILLING
OUT OF THE LOT THE THE WRONG
FORM WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO PROVIDE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STUDENTS
ANOTHER COMMENT WAS MADE
THAT STUDENTS TO FILL OUT THE
FASTBALL OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
ALREADY GOING TO COLLEGE NOT
STUDENTS WERE EXPLORING THAT
OPTION -- AROUND THIS IS AS
YOU CANNOT UNDERSTAND THIS IS
NOT ENTIRELY TRUE -- IT'S OUR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND THEY
NEED THAT HELP -- IS IT THERE
WERE COMMENTS -- ALSO MADE THAT
WE NEED SELF RESPONSIBILITY
FOR FAMILIES AND STUDENTS TO
GET THIS DONE -- THE STATUS
QUO WAS WE KNOW IS NOT WORKING
I DURING THE ONGOING ONGOING
PANDEMIC THE GREATEST DECLINES
IN CALIFORNIA PHELPS FOR
COMPLETION HAS BEEN WITHIN
THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE
YOUNGER STUDENTS OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE EVERY
EFFORT TO HELP THE YOUTH THAT
OUR STUDENTS FILL OUT THE FAST
REFORM WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
GREATER POSSIBILITY THAT THEY
WILL GO TO COLLEGE ANOTHER
COMMENT WAS THAT WE NEED
LESS GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE
SAME THING I I THINK THAT --
THE THE THE FAST FOR SHOULD
NOT BE SHOULDERED SOLELY BY
THE EARLY EIGHTIES I CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION LEADS
A HANDFUL OF ACTIVITIES AND
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATION COMPLETION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THEY'VE
CASH FOR COLLEGE WORKSHOP
WHEN WE'VE HAD THOSE ARE THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT OPPORTUNITY
AND ACCESS PROGRAM WE DID THAT
AS WELL THROUGH THE DISTRICT
THROUGH OUR COMMUNITY THESE
TRAININGS WALKED THE ATTENDEES
THROUGH HOW TO FILL OUT THE
FORM AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
WE DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
ANOTHER THING ANOTHER COMMA
THAT WAS MADE IS THAT THIS
IS TOO LARGE A BURDEN ON OUR
SCHOOLS WE DO HAVE TWO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA OF
ALBERDI UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND PERRIS UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHICH HAVE ENACTED
THE PHELPS FOR KEITA COMPLETION
POLICY CHANGE AND HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT OF POSITIVE RESULTS
IN VAL VERDE THE COMPLETION --
COMPLETION RATE HAS INCREASED
BY FOURTEEN PERCENT FROM SIXTY
NINE TO EIGHTY THREE PERCENT
OF IF WE DON'T DO THIS FOR
OUR STUDENTS OUR STUDENTS ARE
GOING TO BE PENALIZED IN THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO RECEIVE
THE FINANCIAL AID THAT THEY
WOULD BE ENTITLED TO -- THE
THE FINAL COMMENTS -- ONE THE
QUESTION WAS WHAT IS KEITA
THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION -- WHICH IS BEEN
IN PLACE FOR NEARLY A DECADE
AND IT IS CALIFORNIA STATE
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION THAT
ALLOWS UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
TO APPLY FOR AND RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID LAST QUESTION
IS WHAT DOES THE OPT OUT
LOOK LIKE AND DOES THIS COVER
MILITARY SERVICE ABSOLUTELY
IT DOES COVER MILITARY SERVICE
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS OR OTHER
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES THERE
ARE TO OPT OUT OPTIONS FOR
STUDENTS PARENTS AND ELEAZAR
OF A PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN
AS A STUDENT WHO IS EIGHTEEN
YEARS OR OLDER MAY OPT OUT
THROUGH A WRITTEN REQUEST
TO THE ALLEY A OR AN ALLEY
A COMPLY AGAIN EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR STUDENTS
WHO CANNOT COMPLETE THIS
REQUIREMENT AND THUS OPT THEM
OUT EXTENUATING EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY INCLUDE
MILITARY PLANS FOR RELIGIOUS
REASONS ENTERING THE WORK FORCE
AND A NUMBER OF OTHERS MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO -- NOT MY COMMENTS ON
THE RECORD OKAY THANK YOU
AND BOTH THOSE ISSUES WERE
HELD OFTEN IF YOU WERE
VISITING THEM AFTER THE
ME REVISED A LAST ISSUE
BEFORE PUBLIC COMMENT SLATED
TASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW WITH
WE HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ELEVEN HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
LAW WITH US IN A MINUTE FIRST
PLEASE YEAH BRIAN RUTLEDGE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
TWO POINT ONE MILLION ON THE
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION TO
SUPPORT HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAWS OPERATING COSTS THAT
COMES WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT TUITION REMAINED FLAT
IN THE ACADEMIC YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THE CONTEXT IS
THAT THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
VOTED LAST FALL TO RAISE
TUITION BY SEVEN PERCENT TO
COVER OPERATING COSTS AND
THIS PROPOSAL ESSENTIALLY
FUNCTIONS AS A WISH IN BUYOUT
TO ENSURE THAT HASTINGS
HAS SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
RESCIND THAT PORTION INCREASE
THOUGHTFUL WORLD BUILDING FOR
QUESTIONS OKAY L. A. L.
I'LL DISCUSS THREE THINGS
FIRST HASTINGS OVERALL SPENDING
INCREASES NOT JUST THE PROPOSAL
A GENERAL FUND BUT ALSO IT
STUDENT TUITION FEE REVENUE
SECOND I'LL DISCUSS HASTINGS
OUR PLANS ARE TO SPEND IT'S
FUNDING INCREASES UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THEN
A THIRD PROVIDER THOUGHTS ON
THESE MATTERS SO ON THE FIRST
ISSUE I WOULD DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO FIGURE ONE ON PAGE
FIFTY ONE OF YOUR AGENDA THIS
FIGURE SHOWS HASTINGS TOTAL
CORE FUNDING GENERAL FUND A
STUDENT TUITION FEE REVENUE
AND OTHER FUNDS IT USES FOR
ITS OPERATIONS AND THE BOTTOM
LINE OF THIS FIGURE IS THAT
HASTINGS IS EXPECTING A TOTAL
INCREASE IN BASE SUPPORT OF
SIX AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
ADDITION TO THE GENERAL FUND
ABOUT YOU SEE THAT THERE'S AN
MOST OF THE REMAINING INCREASES
COMING FROM STUDENT TUITION
AND FEE REVENUE THIS IS FROM
EDUCATED WOMAN GROWTHS ON THAT
THE MINISTRATION NOTED UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HE SINGS
IS NOT PLANNING TO INCREASE
STUDENT TUITION CHARGES YOU CAN
ALSO SEE THAT UNDER IN THE IN
THE TABLE THAT HE SINGS TOTAL
PLEASE FUNDING WOULD BE MORE
THAN RESTORED ABOVE ITS LEVEL
MIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
SO THIS BUDGET EFFECTIVELY
-- RESTORES CUTS THAT WERE
MADE ON A MASTER'S PROJECT
NEXT I WANT TO JUST TOUCH ON
HOW HE SINGS PLANS TO SPEND
ITS FUNDING INCREASED HAZING
SUBMITTED TO US THE -- A
PRELIMINARY SPENDING PLAN AND
THAT PLAN DID TWO THINGS FIRST
IT SUPPORTS OUR BASIC WORKLOAD
BUDGET CONSISTING OF THINGS
LIKE EMPLOYEE SALARY INCREASES
BENEFIT COST INCREASES AND
THEN THE REMAINING THREE POINT
SIX MILLION WOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO ADDRESS TO SCHOOLS ON OUR
BUDGET DEFICIT AND BILL BUDGET
RESEARCH AND ON THIS POINT
ARE WE HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS
TO SHARE TO THE COMMITTEE
WHICH IS THAT HE'S THINGS
IN ITS PLAN -- ANTICIPATES
ELIMINATING ITS STRUCTURAL
BUDGET DEFICIT THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN DISCUSSING
IN RECENT YEARS WE THINK THIS
IS A POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT
FINALLY IN TERMS OF OUR
THOUGHTS ON THESE MATTERS
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCREASE AND
LOOKING AT THE SCHOOLS PLANS
INDICATES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED LEVEL FUNDING IS
TWENTY ADEQUATE TO SUPPORT
THE SCHOOLS OPERATIONS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE EVEN HAS SOME
WIGGLE ROOM TO WORK WITH WHERE
THE STATE'S BUDGET SITUATION
TO WORSEN DURING THE REPAIRS
AND WORK LOCATION FOR EXAMPLE
-- SOMEONE HASTINGS WORKLOAD
BUDGET CONSISTS OF THINGS THAT
ARE SOMEWHAT MORE DISCRETIONARY
LIKE SALARY INCREASES FOR NON
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES JOHN
HUSING ALSO PLANS TO MAINTAIN
A BUDGET ARM SURPLUS AND
BUILD RESERVES ARMEL I JUST
MAKE SURE IF IF IT WERE IN A
-- INSURING THE REVISION AND
NEEDED TO FIND -- SOME LEVEL
OF FUNDING FOR OTHER PROGRAMS
IT COULD WORK WITH THE SCHOOL
TO -- MAYBE HOT NOT BUILDERS
ARE JUST MUCH THAT DOESN'T BE
OPTIONS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
WEIGH DURING THE REVISION OUR
ANALYSIS ARM YOU KNOW IT'S
JUST THAT WE RELEASED A FEW
MONTHS AGO TOUCH ON A FEW
OTHER ISSUES TOO WE WENT WE
RATE WE RAISED SOME ISSUES TO
CONSIDER AROUND STUDENT TUITION
LEVELS AND WE ALSO HAD AN
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATION ON
DIRECTED HASTINGS REPORT ON ITS
EXPERIENCE IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
GIVEN THE TIME AT ALL DEFERRED
ANY QUESTIONS TO THOSE ON THE
IN THE CULINARY OKAY THANK
YOU HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW
YES TRUMP MCCARTY GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THE COMMITTEE ARE
I AM DAVE STATEMENT ON THE
DEAN OF TASTINGS CULTURE
BLOG AND I'M JOINED BY DAVID
SCORED ON MY C. I.
HASTINGS IS ON A CONTINUES TO
GENERATE AN UPWARD TRAJECTORY
ARE WE WHAT MIDDLE CLASS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY WITH
EXTREMELY STRONG BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE -- OUR APPLICATIONS
ARE UP AROUND TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT -- ARE WE GOING TO
CATION OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM WE
ARE FIFTY AND TWENTY NINETEEN
IT IS ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT IS
DEDICATED TO OUR STUDENTS TO
WORK ON DISADVANTAGE -- WE WILL
BE AT MINIMUM OUR THIRD COHORT
CALIFORNIA SCHOLARS THIS YEAR
WE RECEIVED A CALL SCHOLARSHIP
AND EQUIPMENT BY TEN TO TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR ARE
THEY THIS SCHOLARSHIP IS
FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO
ATTENDED AND GRADUATED WITH THE
STORK LIKE BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THE H.
B. C. OUR NEW ACADEMIC BUILDING
-- THE COULD SHUT LAWCENTER
OPEN ON -- IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY AND IT AWAITS OUR
RETURN TO CAMPUS IT WOULD
BEGAN CONSTRUCTION ON A NEW
MIXED USE BUILDING THAT WILL
HAVE A THREE STORY IS -- ACT
REPLACEMENT ACADEMICS BASED
AT THIRTEEN STORY -- SUBSIDIZE
STUDENT HOUSING THAT WILL BE
SHARED WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING A UCS
STYLE BERKELEY AS WELL YES
YOU SAN FRANCISCO STATE ARM
WE ARE CONTINUING TO BUILD
PARTNERSHIPS WHERE DO YOU SEE
JACKSON'S AND CSU CAMPUSES
AROUND THE STATE -- WE ARE
PROUD TO SAY THAT OUR NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE GRADUATE WAS
ELECTED TO BE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES ARE WE
WILL HAVE A BALANCED BUDGET
THERE'S JUST TO MENTION
NEXT YEAR ARE WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND WE ARE
VERY THANKFUL TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
FOR THEIR CONTINUING
SUPPORT AND I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU
I JUST WANTED IT TO -- TO ASK
YOU -- DEAN FIGMENTS AS FAR AS
THE OVERALL INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF -- LAW SCHOOL APPLICANTS IS
THERE ANYTHING YOU I I THINK
I'VE HEARD THIS THAT IT'S NOT
JUST HASTINGS BUT ACROSS LAW
SCHOOLS IN OUR COUNTRY IT IS
IT CAN YOU CONTRIBUTED TO COVER
NINETEEN THE WHAT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR WITH OUR LOOK ON JUSTICE
AND EQUITY AFTER GEORGE FLOYD
IT WILL WHAT ARE THE FACTORS
THAT YOU SEE GOING INTO THIS
HUGE INCREASE IN APPLICATIONS
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION OUR
APPLICATIONS ROB ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT NATIONWIDE OURS UP
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX PERCENT -- I THINK THAT
THAT'S ATTRIBUTABLE PARTLY TO
REPUTATION OF SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA -- AND OF COURSE
HE'S DOING THIS WELL I DO
THINK THAT APPLICATIONS HAVE
BEEN UP OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS I DO THINK THAT IF
SOMEBODY TRIED TO THE BALL
YOU ARE THE FOCUS ON DIVERSITY
EQUITY INCLUSION I THINK IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE TO SOCIAL JUSTICE
INITIATIVES -- AND I THINK
IT'S QUITE DEEP ATTRIBUTABLE
TO -- THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
EVENTS OTHER HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS THAT
INDICATE THAT IN EDUCATION AND
LAW UP TO MAKE A FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE IN HOW PEOPLE BEHAVE
THAT CITIZENS ARE AND WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES THEY MIGHT THEY
MIGHT HAVE US MULTI FACTOR --
CIRCUMSTANCE I I DON'T THINK
IT'S SPECIFICALLY KOPEN -- IN
FACT IF ANYTHING WE THOUGHT
THAT APPLICATIONS WOULD BE DOWN
BECAUSE THE CODE -- AND THEY'RE
UP AND WE EXPECT THEM TO REMAIN
STRONG ALSO THE MARKET --
FOR WARRIORS HAS BEEN STRONG
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND
WE ANTICIPATE THAT THAT WILL
CONTINUE AND FINALLY I THINK
HASTINGS HAS A REPUTATION FOR
PRODUCING LEADERS AND PUBLIC
INTEREST IN PUBLIC SERVICE AND
I THINK THAT THAT WAS A GOOD
DEAL OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS IN PARTICULAR THIS YEAR
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE -- ON THE BUT
ON THE BUDGET THE PROPOSAL --
JUST WANT ONE BIG PICTURE IF
I KNOW THAT IT'S AN ECONOMIES
OF SCALE ARE DIFFERENT BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE FIND
FOR THE STATE NOT INCLUDING
YOUR TUITION I'M REVENUE JUST
THE JUST THE GENERAL FUND --
SUPPORT SO IT'S RIGHT SIXTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DIVIDED
BY YOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS
GETS TO TAX AMOUNT PER STUDENT
STATE SUPPORT IS THAT ROUGHLY
EQUIVALENT TO UCLA BERKELEY
AND IRVINE AND DAVIS LAW ARE
YOU OUT OF MY SEAT BELT RESPOND
WELL IT'S IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
QUESTION TO ANSWER BECAUSE
THE UC LAW SCHOOLS ARE DEEPLY
EMBEDDED IN CAMPUS SETTINGS
AND THIS IS MADE FROM THE LOCAL
TRANSFERS OFFICE AS TO HOW
TO ALLOCATE THE STATE FUNDS
AMONG VARIOUS PROGRAMS SOME
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS GET SUBS
THEY SUPPORT AND SOME YOU SEE
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS DO NOT GET
STATE SUPPORT SO IT'S REALLY
A DIFFICULT QUESTION THAT I
DON'T HAVE A READY RESPONSE TO
FAIR ENOUGH FAIR ENOUGH AND
THAT THAT'S WHAT I WOULD EXPECT
WOULD BE -- THE ANSWER JUST
LIKE WE SEE WITH WITH THE WITH
MEDICAL SCHOOLS AS WELL AS PART
OF THE OVERALL CAMPUS BUDGET
OKAY WITH THAT NO ACTION ITEM
ON THIS WILL HOLD OPEN UNTIL
AFTER THE MAY REVISE -- THIS
CAN CAUSE AND WE HAVE NO OTHER
MEMBERS HERE TO ASK QUESTIONS
OF THIS CONCLUDES -- THE --
THE ITEMS FOR THE COMMITTEE
TODAY THE ELEVEN ITEMS NO
ACTION ITEMS ALL CAN BE HELD
OPEN WE WILL NOW PROCEED WITH
PUBLIC COMMENTS SO IF YOU NO
ONE HERE IN THE AUDIENCE IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
ON THE -- TOLL FREE NUMBER A
PLEASE CALL ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN THANK YOU
TWENTY TWO RIGHT NOW YES
OKAY MODERATOR EITHER
I AM LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE ON EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR IS GOING TO GIVE
YOU A LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
AND THE PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE SO AGAIN TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS SIMPLY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU AND FIRST WE WILL GO TO
LINE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE THIRTY NEW GIRL BUT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING ON ISSUE
FIVE NEED TO STICK WITH IT IF
THEY HAD TECHNIKON CONCERNS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO LIMIT SERVICE TO
TWO ADULTS AND CHARTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS MAY BE PROGRAMS
PROVIDED SECOND CHANCE
BURKHART'S RATED DETERRENCE
MIGRANT WORKERS AND OTHER
DOLLS FOR GROWN THE TRADITIONAL
SYSTEM WAS NOT SUCCESSFUL I
WOULD NOTE THAT THESE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE VERY DIFFERENT SERVICES
THAT MORE HAVE MORE COUNT
ABILITY THAN TRADITIONAL ADULT
EDUCATION THESE ARE FULL TIME
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO THOSE
RULES AND REQUIREMENTS WHICH
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE
NOT WE HAD FURTHER NOTE THAT
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE FROM THE
MINISTRATION MADE SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMIT OPTIONS FOR SOME OF OUR
HIGH NEED STUDENTS AND CONTAIN
SOME AMBIGUITY REGARDING HOW
THE NEW HOW THE PROPOSED NEW
RESTRICTIONS MAY OR MAY NOT
APPLY TO THE SCHOOLS WE HAVE
MET WITH SEVERAL AFFECTED
SCHOOLED IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON THE ISSUE WE
BELIEVE IT IS THE TO GO FORWARD
IT WILL NEED SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND WE WOULD WELCOME
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THAT
ITEM ON ISSUE SIX YES THEY
SUPPORT GOVERNOR NEWTON'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE
PROGRESS TOWARDS ESTABLISHING
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
ACTIVE CRADLE DATA THE MOVERS
REPRESENT AN INVALUABLE TOOL
FOR POLICY MAKERS EDUCATORS AND
THE PUBLIC TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
DIDN'T NEED THEM DIRECT SCARCE
RESOURCES TO THE BEST USED FOR
OUR STUDENTS TO ACHIEVE COLLEGE
AND CAREER READINESS THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
GO TO THE NEXT PERSON
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY YOU ARE OPEN I CAN
HEAR ME YES HELLO OKAY GREAT
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ENOUGH
FONG WHAT THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
WE WOULD LIKE TO OFFER STRONG
SUPPORT BUT THE CRADLE TO
CAREER DATA SYSTEM AND OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE HARD WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO EXPLAINING
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE DATA
SYSTEM WILL ENABLE POLICYMAKERS
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF STATEWIDE INVESTMENT
IN EDUCATION AND SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF EQUITABLE POLICIES
AT THE STATE RECOVERS FROM THE
PANDEMIC AND RECESSION WE ARE
ESPECIALLY PLEASED AT THE DATA
SYSTEM WILL INCLUDE ALL HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENT INCLUDING
DATA FROM PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS WHICH IS THE FIRST
FOR CALIFORNIA ADDITIONALLY
WE WOULD LIKE THE OTHER
SUPPORT FOR INCREASING STUDENT
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID
FOR TOTAL COLLEGE COSTS BY
REQUIRING THAT LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES SUPPORT HIGHER HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR COMPLETION OF
FINANCIAL APPLICATION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU
FROM WHAT WE TAKE CALIFORNIA
I'M GONNA TAKE IN THE
FUTURE AND CURRENT TEACHER
PREPARATION EXPONENTIALLY
ALL RIGHT TO CONTACT I DO
NOT THE PROPOSAL DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION A JUDGE TEACHERS
AT THE POINT IN THE DEBATE
I DON'T NEED I UNDERSTAND
THE TEACHERS TO COMBAT THE
MANY OF THE STUDENTS AND FOR
GREAT I WILL FIND A TEACHER
THAT ARE MADE BY THE HEY WHAT
CAN I HELP ME BUT I WOULD
WE DEMAND ALL BE SENT
TO THE RESOURCE FOR THE
MAJORITY OF OUR PRINTER
IS ASSISTING THEM STOP
IT WAS MY TEACHER AND HOW
DOES NOT MEAN THE COST
OF I MUST DISPARITIES AND
IDENTIFICATION THANK THE
TICKET THAT THE NEED TO SUPPORT
IT CAN DETECT FALLS AND
WISH TO POTENTIAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
THANKS MISTER CHAIR WE
WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN I'LL BE HAPPY TO CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
AT THE CORE OF THE GOVERNMENT
PROPOSED INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SOME OF THE LAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS CALIFORNIA'S INSTITUTION
LEADERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE ENGAGED IN AN EXTENSIVE
COOPER PROSPECTS TO DEVELOP
A GREATER CRADLE TO CREATE
DATA -- WHICH HAS RESULTED IN
THE BOARD AND PEOPLE PLANET
THAT WILL MOVE CALIFORNIA
FORWARD IN IMPROVING COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS THE CURRENT
CONDEMNING AND THE DIFFICULTIES
MANY EDUCATORS DIDN'T TOUCH
BASE TO EASILY ACCESS DATA
ALEX HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES UNDERSCORE THE
NEED TO HAVE THE STATUS WITH
THEM TO UNDERSTAND THE LONG
TERM IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC
AND THE PAIR EACH GREAT
TO BREAK THE VISION HE ALSO
HAS A LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR TRICKLED OUT AND
THE FACT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATION FOR
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS THE
GOVERNMENT BUDGET HIGHLIGHT
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN A
DECLINE OF ABOUT TEN PERCENT
AND FOURTEEN POINT FIVE PERCENT
IN FOR FIRST TIME FRESHMEN
PASSED BY CALIFORNIA G.
MARC APPLICATION COMPLETION
RATE RESPECTIVELY BECAUSE OF
THE BILITY IS A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER THINKING LONG
CONVENIENCE THE CALIFORNIA
ADDED CHRIS DO YOU ARE
CONSIDERED PURSUING A COLLEGE
EDUCATION A CREDENTIAL
A CHALLENGE WHICH CAN
BE ADDRESSED IN PART BY
INTENTIONALLY INCREASE
UTILIZATION OF AVAILABLE
FEDERAL AID THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
LOPING ALONG WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOU TOO YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI
THERE CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW WE
CAN'T THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS DON KHAKI WITH
MCCUE CAPTION ASSOCIATES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ADULT EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA TOLD EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION K.
TWELVE ADULT EDUCATION
PROVIDERS PARTICIPATING IN
THE CALIFORNIA GOLD EDUCATION
PROGRAM MY COMMENTS RELATE
SPECIFICALLY TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN RELATED TO ADULT
EDUCATION WE APPRECIATE THE
ISSUES RAISED BY STAFF WITHIN
THE ANALYSIS REGARDING SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES WITHIN THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM NAMELY WE
STRONGLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE A
HIGHER COLA CONSISTENT OKAY
TELL PROGRAMS AT THREE POINT
EIGHT PERCENT TO ADDRESS THE
LACK OF A COLI IN THE LAST
BUDGET CYCLE AND TO HELP OFFSET
ADULT EDUCATION COST INCREASES
ADDITIONALLY WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING THE
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS THE DELIVERY
OF FUNDING TO ADULT EDUCATION
PROVIDERS THAT RESULTED IN K.
TWELVE ADULT SCHOOLS IN
PARTICULAR NOT RECEIVING
THEIR FUNDING UNTIL AS LATE
AS FEB WORRY IN THE CURRENT
SCHOOL YEAR WE PROPOSE THE
FUNDING BE PROVIDED DIRECTLY
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO DISTRIBUTE
TO PROVIDERS RATHER THAN
THE CURRENT PROCESS THAT IS
GROWING PROBLEM WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICT NOT BEING ABLE TO
FLOAT ADULT SCHOOLS WHILE
THEY WAIT FOR THE FUNDING TO
COMMENT WE ALSO STRONGLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
THE LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY
RELATED TO GROWING CARRYOVER
FUNDING THAT COULD OTHERWISE
BE SPENT ON THE CURRENT
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS WITHIN OUR
MOST MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
TODAY FOR ESL CITIZENSHIP
BASIC SKILLS TO HELP PARENTS
ENGAGE WITH THEIR K.
TWELVE LEARNERS AS WELL AS
SHORT TERM CAREER TRAINING
PROGRAMS ALL THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO
MID THE PANDEMIC'S IMPACT
CURRENTLY THE ISSUE THIS
FUNDING HAS ALLOWED TO BE
EXPENDED OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE NEEDS OF NEVER BEEN GREATER
TODAY FINALLY WE LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND ADULT EDUCATION
ISSUES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION WE LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER DISCUSSION THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE SEVENTY
ONE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES CAP
MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD STRUM
AND I'VE BECOME A REGULAR
PARTICIPANT IN THESE HEARINGS
I AM THE WIFE OF A CREDENTIAL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER AS WELL AS THE
MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN THE
OLDEST THREE OF WHOM ARE
BEING EDUCATED CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT
NOT FOR LONG THANK GOODNESS
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER IDEAS
POINTING OUT THE OBVIOUS THAT
WE HEAR IN CALIFORNIA NEED LESS
GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE BECAUSE
OTHER THAN HER INSIGHTS IT HAS
BEEN YET ANOTHER BANNER DAY
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
SHOWCASING THE WASTE AND
INCOMPETENCE OF THIS GOVERNING
BODY NO ONE IS AGAINST FEEDING
HUNGRY CHILDREN AT SCHOOL OR
IN THE LIBRARY OF COURSE NOT
WHAT WE ARE AGAINST IS THE
WASTE AND INCOMPETENCE OF THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE FACT THAT
YOU ARE SPENDING OUR MONEY
WHILE YOU DESTROY CALIFORNIA
YOU LEGISLATORS TALK ABOUT
THROWING AROUND HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IF IT
IS LOST TO LOOSE CHANGE IN
THE COUCH AND NOW YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT I T.
PAY THROUGH GRADE THREE
CREDENTIAL LOVELY ANOTHER
AREA OF GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY
WHERE YOU CAN WASTE EVEN MORE
OF OUR MONEY I MEAN MY GOD
THE RHETORIC COMING OUT OF
THIS HEARING IS ON REAL YOU
ALL SIT THERE AND WAX POETIC
ABOUT HOW EVERY STUDENT NEEDS
TO BE PRIORITIZED AND MADE
AWARE OF EVERY OPTION AVAILABLE
TO THEM WHEN YOU HAVE DENIED
THESE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN
PERSON EDUCATION FOR OVER A
YEAR WHO DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
FOOLING YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO PULL THE WOOL OVER
CALIFORNIANS ARE USED FOR
VERY MUCH LONGER TWO MILLION
SIGNATURES THIS GOVERNOR
IS ON NOTICE AND ANY OF THE
REST OF YOU COULD BE NEXT
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER WE
WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MCCARTY AT
THIS MAY WELL BE GET OUT THE
HOUSE EDUCATION TRANSPLANTS
HERE TO COMMENT ON ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT ALL WE HAVE TO A GROWING
COALITION OF FIFTY SIX FOR
THE PATIENT AND TWENTY PLUS
PRACTITIONERS ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH INCLUDE THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE LOTUS
WHAT THE FOUNDATION I CAN
THE BEST CHESS CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN SUPERINTENDENTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE ADDRESS
TRIPLE SKI WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE STOP SEARCHING
THE COMPLETION PROPOSAL DATA
FROM PP I SEE CALPERS TO MAKE
COMMISSION HAVE HIGHLIGHTED WHY
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATIONS WERE
DOWN FIRST TIME STUDENTS WERE
DOWN COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
APPLICATIONS WERE DOWN LOW
INCOME STUDENT APPLICATIONS
WERE DOWN AND YOUNGER ST
APPLICATION DOWN CALIFORNIA
IS LAGGING BEHIND STATES
LIKE LOUISIANA TEXAS INDIANA
ILLINOIS TENNESSEE DC ALL
PASSED THE MORE FINANCIALLY
COMPLETION POLICY NOT JUST
BECAUSE IT'S GOOD FOR STUDENTS
BUT BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
WORKFORCE POLICY THAT HELPS
BUILD OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE
ALL STUDENTS WILL BENEFIT FROM
NOT ONLY MOWING TO STUDENTS
WHEN THEY GET ACT BETWEEN
TITLE MIDDLE BOARD THAT HIGH
SCHOOL MIDDLE AND HIGHER INCOME
STUDENTS CAN YOU THAT OPTION
TO THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
TO WORK STUDY STUDENT LOANS
INSTITUTIONAL EVEN COLLEGE
BUS TO KEEP CLEAR THIS ISN'T
A GRADUATION REQUIREMENT OUR
OPT OUT PROVISION THIS ISN'T
SAYING THAT ALL IN ALL YOU'D
HAVE TO COLLECT AND SUBMIT
THESE FORMS THEMSELVES AND
THIS IS ESTABLISHING A NEW
PROCESS THAT YOU CAN FAMILIES
ARE ENGAGING WITH ALREADY THIS
IS ENCOURAGING AND ACTIVITY
AND ESTABLISHING A LAST MILE
POLICY SOLUTION TO MAXIMIZE
AND LOOKED AGAIN RETURN OF
INVESTMENT ON ALL PROGRAMS
SERVICES INITIATIVE AIMING TO
INCREASE FINANCIAL COMPLETION
FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT SIMILAR POLICY
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN ALL
OF THE STATE AND TO -- GATES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH ANY CHANGE OF
INCARCERATION DEPORTATION OR
ANY OTHER NEGATIVE IMPACTS
TO STUDENTS THANK YOU WILL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK -- THANKS
WE WILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I NEXT WE WERE LINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MY LOOK ON THE
OTHER HAND WITH WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA HERE TO
SPEAK -- TO COME IN ON ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT -- WE SUPPORT
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL TO REQUIRE
ELLIE EIGHT TO CONFIRM THAT ALL
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETE
THE FACT THAT OR THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATION FINANCIAL
AID IS CRITICAL FOR STUDENTS
-- RESEARCH SHOWS THAT STUDENTS
TO COMPLETE THE FACT THAT
ARE MORE LIKELY TO DIRECTLY
WHILE IN COLLEGE ANY PERCENT
FOR STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THE
FACT THAT COMPARED TO FIFTY
FIVE PERCENT FOR STUDENTS
WHO DO NOT COMPLETE ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTY WILL INCREASE -- ALL
STUDENTS FACULTY SUPPORT NEEDED
TO COMPLETE THE FORMS AND
INCREASE THEIR OPPORTUNITIES
-- FOCUSED ON PROTECTING YOUR
EDUCATIONAL HERE TO THEIR COULD
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY THREE
YOU ARE UP GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I AM
CRISTINA CARO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LIBRARY ASSOCIATION
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
ALL OF THE STATE LIBRARY
ITEMS PROPOSED FOR FUNDING BY
THE GOVERNOR ON YOUR AGENDA
INCLUDING THE SCENIC FEES YOU
RECEIVED A LETTER FROM ME AND
MIKE DILLON INDICATING FILLETS
ADDITIONAL REQUESTS FOR PP
FUNDING FOR SAY FREE OPENING
AND RESTORATION OF A CUT MADE
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET TO THE
CALIFORNIA LIBRARY SERVICES
ACT BUT THE ISSUE THAT IS OF
IMMEDIATE CONCERN IS THE NEED
TO ACCELERATE THE EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR THE LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY
PROGRAM INTO AN EARLY ACTION
BUDGET TRAILER BILL SO THAT
CHILDREN CAN RECEIVE MEALS AT
THE LIBRARY IN THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CLA SUPPORTS
THE STATE LIBRARIANS EFFORT
IN THIS REGARD WITHOUT EARLY
ACTION TWELVE LIBRARY SITES IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND SITES IN
LONG BEACH SANTA CLARA FONTANA
AND SANTA CLARITA MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO SERVE CHILDREN IN NEED
OF LUNCHES THIS SUMMER FOR
SOME CHILDREN THIS MAY BE THEIR
ONLY MEAL OF THE DAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
WHAT DO I NEED SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN
CATALANO HALLORAN WITH THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER GSPC IS ANOTHER ONE OF
THOSE PLACES TODAY TO DISAGREE
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION ON
ITEM NUMBER FIVE REGARDING
ADULT CHARTER SCHOOLS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR
TRADITIONAL ADULT EDUCATION
FUNDING IT'S NOT THAT THEY
CHOOSE A DIFFERENT FUNDING
TOWARDS THAT WHEN THE APARTMENT
OF FINANCE RESTRUCTURED THE
ADULT EDUCATION FUNDING PROGRAM
SEVERAL YEARS AGO DEALERS
EXCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
TOLD THEM THAT THEY HAD THEIR
OWN SEPARATE SOURCE OF FUNDING
BUT NOW THE PROPOSAL WANTS
TO CUT THAT OFF WE BELIEVE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO COMPLETE A HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION REGARDLESS OF
AGE THE CURRENT PROGRAM ISN'T
SUFFICIENT CAN MEET THE NEEDS
AND THAT'S WHY YOU SEE HIGH
QUALITY FAST GROWING CHARTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS GOING THROUGH
CHARTER SCHOOLS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE FURTHER RESTRICTION
OF THE SUN THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
FIVE YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH LIKE MAYBE FIVE
YES GO AHEAD
YES YES MY NAME IS DR DOROTHY
STEWART AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
THE DIRECTOR OF THE OLD
FIREHOUSE SCHOOLS MADE UP
OF THREE PRESCHOOL CHILDCARE
A TECHNICAL AREA SERVING
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
FAMILIES I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE HONOR OF BEING ABLE
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY I HAD
THREE POINTS AND LIKE TO MAKE
YOUR CONSIDERATION RETURNING
BUDGETING FOR THE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE EXPANSION OF
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS PEOPLE
POSTPONED TO ALL FOR YOUR OUT
NUMBER ONE THE DEFENSE WILL
BE A DEVASTATING BLOW TO TEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
EXISTE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
CHILD SUPPORT ON THE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO EXIST FOR THE LOSS
OF INCOME FROM OUR FOR LOW
NUMBER TO CANCEL FIND WITHOUT
THE FEW OPTIONS FOR CARE FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS AT THE
PROVISIONAL SUCH CARE SO MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN CARE FOR
FOR YOUR OWN FUTURE THE NEED
FOR LOWER TEACHER INCOME RATIO
ONE TO THREE GENERAL MILLS
IS UNDERWRITTEN BY THE INCOME
FROM FOUR YEAR OLD WITH A ONE
TO ONE RATIO NUMBER SEVEN MY
LAST ONE OF EQUITY OTHER TO BE
EIGHT THOUSAND IN THE FIELD OF
CHILD CARE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WOMEN MUCH OF OUR WORKFORCE ARE
WOMEN OF COLOR THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WILL PUT THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES OUT OF BUSINESS AND
THOUSANDS OF WOMEN OUT OF WORK
FINALLY WON'T BE TO CONSIDER
THE FACT THE BUDGET FOR THE
LAST ONE HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS
OF FIELD EARLY EDUCATION HAS
GROWN IN OUR KNOWLEDGE AND
PROFESSIONALISM PRIMARILY IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR MOORLACH
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT IT WAS
MAIN FLOOR ONLY OPEN SEVEN
CALIFORNIA FAMILY THE NEAR
CONNELLY JEFF -- TRYING ON
THE CALL THE TENDON DON'T
BREAK OUR HEARTS AND OUR
BANK ACCOUNTS NOW BUT LEAVING
A OUT OF CONSIDERATION OF
FUNDING AB TWENTY TWO OKAY
THANK YOU FOR MARCH FOURTEENTH
THANK YOU THANKS BAKER PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIFTY SIX SHE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THIS
IS CHUCK FROST I'M SPEAKING
TO YOU TODAY ON ITEM TWO
WHICH IS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE STATEWIDE K.
TWELVE SCIENCE LEADER
NETWORK MANAGED BY THE SAN
FRANCISCO EXPLORATORIUM WHICH
I KNOW YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WAS REMOVED FROM
THE BUDGET WE WOULD REQUEST
THAT YOU RESTORE THAT MONEY
-- IN THE UPCOMING BUDGET
AS A PART OF THE BROADER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS BUT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING WHICH IS SOMETHING
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS -- THESE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE GOTTEN TO ABOUT
EIGHTY THOUSAND TEACHERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND ARE
EQUITY DRIVEN AND T.
AND GET TO TEACHERS IN THE MOST
AT RISK IRRITANTS -- ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I
WANT TO SUPPORT THE -- IN TSS
FUNDING AS WELL AS THEIR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION GRANT
EXPANSION LET'S HOPE YOU AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL ARE
SUPPORTING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER PLEASE
ONE SEVENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY SMITH HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO HERE IN THE OFFICE --
I'LL BE HALF OF BUT AS PART
OF THE GET REAL COALITION --
ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR REGARDING
THE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
AND FOR THE CLIENT UNDERSTAND
THAT TODAY'S HEARING WITH
THE COMMISSION ONLY REGARDING
THIS GRANT GOVERNOR GLOBAL
IN THE BUDGET FOR IT I WANT
TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS COMMENT ON
SUPPORTING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL'S -- POLICY BILL
TO EXPAND THE FUNDING OF THIS
GRANT I THINK IT'S OBVIOUS TO
ALL OF US -- THAT -- FROM THE
ANALYSIS THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
IN THE GRANT THAT WAS JUST
NOT ENOUGH TO MEET DEMAND --
MORE THAN DOUBLE THE DEMAND
FOR THE MONEY IN THE GRANT --
THAT EXISTS NOW IS BECAUSE I
WE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE
-- -- ARE ARE DEMANDING THAT
THERE BE OPTIONS FOR THEM IN
HIGH SCHOOL -- THAT DON'T JUST
PUT THEM ON A COLLEGE TRACK
THAT -- GIVE THEM THE SKILLS
THEY NEED TO DO AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL HAVE A CAREER LIKE A
CAREER IN THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES THAT IS ITSELF A THREE
TO FIVE YEAR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM WHICH ACTS AS THEIR
SECONDARY EDUCATION BUT YOU'RE
TO WORK AND EARN A LIVING RIGHT
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL SO WE WE
WE SUPPORT THE EFFORTS TO ADD
MORE MONEY TO THE GRANT MOVING
FORWARD TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE
BUT ALSO ENSURE THAT WE KEEP
THE STRICT ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS IT EXISTS NOW SO
THAT WE KNOW THAT -- K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS -- AN ARCHITECT
IF YOU'RE USING THE MONEY
IN A WAY THAT IS -- GOES
TO THE STUDENTS FOR CRICKET
EDUCATION CLASSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
I NEED A WHEN YOU ARE OPEN
LOPING ALONG OVER LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
I CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOW I FIND
OUT ON BEHALF OF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES I'M CALLING AT THE
PORT OF THE CREDIT THE CAREER
DATA FROM THE DATA SYSTEM
AVAILABLE AND DISAGGREGATED
BY RACE AND ETHNICITY WILL
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO TRULY
IDENTIFIED THE OPPORTUNITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS IN EXPERIENCE
FOR OVER HALF OF ALL K.
TWELVE STUDENTS IN ADDITION
WE SUPPORT THE REQUIREMENT
THAT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
FILL OUT THE PAST ARCADA
BEFORE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
HAVING ACCESS TO THE EIGHT
TO WHICH THE STUDENTS ARE
ENTITLED TO WILL OPEN THE
DOOR FOR SO MANY MORE STUDENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
MY NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES
-- HI THIS IS WHAT YOU SEE
ON BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND THE TWENTY THREE
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO CONFIRM THAT ALL
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETE
ABSENT OR THE DREAM APP
APPLICATION AND THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR STUDENTS TO OPT OUT WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S LANGUAGE
PROVIDING DISTRICT MAXIMUM
DISCRETION ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT
THE REQUIREMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RATES MENTION TO
DISTRICTS FELL THIRTY UNIFIED
IN PARIS UNION THAT REQUIRES
AFFECT REMAX COMPLETION AS PART
OF THEIR HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT WHICH SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOME BOTH EVERITT THESE
DISTRICTS ARE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY YET MANY OF OUR OTHER
DISTRICTS HAVE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND -- COMPLETING
ABSENT IN -- ANGRY MAC TO
APPLICATION SO MAINTAINING
THAT DISTRICTS FLEXIBILITY OF
IMPLEMENTATION IS CREDIT IS OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU LET'S BAKER PLEASE
WHY NINETY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ARE NOT ABOUT THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EDGE COALITION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA STANDS AT LEAST SEEN UNDER
REX UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
ARE THINKING THAT NOTHING
COMPARES TO ECONOMIC MOBILITY
AND THEIR DATA TO DOUBLE BE
A TOOL TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
AND ADULT LEARNERS ACCESS TO
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES WHILE
ALSO HELPING RESEARCHERS AND
POLICYMAKERS UNDERSTAND AND
IDENTIFY DISPARITIES WITHIN
THE EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE WE
ALSO WANT TO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE L.
A. L. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
REGARDING THE GOVERNING BOARD
MEMBERSHIPS AND THE IMBALANCE
OF THE REPRESENTATION BETWEEN
DATA PROVIDERS AND THE PUBLIC
WE WILL ALSO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO PROTECT FUNDING LEVELS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM AND WILL REQUEST THE
INCREASE OF THE ONE POINT
FIVE PURPLE COLOR COULD BE
MATCHED WITH THE KEY TO TALK
TECHNICAL OF THREE POINT
EIGHT THANK FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THERE CALL IT
SHOULD ALSO BE MATCHED WITH
THE KEEP THE TOPIC MEANT
TO BETTER SERVE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND ADULT LEARNERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M P.
SURE A ROOF SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF FIELD ACTION DID NOT
CONCEIVABLY LEARNING ALLIANCE
A COALITION OF EDUCATORS
INDUSTRY AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS
TO BE A MOVEMENT PROVIDE HELP
MORE STUDENTS DANCE SCHOOL
GRADUATE ON TIME AND DEVELOP
THE KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS
EMPLOYERS SEEK FOR THE FUTURE
I'M SPEAKING TO ISSUE SIX
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSED DATA SYSTEM INVESTMENT
IS CRITICAL FOR PROVIDING
COMMUNITIES WITH THE ESSENTIAL
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
EFFECTIVELY MONITOR STUDENT
OUTCOMES ADDRESS STUDENT NEEDS
AND STRENGTHEN TRANSITION
SUPPORT STUDENTS MOVE FROM
ONE EDUCATIONAL SEGMENT TO THE
NEXT AND INTO THE WORKFORCE WE
KNOW THESE INTERSECT THAT'LL
BE THE LINKAGES ARE IMPORTANT
MORE NOW THAN EVER AT SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES REBUILD AND
RECOVER FROM CO THAT THIS
MOVEMENT HAS UNDERSCORED THE
NEED FOR DATA ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT SCHOOLS COLLEGES
IN THE WORK FORCE SO WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE LONG TERM
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC AND
PREPARE FOR FUTURE CRISES
DURING ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
WANTED TO THE DATA THAT PROVIDE
THE FULL PICTURE OF STUDENT
PERFORMANCE AND OUTCOMES
INCLUDING FOR SUBGROUPS MUST
BE A PRIORITY FOR THE STATE
IT'S A FOUNDATIONAL LONG
OVERDUE INVESTMENT TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND EQUITY
CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG PEOPLE OF
ALREADY LOST SO MUCH BUT THE
REAL TRAGEDY WOULD BE NOT TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO PREVENT
THEM FROM LOSING THEIR MOMENTUM
AS THEY PROGRESS THROUGH K.
TWELVE TO COLLEGE AND CAREERS
THIS DATA SYSTEM WILL HELP
US TO DO THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
THANK YOU BYE NINETY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GAIL YOUNGER CALIFORNIA
HIGHER EDUCATION -- SORRY
CONNIE THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
PHYSICALLY ON ISSUE NUMBER
SIX RELATED TO THE CRADLE
TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM RESET
PARK AVENUE SOUTH FOR COCOA
TO CONTINUE THE PROGRESS
DURING THE LAUNCH OF THE DATA
THE DEATH OF A CRITICAL HIT
AND AND ELIMINATING STUDENT
PATHWAYS FROM PRE K.
TO TWELVE THE CONFECTIONERY
EDUCATIONAL INTO THE WORK
FORCE EVERY POINT IN EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT TYPE MIGHT PRESENT
AN OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES ALLOW US
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW
THE CURRENT PANDEMIC IMPACTS
CALIFORNIANS AND HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS MORE
POIGNANTLY POTATOES THE SEMI
HELP THE STATE PARKS ACTIVELY
TARGET MONEY TO THE CLOCKING
AT THE PORT IN FACT THAT ON
THE GOVERNMENT PEOPLE POPPING
MEANING OF EXECUTIVES OF THE
STATE AGENCIES TO SERVE ON
THE BOARD THAT'S WHAT PROMOTE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND USEFULNESS
OF THE DATA AND LIKE THE L.
A. L. B. BELIEVE THE STRUCTURE
OF THE GARDEN FOR COULD BE
STRENGTHENED BY INCREASING THE
POINT THE PUBLIC MEMBERS ON
THE BOARD WE APPRECIATE ARE
ROUTINELY SHARED COURT MCGEORGE
WORKING AT ALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO YOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HI THIS IS ISAAC ASIMOV
COMMENTING ON THAT PASSAGE IMAC
REQUIREMENT -- THE CASHIER OF
THE BELLAGIO SUGGEST THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD LEAD
TO AN INCREASE AND -- FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATION AND UTILIZATION
RATE THE MY RECITAL GRADUATES
-- ONE KEY BENEFIT THAT THIS
WILL LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL PELL GRANT FUNDING TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH THEIR
WHOLE POPULAR TENANTS ALTHOUGH
THE FULL AMOUNT OF ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WE'VE GONE
DOWN IS UNCERTAIN IT COULD
BE CONCEIVABLY BE IN ALLOW
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IMPLEMENTATION STATE
CAL GRANT CAUGHT THE IMPACT
AS WELL WITH ELIO AS MAIN
YOU COST IN THE TENS TO LOW
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN CONTRAST ALL YOU
CAN ACT IN THE MOTHER STATES
THE GOVERNOR PAUL DID NOT TIE
THE COMPLETION OF A FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATION HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS THE
PROVISION TOGETHER WITH THE OPT
OUT EXEMPTION PROVISIONS ARE
INTENDED TO REMOVE THE BURDEN
OF PILING UP OF FORMER STUDENTS
WHO OTHERWISE MIGHT NOT BENEFIT
DOING SO THE GOVERNOR'S BALL
BALL'S REQUIRED DISTRICTS TO
DIRECT STUDENTS TO SEE THAT
ARE WHICH PROGRAMS IN ORDER
TO HELP STUDENT THAT GETS UP
TO SOME PROCESS DALY ALSO NOTE
THAT THE PROPOSAL COULD CREATE
A MEDICAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
A POP FOR THE STATE REQUIRED
TO REIMBURSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
INCLUDING SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
THE COST OF NEW PROGRAMS AND
HIGHER LEVELS OF SERVICE BOTH
BUT STATE AT THE GAZA BORDER
ENACTED AND IT'S I'M MORE TO
DETERMINE THAT IT CONSTITUTES
A MANDATE IN THE STATE WOULD
NEED TO COVER THE COSTS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE COST WOULD
DEPEND ON THE SPECIFIC HAVE
YOU THAT THE ASSEMBLY TERMS
TO BE REIMBURSABLE ALTHOUGH
BECAUSE OF YET TO BE DETERMINED
IT WILL LIKELY BE MINOR
COMPARED TO OTHER EXPLAINED
BACK OF THE OF THIS PROPOSAL
DALYELL RECOMMENDS ADOPTING A
PROPOSAL AND CONCEPT OF WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
FURTHER ENSURE THAT THE NEW
REQUIREMENT DOES NOT CREATE ANY
UNNECESSARY HOSPITAL DISTRICTS
STOP NOTE THAT THE INTENT
WAS PROPOSAL IS TO INCREASE
FINANCIAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS WHICH HAS LONG BEEN
A GOAL OF THIS SUB COMMITTEE
REPORTER PROBABLY PLACES THE
ONUS ON THE SCHOOL NOT STUDENTS
TO ENSURE THAT THE OR CAD A
COMPLETION THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER PLEASE
HOPING ONE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE ONE HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
JESSICA KAKO IN BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW DEPENDING AGAIN
CREATED ENORMOUS PRESSURE FOR
THE EDUCATION WORKFORCE AND HAS
RESULTED IN LAYOFFS CHALLENGES
WITH RECRUITMENT IN THE
PLACEMENT OF STUDENTS TEACHERS
EARLY RETIREMENT TO SIGNIFICANT
NEED FOR PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
TO HELP ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
INTO FOR TEACHER PREPARATION
RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING INCLUDING
THE PROGRAM TO DISCUSS TODAY WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE A MULTI YEAR COMMITMENT
INCLUDING SPREADING OUT THE
ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDING OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS IN ORDER TO
MORE EFFECTIVELY INVESTING THE
STRATEGY WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTED
BY THE VISION AND SCOPE OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM I BELIEVE IT IS
ESSENTIAL TOOL THAT WILL HELP
STUDENTS FAMILIES PRACTITIONERS
RESEARCHERS AND POLICY MAKERS
IT INCLUDES THE CRITICAL
INVESTMENT AND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE GUIDANCE AGAINST THE C.
GI WHICH HAS A PROVEN TRACK
STUDENTS AS THEY PLAN FOR
IT WELL IN TRANSITION AND
THE HIGHER EDUCATION TO
HELP ENSURE USABILITY OF
THE CRADLE TO CAREER SYSTEM
FOR ALL STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE
BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THE GOVERNING BOARD INCLUDE
PUBLIC MEMBERS IN ADDITION
TO INSTITUTIONAL LEADERS
AND THAT THEIR VOTE COUNTS
AS SYSTEM IS BEING FURTHER
DELINEATED AND IMPLEMENTED
WITH RESPECT TO INCREASING
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION WE
FULLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO REQUIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO CONFIRM THAT ALL
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETE
THE FASTER OR CALIFORNIA DREAM
APP APPLICATION AND FINALLY
WE WANT TO NOTE OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE SPEECH EVEN IF IAN
CENTER GRANT A STUDENT TO
ENROLL IN PP ARE MORE LIKELY TO
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
PINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO MY NAME IS MARK SMITH AND
I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HOUSE
COMMITTEE CHARTER TECHNICAL
SCHOOLS ALLEN'S WE PROVIDE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
CITIZENSHIP HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND ROBERT C.
P. PROGRAM WHICH YOU ALL
WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER
THE SOCIAL IMPORTANCE OF
TRANSITIONING INTO THE
WORKFORCE LIKE TRUCK DRIVING
MEDICAL SYSTEM CONSTRUCTION
BASED PROGRAMS EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION EVENTUALLY AND
COSMETOLOGY IN FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT IT PATHWAYS I LIKE
TO SPEAK ON ITEM FIVE THE
PROPOSED AGE CAP WE ARE AGAINST
THE LANGUAGE WE SUBMITTED
LANGUAGE TO MANY THAT PROVIDES
COST CONTROLS AND CERTAINLY AN
ASPECT OF WHAT WE BELIEVE TO
BE THE GOVERNOR'S OVERARCHING
AGENDA THIS PROPOSED LANGUAGE
THAT IS REPORTS NOW PUNISHES
IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES JUSTICE
INVOLVED AND COMMITTEES ARE
COLORS WHO THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
TALKING THROUGH THESE LAST FEW
HOURS HAVE BEEN MOST HURT BY
THE COLD -- TRAGEDY EFECTIVOS
LANGUAGE WILL REVERT SCHOOLS
BACK TO NINETEEN TWENTY FUNDING
LEVELS WITH NO RESPECT TO IT SB
EIGHT TWENTY WHICH ALLOWED PER
GROWTH LIKE THE FUEL SCHOOL IN
OURS WHICH IS EXPRESSED GROWN
BY OVER A THOUSAND STUDENTS
TEACHERS OR EVEN PUNISHES
WOULD NOT ALLOW THE CURRENT LAW
THIS ALONE WOULD BE ALMOST
UNRECOVERABLE PAIN PROBABLY
MAKE MANY OF US CLOSE OUR DOORS
MATTER OF FACT WE EVEN WORLD
MANY MANY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
SINCE THE TIME OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT MOST CRITICS TIONAL OR
MANY OF THE TRADITIONAL DAHLE
THAT PROGRAMS HAVE SHUT DOWN
WHEN HE SPOKE WHEN THESE
POPULATIONS WITHIN THE MOST
SURVIVAL DON'T SEVEN CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT IS SUPPORTED FROM
THINGS I'VE EVER HEARD OF A
LATIN CAUCUS THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK CHAMBER AGING CHAMBERS
EVEN SOME OF THE LARGEST
SUPERINTENDENTS IN THE STATE
TESTIFIED TO SUBMIT LETTERS TO
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
THE MAYBE BY SLASHER HE SAID
THE SCHOOLS ARE CRITICAL TO
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN THEIR
DISTRICTS THESE ARE LARGE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH PROBABLY
SURPRISES MANY EVEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE THAT SUPERINTENDENTS
OF LARGE DISTRICT WHICH BECOME
WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THIS
COMMITTEE CERTAINLY TO HELP
YOU UNDERSTAND THE VALUE AND I
KNOW WHEN I APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND EFFORT YOU PUT IN I KNOW
YOU HAVE A DIFFICULT JOB WE
WANT TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO HELP CALIFORNIA MOVED
FORWARD IN THE TRAINING AND
RETRAINING OF THE OF THE MOST
DEVASTATED POPULATIONS -- THAT
WE CURRENTLY SERVE EN EL THANK
LIMIT AT ALL YOU TEND EITHER TO
WRAP IT UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MY LOOK LIKE COULD YOU BE
ABLE TO FIND THAT YOU KNOW IS
GOING ON SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
NUMBER
SENATE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF
REPRESENTING MYSELF SUPPORT
ON THE BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
REQUIRE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY TO CONFIRM ALL HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETE
FREE APPLICATION FOR FEDERAL
STUDENT AID FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATION GOOD
CANCER HIGH SCHOOL I KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THEIR
FINANCIAL AID TO GO ON FOR
MORE EDUCATION OR TRAINING I
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND ALL YOU DO FOR
OUR STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AS
A REMINDER TO THE PARTICIPANTS
ON THE PHONE LINES -- TO
MAKE IT RIGHT PLEASE PRESS
PLEASE PRESS ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE ONE
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT NINE
ONE OH TO YOUR OPEN
WHAT DO YOU MAKE IT YOURSELF
BUT YOU PLEASE PRESS STAR ONE
ZERO AGAIN AND IN THE MEANTIME
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE ZERO ONE
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NOT VALUE TO THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THE ASSOCIATION
IS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE GET
REAL COALITION MY COMMENTS
ARE DIRECTED TO ITEM NUMBER
FOR EXPANSION OF THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION CENTER
GREAT GRANT THE ANNUAL
UNFULFILLED DEMAND FOR SIX
SEATED GRANT DEMONSTRATE THE
NEED FOR THESE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
THIS COMMITTEE HIGHLIGHTED
THE NEED FOR HIGH QUALITY CTE
PROGRAM PROGRAM DURING THIS
HEARING AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THE STRUCTURE OF
THIS GRANT AND INSURES THAT
THIS MONEY GOES TO HIGH QUALITY
CTE PROGRAMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
PLEASE EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF CGD
FUNDING FOR ALL K.
TWELVE STUDENTS
THANK YOU THANKS BAKER
THANK YOU HONEST CAROLINE
ONE ZERO SIX ONE OF
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ANN HAWTHORNE I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES UNITED METHODIST URBAN
FOUNDATION AND OUR KIDS THE
PROGRAM -- I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT ON THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO REQUIRE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO CONFIRM
THAT ALL HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
COMPLETE A FAST OR A DREAM ACT
APPLICATION OUR KIDS SHOULD
BE PROGRAM PROVIDES SUPPORT
TO HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT IN HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR THE SEPTIC LEAK
OR APPLYING TO COLLEGE BUT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN WE HEAR FROM
STUDENTS THAT THE MAIN REASON
THEY DO NOT WANT TO APPLY TO
COLLEGE IS A FAIR CONCERN ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY WHEN STUDENTS
FILL OUT BUT BASS SAID THEY
LEARNED ABOUT ALL THE FINANCIAL
AID THAT CAN BE AVAILABLE TO
THEM AND THEN THEY DO MAKE
THAT DECISION TO GO AHEAD
AND APPLY TO COLLEGE FOLLOW
PROGRAM CAN HELP A HUNDRED OR
TWO HUNDRED MAYBE EVEN THREE
HUNDRED STUDENTS APPLY FOR
THE PAST BUT -- FOR THE DREAM
ACT THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS WHO WERE NOT ABLE
TO REACH BUT WHO WOULD APPLY
TO COLLEGE IF THEY WERE AWARE
OF THE AVAILABLE FINANCIAL
AID SO I URGE YOU TO --
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
FIND ONE OH NINE YOU ARE OPEN
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL
MCCORMICK SUPERINTENDENT IN THE
PROPER UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE PASSWORD KATEH COMPLETION
I WONDER WHAT YOU KNOW WERE
IN TRAINING OUR FOURTH YEAR
OF HAVING COMPLETION THE
NEEDS IN AND PASSWORD CATA IS
A GRADUATION REQUIREMENT AND
IT'S -- IT'S IT'S BEEN GREAT TO
REMOVE THE NUMBER ONE BARRIER
FOR STUDENTS AS THEY -- PROCEED
ON THE PATH TO THEIR DREAMS
OF COLLEGE ASPIRATIONS AS A
RESULT OF THIS REQUIREMENTS --
ARE EIGHT THREE G.
COMPLETION RATES FOR UP TO
SIXTY TWO POINT SIXTY SEVEN
POINT TWO OUR OUR COLLEGE GOING
RATE IS INCREASED TO SIXTY
SEVEN PERCENT WE'VE PARTNERED
WITH A LOCAL GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S TRUST AVAILABLE FOR
OUR NEXT STATUS FAMILY AND
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES THIS IS
BEEN ONE OF THE GREATEST THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE FOUR EQUITIES
-- IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
I'D REALLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO THINK ABOUT SYSTEMATIC
APPROACH ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT INSURERS
THAT THERE'S NO LONGER FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
LEFT UNCLAIMED ON THE TABLE
THE INVESTMENT ISN'T THERE NOW
LET'S MAXIMIZE THAT INVESTMENT
BY HAVING A SYSTEM IN PLACE
TO GUARANTEE FAST FOR CATA
COMPLETION THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
ONE OH WAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES HELLO MY NAME IS TO PRETEND
-- I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF STEP ONE SCHOOL IN BERKELEY
-- A HIGH QUALITY SO THEY
YEAR ROUND CHILD CARE PROGRAM
-- I'M SPEAKING AGAINST THE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO -- I
DID NOT HEAR IT SPOKEN ABOUT
TODAY BUT I COULDN'T HEAR ALL
FIVE HOURS OF THE MEETING SO
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU COVERED IT
TODAY BUT I HAVE THREE POINTS
-- DISABILITY NOT GOOD FOR
FAMILIES FAMILIES ARE WANT CHOI
THEY WANT A HIGH QUALITY EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROGRAM THAT COMES IN
MANY DIFFERENT FORMS IT'S NOT
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL -- THE TIME
OF LIFE AND THAT NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED NUMBER TWO IT IS NOT
GOOD FOR THE EMPLOYED WOMEN OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF
COLOR -- THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN MASSIVE JOB LOSSES -- AND
WOMEN WHO WON'T CHOOSE TO ADOPT
TO ADAPT TO A GOVERNMENT RUN
PROGRAM WILL FIND THEMSELVES
OUT OF THE JOB NUMBER THREE
IF THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT
COULD HURT CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
-- MY PROGRAM OF OVER TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO PIVOT
CHIU AND INDEPENDENT OF THE
PROGRAM -- WITH ABOUT FOUR
YEAR OLD CHILDREN GOING TO
GOVERNMENT RUN PROGRAMS THAT
THAT SHOULD TURN ON INVESTMENT
FOR CALIFORNIA IS JUST SUPPORT
AND EXPAND OF THE CURRENT NEXT
DELIVERY SYSTEM WHICH IS --
HOW IT WAS DESCRIBED IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S MASTER PLAN A
VERY IMPORTANT DOCUMENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PLEASE UP PRESS ONE ZERO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
I WISH YOU CHAIR THIS IS FRED
JONES I'M PART OF THE GET
REAL COLLECTION THAT YOU'VE
HEARD A COUPLE OF MY PARTNERS
TESTIFIED EARLIER SOMEONE
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THAT
PATENTLY ACTIVE CULTURAL
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
JERRY JEREMY SMITH OF STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATRICK
MCDONNELL'S EFFORTS TO GET MORE
IS BADLY NEEDED SIGNS INTO THE
CORNER TECH BUDGET PATIENTS
AT THE DOUBLE WHAT AMOUNT YEAH
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT ADVENTURE
FROM HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IT'S STILL
WILL NOT BE ENOUGH TO COVER ALL
OF THE ALLEGATIONS DEMANDS OF
THIRTY DOLLARS BUT WE CERTAINLY
THINK THIS IS THE YEAR TO DO
IT SO WELL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AFTER THE BOMBS REQUEST
APPEAR COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU I KNOW
MISTER CHAIR I APOLOGIZE
ARE WHITE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MY NAME'S
DAVID GOOD GROWING PRESIDENT
SMALL MANUFACTURERS INSTITUTE
AND TODAY I WANTED TO -- PUTS
MY MARKS ON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA METALS COALITION
GROUP CLOSER ON THE BOARD AND
WE APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN
LISTENING ALL DAY AND AT THE
-- IT'S GREAT THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING BUT
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE BUTROS STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
AND GRADUATION IMPROVEMENTS
WE THINK THAT THERE'S JUST
GONNA BE CONTINUAL MARGINAL
OUTCOMES WITHOUT MAKING CTE
CLASSES IS A MANDATORY FOR A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS THE
FUNDING FOR THE C. T.
PROGRAMS HAS BEEN -- TRAGICALLY
LOW OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
AND AND WHEN YOU CAN LOOK AT
THE FEDERAL PERKINS FUNDING
THAT CERTAINLY HAS BEEN KEPT
UP WITH INFLATION OVER A TWENTY
YEAR PERIOD IMPACTED -- BUYS
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
LESSEN IT DIDN'T SAY NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE -- THIS KIND OF
REINFORCES WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
-- GALLAGHER SAID EARLIER BARS
ON THE PERCEPTION AND STATUS
OF CP IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
PROBABLY AND -- WE ACTUALLY
WOULD URGE YOU TO THINK KIP
FIGURE WITH THE FUNDING LIMITS
OF BUT AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE
WHICH WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE FUNDING THAT HAS COME
OUT TO THIS GRANT PROGRAM YOU
KNOW IT'S REALLY KEPT THIS
CRITICAL AREA OF SKILL AND
AND INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
FROM FURTHER DECLINE -- BUT
SADLY THE FUNDING IS REALLY
A DEMONSTRATION OF PUBLIC
COMMITMENT AND WE HAVE A LONG
WAYS TO GO TO HAVE EQUALITY FOR
STUDENTS TO LEARN DIFFERENTLY
THAN TRADITIONAL DIGITAL
LEARNERS AND THIS IS A A
CULTURAL SHIFT THAT WILL NEED
TO TAKE PLACE TO KILL C.
T. PROGRAMS -- EQUAL STATUS
WITH EIGHT KEY PROGRAMS AND SO
WE WANT TO SUPPORT IT -- AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
THIRTY NINE AS A SEPARATE IS
REALLY -- YOU KNOW THE BEST
GAME IN TOWN TO KIND OF KEEP UP
AND WE APPLAUD THE SPONSORS FOR
THEIR EFFORTS -- BUT WE NEED
TO DO SO MUCH MORE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE NEXT SPEAKER
PLACE THAT WE WERE GOING TO
THANK YOU WILL -- EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANKS TO THE
HEAD GOOD AFTERNOON HOW HIGH
UP YOU HAVE TO THE CORRECT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY COALITION HERE
TO SPEAK ON ISSUE NUMBER FOR
THE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CENTER GRAND AT THE REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM WITH
CENTERS OUR COALITION MEMBERS
BUDGET SIGNIFICANT RELY ON
THE STATE'S COMPETITIVE AWARDS
FOR CTP AND AN INCREASE THE
TYPICALLY WILL GO ALONG WAY
KEEPING OUR PROGRAM BAKALY
FUNDED THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS WITH
THE SKILLS AND EDUCATION THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY ECONOMY
SHOULD THE CONVERSATION AROUND
TT TODAY WE APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
EXPRESSED INCREASING ANNUAL
ALLOCATION PRETTY TAKE THE
CIVIC WE ARE COALITION SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DONALD
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE FUNDING
TO THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY BEGINNING WITH THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO STATE
BUDGET WE ALSO SUPPORT A FAMILY
MEMBER MCCARTY AT THE NOVEMBER
GALLAGHER'S RECOMMENDATION THE
PRIDE HE TAKE INDICATED CALLED
SOPHOMORE COURSE PROGRAM WITH A
COLA NEITHER OF THESE PROGRAMS
THAT RECEIVED A CALL THAT THEY
WERE ESTABLISH OF ON GOING
PROGRAMS IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STATE BUDGET ACT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAVE COMMENTS
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT CENTERS PLAYED EVERY
TEACHER STUDENT AND INDUSTRY
PARTNERS TOGETHER TO PROVIDE
A WELL TRAINED PIPELINE OF
TALENT FOR CALPERS WORKFORCE
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU ON ENSURING
THAT OUR STATE HE T.
PROVIDERS ARE ADEQUATELY
FUNDED TO CONTINUE THIS
EXCEPTIONAL WORK THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE
AND OUR FINAL QUESTION
WILL COME OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL COME FROM LINE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
I KNOW EIGHTY SIX IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE
-- PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN
OKAY ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FINAL SPEAKER I THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES BUT YOU OKAY THAT'S
NOT A COLLECTIVE DOES NOT
ACCUSE SORRY MR CHATS OKAY
WE'LL SEE YOU NEXT TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND WITH THAT
WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU